foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome everybody to more coverage from
the feed a World Cup and Women's World
Cup I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me today the friendly face of
Grandmaster Ben Feingold Ben rest day
yesterday how are you feeling about
today's round with 32 action in the
World Cup and the round of 16 action in
The Women's World Cup
no this is this is awesome because uh
the cream has risen to the top and the
players are getting so strong now
winning those matches they even got a
better co-commentator with me so that
was I mean I couldn't believe Danny
fired himself but you put you put the uh
the Hess in chess and you were just in
Sochi so I think I guess you didn't have
a rest day
yeah those uh days of travel or anything
but rest days especially with screaming
kids on your flight for 10 plus hours
but no big deal either way I'm happy to
be here with you Ben and it's just such
a fun event I've seen your coverage it's
been awesome and of course following all
the games very closely the players are
do letting their move to the talking for
them mm-hmm yeah I guess there were a
lot of Americans who lost on your flight
as you said screaming kids no put me
back there I want to win
uh well unfortunately only one winner
can take home this competition and we
have yet to figure out who that will be
but why don't we remind everybody of
what we have going on here what this
tournament is like it is an eight round
knockout tournament the players are
paired against each other in two game
matches one with each color that's in
classical time control of 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves followed by 30 after
move 40 and then 30 second increment
from the very first most that way if
you're in time trouble every single move
you make you gain 30 seconds of your
clock you can rebuild your times that
you do not flag but Ben I think you know
besides the format which everyone should
be familiar with there's some huge story
lines from the previous round and I mean
that what did you think when you saw
Anish Geary Fabiano caruana and even
chakra or mamajar have eliminated yeah I
was actually surprised at all three
obviously we expect Fabi to get to the
semis of the finals
um and I figured when Mom and jarov won
game two on demand in the slow chest
that you know that was
that wasn't going to be good for Marta
rosian but but yeah that that guy really
showed a lot of class and he played
really well and it was I'm still
surprised and I guess as Magnus said you
just can't be surprised at anything
because it's too gay match and all the
players are really good and a lot of the
players are underrated
um because of covet a lot of people
haven't had their feed a rating go up in
a while because they haven't played any
events so he said some of these kids
like you know 2550 you know cinderov is
2700 strength so it's um it's an amazing
event because there's so many upsets I
think a lot of that is what Magnus said
players are underrated and some of it is
they're two game matches so it's a
little more luck than usual but it's
really exciting for the spectators
there's always a good game to look at
and there's almost always going to be an
upset and we're going to learn who the
players of the future are when these
teenagers are beating everybody
that's definitely true I think most
surprising thing for me is that middle
part of the graphic there that Magnus
Carlson is alone above 2800. we've known
Fabiano caruana above that rating far
above it for so many years now ever
since he won the sinkfield cup in 2014
starting with seven straight wins he was
almost 28.50 at that event and he's been
well above 2800 for the past seven years
and yet now after losing to renat
jumabayev he is below that threshold
dingley run also just a point below it
so Magnus Carlsen sits alone above 2800
I can hardly believe the sentence that
comes out of my mouth there
yeah I guess it's hard when you're when
you're one of the top three players in
the world to keep your rating because
you gotta you gotta get plus scores all
the time against the best players in the
world and Magnus has been able to
achieve that for over 10 years but it's
hard for the other players to keep the
20 and 100 ratings
um
yeah I guess
if I was 2800 I would be under it I
guess five seconds later even without
playing so I mean that's it's tough to
do
um but it is surprising that he's the
only one yeah and it just goes to show
how dominant he's been in the world of
chess for so many years now and we'll
see if he's able to get through his very
tough opponent in this round of course
his previous matches were against Grand
Masters very strong players but we're
getting into fratislavoy tachek a former
2750 rated player still around 2700 So
the matches will continue to be
difficult but for now Ben I think you
and I have to go on a very quick break
so we can get everything in order for
the start of the round everybody you
will not want to miss the action as it
begins from the fide World Cup and
Women's World Cup
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
getting ready to start Magnus adjusting
every single piece Ben are you one of
those adjusters before the games begin
or what's your sort of habit yeah I
don't necessarily adjust every piece I
probably have but I just make sure my
Knights are facing the way that I like
which nobody I was gonna say nobody else
likes but they're both doing it they're
they're facing this way most people like
them to face out yeah but they both have
their Knights facing sideways that's
what I do interesting I think that says
a lot about a player because Knight's
facing forward it's the aggressive
players who want their Knights to start
jumping into enemy territory and here
you see the clocks are uh pressed and
here we have the first moves of the game
yeah Magnus is adjusting the pieces and
himself he's like get his shirt ready in
his pants he sat down at the board with
a mask then he took it off he wanted his
opponent to see who he was yeah
you weren't familiar
well that has happened at events like
the world rapid and Bliss wasn't there a
famous example of like borstaff chenko
sat and like made a move against Magnus
and he was at the wrong board yeah so
there's a funny video of uh
or maybe it's a picture I think it's a
video where crab Nick's playing in an
open tournament for the first time in
his life and he doesn't know who his
opponent is so he looks at the thing
with the placard and goes okay
who's my fault
oh gosh can you that's very funny in
this day and age easy to Google it but
back then you don't have the phones just
to whip out and check who your opponent
might be but we have something weird is
happening because the players are both
looking away like something's happening
that means the opening came unexpectedly
and Magnus decides against this Catalan
opening to play D5 we see Bishop G2
temporarily giving up this Pawn on C4
but white always has Queen A4 check to
this King on E8 to win back that pawn if
you want to play this variation so of
course the both layers are very
experienced in such a line but I I I'm
not bad am I reading too much into that
looking away sort of indicates to me
that one the players is surprised by the
opening choice right I thought they were
looking at something like there was a
brouhaha in the playing Hall but
probably not but yeah they're both
looking away right yeah definitely Eric
Rosen being distracting taking the
photos he's always doing that I told him
to stop that
well we can actually look across the
playing Hall as the opening moves are
made many
you know many players there just
settling in it just looks normal yeah
nothing funny is happening yeah nothing
at all well hopefully nothing funny does
happen that the players can just let
their moves uh do the talking of course
there have been some strange events
already in the World Cup players who
have unfortunately had to Forfeit
because of uh covered related issues but
I think we're at the point of the term
and hopefully with uh you know all the
precautions being taken that everyone
can just let the games settle their
matches
and yeah Magnus is looking away a lot
yeah I wonder which variation do I play
and they both are looking away now so
something must be happening in the
terminal
are they Frozen no they're Magnus goes
oh yeah that's funny how they both look
away yeah A5 what what
he he's throwing in in early A5 I guess
just to
I don't know what
that's the secret illegal preparation
that move is often useful if white goes
B3 right if white plays B yeah you can
go A4 but it does feel like a move
that's quite committal because sometimes
you do that Palm back on A6 to cover the
B5 Square so yeah Ben you're caught
really off guard by this
um it seems like it's been played a
couple dozen times I'm looking at the
opening Explorer here and B3 is the most
common response to A5 which is he was
thinking should I save this for the
World Championship now I'll just play it
now
you know that that is a difficult thing
right for both Magnus and Jan when he's
playing events it's like well what do I
do because every player that I'm facing
off against here is an extremely strong
player you can't just play whatever you
want you'll get roasted so
um he plays A5 which is a legitimate
line and now it's we're touching on the
clock trying to figure out do I go for
B3 or the second most popular move which
is Knight to C3
yeah because of all these these new
engines and AI everybody just pushes
their side pawns now
A5 H5 H4 that's all they're doing
and Magnus agrees I do understand the
move though I I it is a flexible Choice
it allows you to sort of worry your
opponent in the event of B3 which is the
most commonly played idea and so that
you can play A4 to make your Rook useful
where it is I think oftentimes people
feel I need to activate my Rooks they
try to move their Rooks to the center
but especially in Catalan style
positions the center doesn't really open
up so I I do see the merits in such a
move
yeah the the drawback I guess is often
black is playing A6 and B5 so I think it
makes it harder to play B5 but I I guess
um you know this is his preparation and
that's that's what he's doing I mean
it's not not only is it not a bad move
but now uh his opponent is gonna think
forever
that's one advantage
unless you're playing Alexander grishok
your opponent thinking forever is
typical that's just normal yeah right uh
so if Watashi goes and sits and thinks
maybe we can go to another game that I'm
finding kind of interesting not one of
the biggest names not one of those
matches in tournament but Etienne bakrow
taking on uh pankratov I just caught
this game at the corner of my eye and
Ben it's a French and it's one of my
favorite lines in the French where when
the bishop pins the Knight on C3 it's
not just attacking the Knight but the E4
Pawn is undefended because the Knight is
pinned and here we see Buckroe play
Knight to E2 which does not defend the
pawn on e4 but does defend the Knight on
C3 with the other Knight so do you have
any experience in this variation Ben
yeah I used to play the French with
black when I was a teenager that's
basically all I played so I I faced 92
now and then and
um
in this match when I saw it on paper
yesterday I was like
black crow has to be the favorite and I
noticed his opponent was higher rated
but I I didn't believe it so yeah I mean
but Crow was was a grand master and he
was about 13 and he got to 2700
relatively quickly and he just never got
his rating over 27.50 or so he just sort
of hung around the mid 2700s low 2700s
and I'm a big fan of a crow I think uh
you know he he's better he's better than
his rating
um he has a lot of experience he's
played Grand Masters and super Grand
Masters for over 20 years
so but yeah I know that uh Knight E2
seems like a movie with like uh Robert
in other words because it's not Mainline
Theory it can catch your opponent off
guard which it seems to be doing in this
game and about bakro he is the main
second for Maxine Buster Legrand so he
probably has quite a number of opening
tricks up his sleeve I'm just not sure
what he's allowed to use what that
agreement is like that's right the
second and the player because you come
up with all these Novelties and cool
opening discussions and then you're not
allowed to use them yourself because
yeah it's a risky decision by pancreasa
because he's playing the French against
the Frenchman so
some kind of reverse psychology yeah
next time I guess uh Etienne has to play
the Russian defense when he gets the
black pieces exactly but here here
politics E4 is the most popular move it
seems to win upon on the spot white
typically plays A3 hitting the bishop on
B4 that's pinning the Knight and if the
bishop moves back you get to take on e4
but if Bishop takes C3 Knight takes C3
and say Pawn to F5 some people think let
me just latch on to my extra Pawn this
gets very dangerous for black because
the king is still in the center and when
lines start opening up and this bishop
eventually goes to C4 this Pawn can go
to F3 to open up more files the king
doesn't find true shelter very often in
this line
yeah when I had black when I was a
teenager I would play Bishop E7 and give
the pawn back but I think some people
take and play Knight C6
yeah instead of uh I think maybe taking
is more common now
it is on C3 yeah it's becoming
increasingly common because you have
engines that can help you in your
preparation to deal with some of the
ensuing threats but Ben you're right
that Bishop E7 is the most popular move
giving back the pawn in the center and
saying well what's your knight doing on
E2 you probably want your knight on F3
to get out of the way of the bishop run
F1 right this is a strange variation
where I think black is quite solid and
you just need to make sure that you have
all your lines in order because this is
safer and I think pankaratov will
eventually go for it but if he's willing
to venture into more tactical variations
he will as you said take on C3 and play
Knight C6 first to attack the pawn on D4
and then white can play Bishop to B5 for
example and it's really a complex
position and based on punk rock's early
time usage I'm not sure if he knows the
ins and outs right it seems like a good
a good surprise opening uh from Etienne
right and
well Bishop E7 was in fact played and so
I think we're getting the more solid
approach in the French and I would
acknowledge the night being misplaced on
you too that's really the the main thing
white got this A3 move thrown in because
typically in Bishop E7 lines the bishop
goes there directly but it has come with
the benefit of leaving this Knight in
front of the bishop 101 so I think that
black is totally fine thus far
um
and yeah it's not it's not an exciting
new variation but it just gets his
opponent out of his pre-game prep
exactly and I was hoping for excitement
but we didn't quite get that I'm looking
across the games Ben so if you see any
particularly fascinating opening stages
do let me know I'll gladly go on over to
that game I see a sharp Sicilian in the
matchup between Duda and edani so that's
well known Theory but yeah I'm not I'm
not really familiar with uh Donnie I he
seems good but uh
all these people that I I barely knew
before the event uh I guess I'm gonna
know them now
indeedani a very strong player from Iran
it's it's interesting because sometimes
the up and comers or the established GMS
who just aren't quite as highly rated as
the top players in the country get
overlooked because Iran had alireza
farooja before he transferred to France
Parham and then even in this tournament
there's Amin tabatabai amongst other
participants and yet here is idani in
the round of 32 playing against super
Grandmaster polish superstar John
Christoph Duda and Ben as I just opened
the Explorer here based on the opening
Rook G1 there's been one game and Rook
G1 has been played so both players seem
to be in their preparation based on the
lack of time consumption when these
positions get wild really quickly and
well which side would you rather have
that's right
um I mean if Matt Larson's watching I'd
rather have black but he's probably
asleep now he's on the west coast so now
I could say that I I would prefer white
in this position
um but yeah Iran has a lot of really
strong players and as you know I coached
at the world Youth and Cadet for several
years and Iran was killing it they had
every section they had some of the top
players and it's not surprising you know
their fourth fifth sixth best players
I'm not that familiar with but that
they're really good
this is a very sharp position where
probably the theoretical knowledge of
the players is ending around now and
as you said it's a very sharp position
opposite side castling
um white has the open G file black has
the open BNC files white has the two
Bishops and you could argue
um if nobody gets mated that the the D
and the a pawns are weak for black so
maybe in the long run
um if things settle down White's going
to have some targets and black will be
fighting for a draw but it seems like
there's going to be some attacking going
on
yeah that's my read of the situation as
well that both sides are going to
challenge each other's Kings I'm not
entirely sure how and maybe we can
quickly go through the opening just to
show everybody this Sicilian Defense
because this is well known at the top
levels where essentially black throws
some Queen side pawns white throws the
king side Pawns in early E5 in this
night or fear the Knight drops back to
B3 and this opening you can look it up
uh in game explorers yourselves
everybody who's watching but this is
typically what happens in these lines
White Castles Queen side after black
king side and you see the pawns go G4 B5
G5 B4 and the reason you get away with
this is that after Pawn takes F6 Pawn
takes C3 hits the queen here and very
important that this king is on C1 not on
B1 Ben I'm sure you've had students try
this kind of thing when the king is not
on C1 and then they just live again yeah
Matt Larson is a big Authority on this
particular position we've analyzed it a
lot years ago and you know he had a
couple Novelties much much later and he
actually he actually has good results
with black although he doesn't think uh
you know
black should have anything and I think
he still prefers white but this is this
is what he plays and he he knows a lot
so
yeah you need to know a lot If You're
Gonna Play yeah
that's for sure and I just to show
everybody the points after gf6 bc3 the
queen took on C3 because it politics E7
Pawn takes D2 is with check you see
always play King B1 exactly that's why
the king would love to be on B1 because
then you could just take the queen back
and go up a piece so in the game uh we
saw Queen C3 Knight F6 and this is known
where you get the bishop pair but bring
your knight into C6 hitting the Queen
the bishop and this is still familiar
territory and if I'm not mistaken the
move Rook G1 was just played and
the only game that I can see here was
Rook F to C8 which is a pretty logical
move but I wouldn't be surprised if here
hidani for the first time he chooses a
new move yeah a lot of times when I was
working with Matt on the openings like
this one I would say something like yeah
there's two games in my database with
this and there's four with that and he'd
always come back with in my
correspondence database blah blah blah
blah blah I'm like I don't got that so
he's like oh yeah that opening is
refuted because of this correspondence
game I'm like what so his his opening
preparation was a lot better than mine
but somehow I still got paid
that's that's how you know you're doing
it right that's right yeah
and the correspondence games are
important to look at especially in this
day and age because people spend a lot
of time working through various openings
and positions and you can learn a lot
from those games where it may not be
just a human against human so some of
the decisions may seem out of the grasp
of you know we mere mortals but it will
be helpful especially in the opening
stage and believe it or not move 20 is
still the opening stage for many of
these top players
all right now Robert trivia time for you
what do you and Matt Larson have in
common that's not chess related we went
to the same University that's right both
graduated Yale and he's at Stanford now
but uh you know getting a graduate
degree yeah you yield he's all know each
other Joel Benjamin yeah I passed your
exam that's all that's important to me
that's right yeah you know everything I
can't trick you I think you can and you
will but for now I'm doing okay here
yeah
so do you agree that with me that you'd
rather have white here or is it too
crazy
these positions I tend to believe John
Christoph Duda but then there are some
games where he goes absolutely Bonkers
and I like well you're 27.50 what was
that game but that's just his style so I
at first glance definitely like why you
make great points about the D6 Pawn
being a Target the A6 Pawn also being
isolated and potentially vulnerable but
then I look at how solid Black's
position is so it feels like black
should be able to eventually punch
through a D5 move or something like that
and I look at the number of Pawn Islands
black has two Pawn Islands right just
the A6 pawn and the D6 to H7 those two
separate Pawn ons and white has three
and that could mean some of White's
Pawns in fact are a bit loose so I
generally speaking prefer the bishop
pair I think that Black's King doesn't
really look like it's in too much danger
you can always push this Pawn to G6 to
close down the G file whereas White's
king is not in true danger but I don't
really see how white is intending to
make clear-cut progress
you know I think black always has to be
cognizant of
when pieces get traded how that affects
the resulting position when nobody's
getting mated
and sometimes that's going to be good
for white because of his plan majority
on the queen side into Bishops and
sometimes as you said if blackheads D5
in then black black looks pretty okay
that's really the kind of undercurrent
of the position is the pawn structures
they've highlighted here as you're
saying the three on two that sometimes
just allows white to create an Easy Pass
Pawn if we throw the Queens off the
board if we can Envision that then white
Pawn just start marching up the board it
actually seems yeah anan's always doing
that in these positions he always gets
Queens off and makes a lot of pass Bonds
on the queen side he's just a magician I
never understand how it happens I'm
always like these are complicated it's
like yeah not too complicated Queen's
gone let's just win the game but it's
going to be a while before I think black
even makes a move which means very
likely that idani is out of his
preparation and he's trying to figure
out this position for the first time
um all right I know you're a Jeffrey
Zhang fan um you just read my mind
is that exactly what you were thinking
Gojo yes yeah no well
you probably are going to receive some
backlash because Jeffrey Zhang as we
will go over there he is playing against
vidit Gujarati so the many video fans
I'm sure in the chat right now welcome
everybody and we had what looks to my
eyes like a London system but a London
system that's been turned on its head
because this is not how I normally see
these games develop
yeah I've never seen that position but
you know looks like both sides are
playing very reasonably yeah right the
initial development of the pieces Queen
B6 just trying to be a bit more
aggressive against the D4 and B2 pawns
and Rook B1 says you're attacking
nothing but takes Queen takes C5 and
Bishop D3
and I feel like this is the way players
uh go for the London these days they
don't mind this double Pawn on F4 and F2
because they said that I have great
control over the side of the board even
if my pawns are stacked
yeah I mean it looks like if you trade
on F4 it reminds me of a lot of these
slots positions except you know white
has the sloth position with with what
and he's up like two or three Tempe from
uh you know assuming he was playing the
sloth with black
um because yeah white black loses the
tempo because he's black and he's moved
his Queen a few times and yeah White's
has a big lead in development control of
E5 it's hard to believe white has an
advantage but I mean I I'm guessing this
is this is probably prep
yeah and I would say one big thing that
leaves white slightly better is the
quality of the Bishops right this bishop
on right D3 is a very strong piece the
bishop on C8 not clear where that's
going to go oftentimes you just want to
trade it for the superior bishop and if
you trade on squarely A6 then white gets
an even
better grasp of the central scores E5
and D4 so I agree with you Ben I'm not
really seeing the biggest early stage
Advantage for white but I think that it
just becomes more difficult for black to
come up with a plan and that's what
Jeffrey likely is relying on yep
yeah this is a pretty even match up I'm
not sure even on paper who's the
favorite
it's
they're they're pretty equal in strength
I think yeah I was just trying to
come up with one a name I'm just gonna
say somebody then I realized I don't
know how to differentiate between them
uh it looks like they did it a little
bit higher rated classical chess of
course the pandemic has meant you know
over the board tournaments Jeffrey is
several years younger but that it's
still a young player himself and well it
did just Outlast adibon in a really
nerve-wracking type that was a great
match yeah right and that shows that he
can bat with the best of them in those
quicker time because whereas Jeffrey
quite renowned for his rabbit and Blitz
skills as well I just don't know how to
choose to toss up
thank you
yeah this has been a tough event for a
lot of people it's sort of like you know
in poker if you ask a professional
what's the worst day of the year it's
always the day you get knocked out of
the World Series of Poker that's the day
you don't like and obviously if you're
playing in a poker tournament or rarely
in a chess tournament that's a knockout
the worst days we could get knocked out
everybody gets knocked out except one
person so everybody's having a tough
tournament and the people who are left
they know that they can get knocked out
any rounds
um and that's that's going to be a hard
pill to swallow so just making it round
after round no matter how the match
actually goes if you got lucky or
something weird happened you're still
happy about it that's very true you
don't care if your opponent blundered a
queen like we saw Maxie matlikov do uh
in the previous tie break as long as you
make it through you're happy to be there
and well speaking of people who are
probably very happy to be through to the
next round let me go over to Juma bios
game because joom I have defeated the
world number two or maybe technically
world number three right now five out of
caruana and now junebag gets the white
pieces against another American player
in Sam Shanklin who I saw on Twitter
expressed relief to be through the next
round saying that arashenko actually
played the better the two in their match
at least that's according to Sam yeah I
agree with that and the game that Sam
won at the end after a thousand draws
um he was he was much worse or losing
that end game and uh it turned her on in
time trouble the queen and Juan ending
he was you know I think you have minor
pieces also he was he was lost and his
King ran all the way up the board that
got to the seventh and eighth rank his
Pawn was too strong and eventually he
won but that was a really hard-fought
match and there were a lot of draws that
could have gone either way
yeah and I think there's something a bit
sort of difficult about a match when you
played Juma Baya because he is not as
highly rated as other players you were
probably expecting if you beat arashanka
like shank brothers did to play Fabiano
caruana and now you're playing somebody
who's 26 37 on paper obviously Guinea
points throughout this tournament and is
clearly a really really difficult player
to knock out in this event so I think
that can be tricky for players
psychologically Ben where you get into
this mindset of I'm the favorite now I
should win this match and that could
actually pollute your thinking
yeah I I think Sam realizes that uh you
can't look at these ratings and trust
them because he's got a lot of the
people just play way better than the
rating so you just you just gotta play
your own game and and hope that you're
you're more skilled than your opponent
and not just expect that
yeah and Sam is renowned for his
knowledge of the openings he is a
theoretician through and through and the
fact that he's already spent about six
minutes and we're on move seven for most
people that's a normal
expenditure of time for Sam Shanklin
that indicates he was not expecting this
opening today and he may still be within
the framework of familiar repertoire but
he is not prepared specifically for this
game against renat and so let's go back
to the beginning Knight F3 I think
Knight C2 before anything happens is
unusual
but what's funny is this is not like an
atypical idea it is early to play Knight
C2 and probably a wise choice by
jumobile but it's not like retreating
the Knight back away from the center is
abnormal on the slightest right this is
a
an idea that you see black use in
grunfeld positions
yeah somebody like Shanklin might say I
have the black pieces so my theoretical
knowledge is going to be the most
aggressive tries for white and I know
how to meet all of them and if white
plays an innocuous move then I've
already equalized I don't have to
analyze that for hours so that's
probably why I play Knight C2 it's less
likely Sam has analyzed that a lot
compared to just White playing normally
yeah I think that's absolutely correct
and white can play Knight c three now go
to Castle kingside and I typically like
these positions from the white side I've
unfortunately had the black side of them
very frequently and what I don't like is
this bishop on G2 is an absolute monster
controlling the length and diagonal and
it's very difficult for black to strike
in the center because one of the typical
strikes is D5 which is not going to
happen now that you have three pieces or
sorry four if you include the queen just
barreling down at the square I I really
tend to like white in this it's funny
we're the same in that respect that I
like white but I'm always black in this
position and the truth hurts yeah and so
just playing the black side of this
position I almost never have a good time
with it right yeah it's no fun I I think
that black often puts like a queen A5
type of move and someone swings the
queen all the way over to H5 that's you
know a cool way to get your queen in the
game but still once you get to H5 you're
not gonna go Checkmate the white king
and I really do feel like white ends up
with the better position one thing I
think one instructive point Ben is that
many players would want to play E2 to E4
but white often refrains from doing that
because they want to keep this bishop
open on the diagonal and putting the
pawn E4 while it takes better control
over D5 you don't need that extra
attacker of that square so leaving the
bishop open is probably a better try
yeah it's sort of like white white has a
little bit more control over the white
squares in the center and doesn't really
have to do anything aggressive because
it's hard for black to
do anything that gets gets his pieces
out to active squares or attack anything
so that's why uh
that's why we we have black but we don't
like it precisely
um well Ben I'm just trying to go around
as much as possible glance at some games
is there any matchup that we should head
on over to
well probably something we haven't
looked at yet
um who's the most exciting let's see how
let's see how the gangster's doing
grishrock how much time he spent let's
check it out yeah I mean he's I mean to
me he's one of the you know the three
favorites left
so Magnus grishook and who's the third
uh mvl okay that's that's my three
favorites right now I'll give you three
different favorites tomorrow
oh you're just trying to maximize the
chances that you're correct I respect
that honestly and Grisha has only spent
15 minutes nine moves have been played
and the position is opened up for this
bishop on G2 the problem is if you
really want to open up you have to play
the move C4 which I think is a perfectly
good move but there's that risk of the
D3 Pawn being a total weakness so yeah I
don't know then C4 is tempting but it
also has that really obvious drawback
yeah I'm guessing that's why grishek has
used a lot of time by now he was
probably making sure after C4 he was
okay
as you know C4 is explosive you guys
have to watch out for that
you most certainly do and you take on C4
even though I just mentioned the D3 Pawn
it's not just about the pawn but the
square because if you don't take well
then white will gladly taken cv5 looks
pretty good yeah so d uh BC DC and then
this Knight comes over to B4 heading
into this Square here I don't know why I
put the red arrow but hey let's change
it to Blue I don't know we have choices
they're both good yeah yeah the knight's
trying to get into D3 but what happens
after like Knight E5 I just The Rook
honey it's not defended seems Wild
yeah I mean you can either sacrifice The
Exchange which looks wrong or he can I
guess just defend his night with either
his queen or his Bishop
you have to watch out for A3 that I'm
technically confused
because this Knight is defending that
night and if the night on C6 takes on E5
there could be Bishop takes B7 and then
take here and this Knight's hanging so
these positions need to be worked out
and I'm guessing that it works out okay
for black because if you do take on B7
and this Knight jumps into D3 do you
really want to take this rook in the
corner and when the queen takes this
whole diagonal is blacks there could be
a big attack there and white is
underdeveloped and it's going to be a
struggle to get all the pieces out
that's that's too interesting yeah
no but it's funny because a lot of the
people watching these matches who who
aren't the best players in the world
they ask questions like why doesn't
white just play like 95 or A3 and you
know Chris shook is analyzing you know
more deeply than we are because he
played the move and he's looking at the
forcing variations and he has a line
worked out that he thinks is fine for
black which probably is is several moves
along but I guess if black wants to be
safe he doesn't have to play Knight
before your variation he can play Knight
B6 or Knight C7 because that defends his
Rook that's a good point and then maybe
he's okay although you could still play
95.
so
and you can also see the problem or
potential problem with this is
structurally black has these split pawns
on the Queen Center even if I play a
calm move like B3 or something to that
effect or queen I don't know Queen E2
perhaps black is not happy about the
resulting Pawn structure so that's why
maybe he feels like he needs to go
dynamically so I think your point is a
very good one Ben is that when players
are spending a lot of time in the early
stage it's not just because they're
wasting time no there's so many
different possibilities here as you
mentioned 95 still is something to look
out for and you need to work through all
of them and not just hope that all is
going to be fine at the end you really
need to analyze concretely yeah and you
know there's they just put up on the
screen that grishek is the only top 10
player than Carlson's still in the event
that that's actually not why I thought
karishnik was one of the favorites it's
because Richard obviously is good in
slow chess like everybody else but he's
also really good at rapping and Blitz
I'm a big fan of griststruck when the
time control gets faster it's funny
because he plays super slow in slow
chess but when it's rapper or Blitz he
can play really fast if he has to he's a
three-time world Blitz Champion if I'm
not mistaken so there's some but we know
this Ben I mean they're players
obviously not the level of Alexander
Grisha but Alexander Ivanov for example
in the United States he is always in
time travel always has been and yet a
very good Blitz player
you know Robert uh I'm so old that I
remember Alexander Ivanov playing in
tournaments before delay an increment
existed and when they started using
um delay or increment like a US
Championship the players were all mad
they were like well this just means
Alexander Ivano is going to do better
like that's the only person that's going
to help and in the 1994 U.S Championship
which was my first one Alexander Ivanov
lost five games on time
wow because there was no increment or
delay and in one of them he played 18
moves of theory in a dragon against
Boris kryman and he lost on time on move
23.
and he was like plus one but he just
can't move he just can't do it but you
know a 30-second increment
now he's hooked up so
yeah that's uh the change of the whole
game he lost five games on time in the
1994 yeah yeah wow
yeah that's that's bad he lost a lot of
games on time before increment And Delay
existed
I I certainly believe that no my my
favorite quote
um I think I think kaidenov told me but
it was one of the one of the top
American players who came from the
former Soviet Union said Alexander
Ivanov is karpov
except carpop's not crazy
he thought he had the understanding of
Chess of karpov but he just won't move
yeah so if you don't move then you know
it's a very big backhanded compliment I
guess you know I thought it was a genius
but he just won't move right and then
when he has no time on his clock that's
not good yeah uh well speaking of Genius
is one game I just want to tune into
before we head to our first break is
this one between dubov and yasopenko do
both of the black pieces people have
been clamoring for dubov they love his
exciting games this is not one of the
most exciting positions I've seen Ben
it's very closed up here black needs to
figure out can I play D5 or does that
leave me structurally vulnerable with
these doubled e-pawns here and I don't
know I wish I was talking about a
different position when I see the names
yessa Panko and do love that's correct
yeah this isn't what we were hoping for
but sometimes when you have these uh
doll kinds of positions sometimes in 10
moves they're not Dull anymore so we can
hope for that that's true well we will
hold in our hopes for now we will be
taking a quick break and when we return
more from the fide World Cup and the
Women's World Cup coverage presented by
chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
chess.com is your exclusive twitch home
for the video feeds for this year's
World Chess Championship you will not be
able to watch the camera feed anywhere
else join us for the best coverage
around as we watch this year's players
an offending Champion Magnus Carlson and
Challenger yonda palmchi battle for the
title The World Chess championships
coming your way in November to chess.com
but for now well we don't have the world
championship but we do have the World
Cup we left you we just have been
speaking about Alexander grushrook
scheme with Anton core above instead of
C4 just a couple moves back A4 was
played carving out the C4 Square for the
night so this is going to be a more
strategic battle than a tactical one
then and I don't know I'd rather go
somewhere else in game we haven't looked
at yet because I do think that in the
near future the players are going to go
deep in Think Tank yeah and also this
game is probably not going to end
decisively that's your take it's going
to be a draw yeah
yeah it's pretty close position for now
and not an easy way to see how it opens
up but the C4 square at the very least
that's a nice one for this night
um has the night on D5 that's pretty
good too rich X pieces are fine there's
a positional disadvantage for black on
the queen side but I don't think it
matters as much as you know it gives
white an advantage probably just very
very slightly better for white I agree
and let's uh go to some games we have
not looked at yet I will we're just
during the break you and I were talking
about Abdul sitarov so let's check out
that game between
um
oh I clicked on the wrong game as soon
as I'm gonna do sitaro I clicked above
where I meant to
wait now where'd the game go
outside of it there it is that's the
game sounds like me doing it
abusatara with the white pieces against
vasif and Dora Bailey and this is a
strange looking position to my eyes Ben
where it's even material black has
developed absolutely nothing except for
the Knight that seems to have wandered
too far to C2
yeah this looks crazy and with based on
the clock times
um black knows it better than white does
but it looks very strange for black as
you pointed out
um it's funny whenever I'm playing in a
tournament and I get totally destroyed
by somebody I'm always rooting for them
later because I feel like maybe they're
better than I thought they were and then
when they do really well then I'm
pleased and durabiali is one of those
players in the world open two years ago
I got beat really badly and I was like
well he's not that good he shouldn't
beat me where I have no chance at all
but then when I see him doing well in
the World Cup I'm like all right I think
he tied for first in the his uh what was
it Azerbaijan the championship that's
right is that the right country that is
absolutely correct yeah so I mean
obviously durbiali is ridiculously
strong yes yeah I'm not sure who the
favorite is this match because
you know there's it's it's becoming a
place where there's no favorites anymore
unless you're like you know top 20 in
the world everybody's just really good
that's true abusotara probably a bit
underrated given his Youth and the fact
that he hasn't been able to play over
the board events at least not many of
them and this position then I'm still
trying to wrap my head around it black
has developed nothing but this Pawn on
D4 actually is quite a Target because if
you play Knight D3 then already the move
B5 potentially kicks The Rook away from
A4 and drops this very important Central
Pawn though we know from many different
types of Catalan positions you give them
Pawn but claim all the squares and the
queen side and you're still better for
white even if you're down material yeah
in fact Robert was was F6 the last move
because if it was I'm not saying it was
but if it was I'm confused why he didn't
oh no no okay that's a good point so
knife 3 was just playing let's actually
go through this because if it was he
could have played B5 so I'm I'm still
confused so okay early night jump Queen
trade being offered and this is
I think well-known position thus far
double pawns don't look very good but
you're ahead in development you have a
better Center your Center yeah
and castles to avoid the frequency too
all this makes sense Rook A4 so in this
position
oh oh the oh white hasn't played E4 yet
so B5 would be very risky with that c
Fawn all juicy yeah okay yeah that's
yeah the engine doesn't like that no I
think just a simple move like Rook A5
and yeah no I thought maybe the Palm was
already on e4 so I was like why do you
play F6 okay he's starting with F6 and
then E4 came and then of course of
course the move Bishop C8 is best of
course right just always retreat
and then after Knight F3 the bishop
comes back to E6 and hits this Pawn on
B3
yeah because Knight F3 really traps the
night we got to watch out for Rook C4
um
and just any move basically the Knight
on F3 I think then I had to go to F3 as
you said after Knight D3 B5 black might
just be winning material right and I
mean not abundantly clear if it's worth
it for black I mean clearly this is
prepped by your Bailey but I'm looking
at this like well even if I would go
Rook A5 let's say make takes here oh
actually I don't like Rook A5 because
I'm walking into a potential yeah but
there's almost nowhere to go yeah yes ah
if I go Bishop E3 you start taking all
my pawns yeah yeah and Black's playing
E5 soon and the puns attacked yeah
so this this is his idea but Knight F3
Bishop E6 right you stop The Rook C4 and
you also threaten the pawn and B3
yeah this seems like black knows the
opening better than white
um
so I don't I don't know if White's just
walking in the prep or he he wasn't
ready for this line
well I guess one of the questions I have
is if I just play Knight D2 the protect
the B3 Pawn so what's Black's idea the
Knight on C2 can't be attacked very
easily but I'm trying to figure out like
how you eventually do get it out like
let's have a knight to D2 so I'm
protecting my pawns that were under
attack
what's the yeah I'm wondering if I can
if black can put his Knight on B6 right
but I guess the Rook The Rook should be
relatively safe on A5
right so here
okay somehow it's funny how the knights
trapped and The Rook is almost trapped
everything
strangest the bishop on C1 is trapped
very strange position yeah this is
trapped here the Knight on C2 the bishop
on f8 strap yeah
but my dad used to say when he saw these
positions that both sides stand badly I
agree with him and then it's a statement
that I can concur with because I don't
know what's going on but I do know that
Dura Bailey's moving so quickly which
leads me to believe that he has mapped
this out and it's maybe not just
acceptable for black I think he's trying
to play for an advantage because White's
structure right now is compromised this
Pawn structure these Double B pawns
isolated weak and if you can't trap that
Knight on C2 well what are you gonna do
yeah the Knight actually does some good
on C2 yeah trapped on a good Square
it's keeping the Rook at a fourth Bay
puts pressure on D4
uh uh and you know it looks like if
black ever gets in a little trouble he
can either play Knight A6 or a59 you
know get the Knight to B4 the bishop can
move off of E6 and you can move the E
Pawn he has B4 controlled so it looks
like the knight's not gonna get trapped
and captured but it's it's hard to say
if if you don't know the position
already should white spend a lot of time
trying to win that night or should black
white forget about the night and just
improve his own pieces and hopefully not
lose his B Pawn and then his d-pawn
so it's it's difficult for white if you
haven't seen it before
yes uh I think that durabelly just
clearly outprepared his young opponent
and Abdul sitarov
is going to have to figure this one out
because his structure is worse that if
you drop the B3 Pawn that's just a free
Pawn Knight bd2 as we were just talking
about it looks normal but then your
Bishop 1 C1 can't develop and the Knight
on C2 is not going to get trapped so I
think this is
pretty brilliant stuff from the azeri
one of these their top players and if he
can get this with black big trouble for
abusotaro yeah the timing Advantage is
quite nice and obviously you know
Nordy as uh as uh Danny calls him uh you
know he you know he he knows that he's
been out prepared and it doesn't mean
that his position is bad it just means
his opponent knows the position already
he doesn't and his opponent has a
monster time Advantage when you have
white that's not what you're looking for
in the opening is your opponent now
prepares you you don't have an advantage
you know you're way behind on the clock
so it's some plus it's an unpleasant
feeling and we know we can see the
numbers as zeros because of course and
he has no he just put the move D5 he did
that's that's what happens when you when
you're a young player you play D5 yeah
and so what is the idea though if I just
I think you have to take there's no
question you have to take because if you
move your Bishops into F7 then Rook C4
is simply done right yeah you have to
take otherwise Rook C4 is good yeah so
what is his idea here
um
good good question he said just beep on
temporarily
um I mean I'm looking at E5 but I just
don't believe it I I can't believe it
yeah so because then Knight C6 even
that's just that yeah
what I'm guessing he has to take on D5
but I don't I mean that's that's a
strange idea because he's giving up a
pawn and his b-pawn is still attacked
unless you can just keep giving up Pawn
somehow and then this bottom B7 is a
clear Target yeah but I I don't really
believe in this either
this seems strange
no it's strange because he you know he
didn't think for an hour I mean those
kids don't do that but D5 is a very
committal move and it looks like that's
not a move that um vasif had uh
analyze beforehand
uh he he took it on D5 he oh he took
okay maybe he had yeah and one idea
though still is kind of minus this
pressure along the diagonal and the king
is still stuck in the center the bishop
can't develop so maybe white is just
trying to open the position up you know
exploit those deficiencies in Black's
position so even a move like Knight C3
Pawn takes E4 and I guess Rook takes E4
perhaps I can get away with something
like this and actually Evo bar is sort
of start creeping up there
oh that's confusing me it's going up and
then yeah maybe maybe
um the sacrificing pawns is right
because the bishop on G2 is open as you
said white has free development and you
know Black's position is a little
awkward yes
for example Bishop takes B3 your
Bishop's under attack you steal a pawn I
was already thinking about Knight D2 I
don't know where my rook's going to go
but this Pawn on B7 is quite loose
yeah that's right
in some positions you could play Rook
takes E7 track and just get two pawns
which is weird
I've never seen what that's so crazy
oh and I think that Bishop F7 is
actually a mistake because then Knight
to B5 not only threatens the fork on CC
yeah I mean Knight D6 yeah Black's
position is weird here yeah
but he's prepped this so he must have a
way to save this game
I like that we're looking at the two
players the ravioli looks like he's
confused and and uh syndrome looks like
he's you know he's confident
and so now they switched they don't know
what's going on but this chess is too
hard I guess Ben one of the important
questions is you know bluffing in chess
where you Blitz out some opening that
objectively may not be good for black it
seems like according to the current
position we just have the eval bar on
the screen not the moves that says about
level and
I don't know it does dirt Bailey know
the ins and outs to the point where yeah
I can equalize and find the way through
or is he bluffing with some quick moves
that can catch an opponent off guard
make him nervous especially a youngster
like a booster of probably not a good
tournament to Bluff in
you got to watch it in these events
because your opponents can
even if they don't know the position
they can play pretty well
that's true you know when I was when we
were interviewing Magnus
um you know I was like and Grisha we
were like there's a lot of decisive
results here and in a lot of the online
tournaments where everybody's you know
29 million rated there's a lot of quick
draws this is a lot better what's the
reason for that and I think Magnus put
it really I think it was Magnus he said
you know the or maybe it was maybe it
was Russia they said that there's a
difference in ratings in a lot of the
matches so there's a more exciting play
you know it's there's not much at stake
when you're both 2 800 and the game is
not slow rated but here
the higher rated players have to be the
lower rated players and these guys in
particular like to play Crazy chess so
you get these really crazy games which
is a really refreshing after what we've
seen the last few months with so many
quick draws that are you know that
aren't really playing
yeah there is definitely an onus on
these top players to win games and
they're playing against very strong
competitors right you look at the likes
of a durability and abusatara
beating a 2650-ish Grandmaster on demand
no easy feat obvious so in a small
sample size of just two games that's why
you see these top players knocked out
whereas if there's a 10 game match then
of course I think pretty much every
single time the much higher rated super
Grand Masters would win those matches
but in two games definitely not the case
necessarily
it's funny I say onus a lot and I don't
didn't even go to Yale so there you go
your vocabulary I guess is yeah Stella I
mean I
different colleges the first clown than
Barber but I didn't learn very much
vocabulary so I'm trying all right
Sweeney Todd Sweeney that over here so
what you're gonna call me sweetie pie
but I guess that's reserved for Danny no
all right oh gosh I think Danny reserves
that for me not the other way around
so let's uh maybe head on over to the
Women's World Cup we have some excellent
matchups there so I'm going to
switch our attention this game between
ASO bayeva who is another young Talent
she beat her compatriot Sensei
abdumalique she also then uh won again
so she keeps knocking off higher rate of
players and now she has the black pieces
against Katarina lochno who is a
superstar in her own right and this
position I never know what's going on
Ben so I'm going to throw to you yeah
thank goodness yes yeah awesome so
obviously we have a poison fine Sicilian
and normally
uh both players are playing a lot of
theory and you get to move 2025 quicker
than you do in most openings and the
first person who has a big think is the
one who's you know less well prepared
but it looks like both players have
already been thinking and
uh generally when there's a lot of
theory I I bet on the younger player but
it's hard to bet against Lano because
you know she's so experienced and such a
tough opponent
um again as I mean it reminds me of the
other games where it's just so crazy we
don't see quick draws we don't know who
has the advantage and the position is
just a complete mess and generally the
younger players like that they like to
calculate and they like to put pressure
on their opponents and I think this is a
really good strategy with black is not
to play Passive and defensive and be
slightly worse and suffer I think it's
good to mix it up and put a lot of
pressure on your opponent of course if
you don't know the theory very well it's
going to end really quickly
but uh yeah this is these are positions
where you don't really use general
principles you you see what the engine
says you put your five engines on you go
to sleep you wake up and you're like
okay this is how you apply it because
it's just so complicated yeah I don't
think we're instructing any of our
students to play like this especially if
they're newer players because look at
how ugly the pawn structure is and the
good news for white is compared to some
other poison Pond versions you only have
one Pawn sometimes you're down like
three Pawns in a piece as Fabiano
caruana demonstrated against Maxine
Bashar the groove and the candidates but
how did we get here we know the poison
Pawn variation it involves this queen
for black hopping out to B6 and taking
this Pawn on B2 white allows it because
the claim is that while you've gone and
captured my Pawn spending three turns
with the queen look at how quickly I can
go and attack you and after the knights
were swapped on
C6 E5 was played so I'm trying to figure
out where the First new move was played
so Knight C6
if this opening Explorer database is
correct Knight C6 was actually a new
move by what's the old move it seems
that there are a bunch of games Bishop
to E7 developing the bishop protecting
the Knight makes sense Knight B to D7
and there even was a queen C5 Choice
yeah in this line so I think it's odd
that black plays a new move here and
after takes takes E5 goes into the tank
yeah that doesn't seem like a weird way
for white to play why is playing Super
aggressive well I think part of it is
right here so Bishop E2 is not a very
common move yeah I was saying Bishop B2
doesn't look like that's the main move
yeah E5 is just the immediate Pawn
thrust opening the position but Bishop
E2 you play a rare move you cast your
opponent off guard and then you get to a
position like this where you're both in
relatively new territory and figuring it
out for yourselves but Ben Knight D5
looks like V move to me because you
can't move your knight off the D file
you get checkmated right on d8 so Knight
D5 closing down the line here
how bad for black and this really be
it doesn't look like it's it's that bad
but uh
black has to be super careful because of
the huge lead in development that white
has and obviously if black survives you
know blacks up a pawn White's Pawn
structure is totally messed up and
that's why we love these positions and
that's why you have to be super well
prepared and this looks like maybe
as you said wano's Bishop E2 is like a
pet line that she hasn't played before
and her opponent is like Bishop E2
what's that because there's always so
many possible legal moves and as you
know against the night or if you know
even right after A6 they're playing
every legal move so just to throw black
off and you know if you throw your
opponent off and it's not bad and you
have it well prepared obviously that's
very advantageous even if the engine
doesn't say so you just know more about
it than your opponent that's true yeah I
guess I guess she's considering well she
she played it after I was going to say
she was considering whether to go Knight
D7 or Knight D5 obviously Knight D5
looks more natural yep and uh there it
is and one line I'm just calculating my
headband which shows that just because
you've castled doesn't mean your king is
safe I just want to put this on the
board real quick is that what's that
castle Bishop C5 check King H1 you
Castle saying my King's not centered yes
there's Rook B3 Queen A4 and queen takes
H six kind of ideas will work wow in
some positions not here but a move I
think that could work sorry yeah grab
the wrong piece Bishop F6 just uh
barreling through no that doesn't look
like a safe King not even a little bit
uh but the queen H6 line that I wanted
to play was if this bishop you know
could be on D3 you just think about it
where there's sometimes you just even
give up your queen and if this bishop
gets a D3 it would be winning the
problem is here the queen can interpose
on e4 right
would be such a beautiful Checkmate the
king drops back and you just yeah with
the Bishops
but many many tactics white should be
favored if the King goes to G8 and
that's what the players will have to
figure out here of course black isn't
going to walk into a mating attack so
after Knight takes D5 just to go through
that line again Bishop C5 check King to
H1 maybe Queen E3 Ben just to hope that
white black certainly wants to trade
Queens yeah
yeah just centralizing offering the
queen tree black is up a pawn your king
will be much safer if the Queen's come
off so I think that would be a better
way to play for black
no I agree and uh
did white white did play Knight takes D5
so yeah that's they always play the
moves you suggest is that good it's
better when you suggest it than I do so
I guess so
I guess Rook B3 was a very natural move
to hit the queen and protect the Knight
but then when Queen A5 happens you don't
want to trade queens and there's
pressure on C3 so
yeah these positions yeah if white can
keep the Queens on for a long time
White's gonna have a long-term attack
and probably a flag trades Queens black
is going to be fine
I agree is there any chance you'll take
with the epon or there's no chance
I mean she hasn't moved yet so
so there is a chance I will see yeah
because she hasn't moved yet yeah and
put the bishop on E6 for safety but
yeah I actually kind of like that yeah
yeah my first instinct is to take with
the c Pawn just to keep my structure
better but taking with the epon to open
the E6 Square for the bishop does feel
like a smart play
now this is a very difficult decision
yeah just recapturing is a tough
decision yeah
that's how tricky and complicated these
uh when I was avoid all of this either
color because I don't want to get in a
battle of you know did I prepare better
than my opponent I'm just I'm like you
like we just want to play chess and I
remember many years ago when you had
that match with Shanklin the US
championship
and you know you want to play chess but
he doesn't he just wants to play his
prep and then when his prep is over the
Arbiter has to come in and stop the game
and say who's winning yeah you're just
like can we just play chess yeah yeah
there was a forced repetition after like
25 moves or something I didn't know the
line he did and credit to him he works
very hard he's opening Theory and it
goes and it's quite extensive so it's
been paying off for him he's over 2700
but yes I am definitely prefer to just
make things up at the board which is
probably a moment where I said do as I
say not as I do study your openings
and we see on screen here that lock no
and grashook are the strongest chess
couple in the world yeah they are a
pretty powerful Duo both Grandmasters
both still remain
Sasha I'm trying to think if I can argue
with you but I think I can't because
there's another strong couple still left
um
it's Alina and I can't say her last name
uh kashinska there you go and she's
isn't she married to 2700 to avoit yeah
there you go that's that's close
unfortunately for them both lock no is
high rated than kishner I know but it's
close yeah it is I wouldn't if I had to
you know face off against either a
couple it would yeah that's not good
yeah so let's uh speaking of Alina we
should probably head on over to her game
we haven't checked out how that's going
and she's the black pieces against
Dinara saba castova and while I tend to
like these positions for white if you
don't get C5 in
I'm almost never happy about Black's
position so yeah but this looks like
this looks like if I knew you were
playing you'd probably have black
that's sadly true
which means that the position for black
is not particularly good
oh gosh you caught me there Ben and well
you know the brakes that are typical in
these positions are E5 and C5 you can't
play C5 because you're Knight's in the
way right you can play E5 but that
typically does not solve all of your
problems right especially with this Rook
on E1 and the Queen on E7 move like
Bishop D3 says hey give me an isolated
Pawn why don't you all right take on D4
I take back your Queen's under attack
you have a problem this way yeah Bishop
G5 is coming yeah that's not good Bishop
F5 Bishop G5 B5 yeah everything's coming
yeah that's that's not good no
so E5 is possible but after Bishop D3
I'm not sure what the follow-up is
yeah and you know again these that's why
I prefer like when Black's playing the
poison Pawn because these positions that
some people like laco and Geary can be
slightly worse and find the right plan
and draw lower rated players when
they're getting squeezed like this it's
it's not so simple and so it's better to
put pressure on your opponent and not
give them a free hand where if you play
perfectly or equal and if you don't you
get smushed right so that's that's why
we don't like these positions but it's
hard to get an active position with
black and still have a good position not
easy to do
not at all and right now it just seems
like one of those positions where white
has so many different kind of obvious
ideas and black is just struggling do I
play E5 or does that cause my position
to collapse and so you start spending
time and you're like no no more E5 can I
play B4 but then you play a move like B4
and after the Knight moves I guess you
can move Knight you can take here as
well but sometimes you just give up the
pawn like I don't care open Knight A4
yeah because we're getting the B file
and C5 and A6 and C6 yeah black has a
lot of issues just everything is a
problem here right yeah because you said
Rook B1 you can't even play Rook B8
because I sacked my rook and then take
your knight after so
ugh that's my kind of sacrifice
and you can't play Bishop a a because
Bishop A6 so you're yeah this is no fun
this is not how you would like this
position to go so
yeah that's that's not a favorite one
and there's one more game here I wanted
to check before we take our second quick
break uh the matchup between on the
music and Elizabeth Pates because
they're very good friends they often
stream together and you know they're
battling it out for a very important
spot in the top eight of the Women's
World Cup here and white is up a pawn
but black is
using the Dynamics to her advantages the
bishop pair open Bishops a rook and come
to d8 so Ben are you greedy would you
prefer to be up upon here or do you like
Black's chances
uh I'm usually greedy but I don't know
if I'm that greedy
um I mean this seems like
black should be reasonably happy with
the results of the opening Black's
position looks pretty nice
obviously you know White's gonna hope
the extra Pawn is good
um
that that would be a tough decision for
me I don't think I would do it but I
mean I'm worried about
White playing Knight D5 later which I
guess she can't do now so if if white
plays Knight D5 later and it's good then
I I guess I should have done it
but but yeah I don't I I think black can
be okay without uh in fact is it White's
move here it is White's turn yes yeah
okay so that's good I'll have to make
that decision right
but yeah hey so you were saying they're
good friends now I don't have any
friends I have no trouble but you have a
lot of friends at the Grand Minister
level do you find it easier
um or more difficult when you're playing
your friends I assume that's that's not
as pleasant as beating somebody you
don't like as much yeah I mean I don't
really like chess players so I don't
have that problem exactly but yeah it is
really an issue psychologically when you
play people that you know you get along
with well or if you've worked together
that's just an absolute nightmare when
you have to play somebody that you spend
a lot of time preparing with it's just
not fun and I think that these players
they're professionals they'll you can
get over the personal relations they may
have and what about the music sisters or
what if they play each other actually
there was a tweet I think it was Chris
bird or maybe it wasn't but he said if
the music trucks play in the final I'm
not sure they're in different brackets
but it says based on previous games
they've played what would happen
because usually they just play like a 10
move draw right and you see that happen
with many
pairs of friends or in this case
siblings you see mamajarov and kariakin
who are very good friends they draw in
15 moves every time and then you know in
the online events you see certain
players have their draws right there's
the
um the Berlin draw that some people do
the queen D4 Queen E4 and then there's
the queen D4 Queen D2 draw that I think
the job of unless they so have down so
actually the person with the most
siblings has to be rajabov because he
has all those quick draws so I think
everybody in the world is this sibling
and he's just like yeah
hey you know he's just an agreeable guy
I guess there you go yeah but yeah
Anna took an F5 Bishop takes F5 seems
quite obvious as a reply unless you
throw in Rook d8 first which I wouldn't
do Ben because I would want to sacrifice
my queen as one if you play say Rook FDA
because I think I've read this could I
sacrifice my queen not my pieces it's
legal I'm going like this and then just
taking on D6 I like White's position
here you have a knight a rook and two
pawns for the queen I'm taking white
yeah and we have a white square Bishop
too so that that could be yeah could be
annoying
in fact he might throw in or she might
throw in Bishop C4 check first now
probably not because B2 is not not
defended yeah just so yeah but this yeah
this seems fine she just took back on F5
to want to analyze all that and probably
didn't like it like you
it's not worth exploring Bishop takes F5
it just hits this Pawn on C2 you can
play Rook D whenever you want not when
it gives white other options exactly and
well I'm not even sure how you defend
this Pawn Knight D5 at some point would
be nice for white but it seems like it's
not happening anytime soon but what is
happening now is Ben and I are going to
take a short break one return there will
be much more action heating up from the
fide World Cup and the fide Women's
World Cup this coverage is brought to
you by chess.com foreign
[Music]
foreign
rapid Blitz will begin in August with 10
top Grandmasters competing for their
share of 150 000 prize fund in faster
time it shows the direction of a game
can change quickly and even the best
players in the world might falter who
will outwit their opponents and take on
first place watch on chess.com and find
out it will be another fun top event but
in the meantime we are still in the
World Cup speaking of top events with a
lot of action quicker time controls in
the tie breaks we've had the Magnus
Carlson position against Russell
voytacek during the break and it looks
like
is what's happening in this game here
this Knight on B4 looks somewhat decent
but A3 can always pick it out then not
the most open of positions who do you
think that favors here Magnus or
Radisson
um I actually don't think it favors
anybody this position is probably you
know more equal than not but uh this is
the kind of position doesn't play
accurately and find good squares for his
pieces he could end up getting smushed
on you know even on the king side but
obviously the Knight on B4 is good
White's gonna play A3 Magnus is probably
trying to decide
um how to how to attack on the C file
with either Rick C8 or queen C7 that way
the Knight potentially could hop in the
seeds too but that would be funny if it
goes A3 Knight C2 Rook A2 and we see
what happens there that's uh that's a
very strange um something
it depends like who's quicker here and
you know
um does A4 worker it doesn't I guess it
doesn't
well it's funny because you can almost
trap this Rook on yeah it's a very
strange position like it reminds me of
the the uh you know the other game where
uh uh Garibaldi is his night on C2 and
sort of confusing
yeah and you know B3 I think you were
just pointing this out it looks like his
Knight is trap of Queen C7 it defends it
but then you're like wait what about
Rook D2 the knights are really trapped
but then the bishop is no longer
defended here so you can get away with
this it's just it's all tricks yeah yeah
and no kids playing in this game though
right
yeah so this is a very strange position
because it looks like if black just gets
pushed back and has to move the Knight
back to C6 you know I'm going to take
Wyatt but if black just dominates the C
file then Black's probably better so
it's
I'll tell you in three moves what I
think right now I don't know and I want
to play Bishop A6 and after 83 I was
thinking can I play this move Bishop E2
just to be a trickster because if you
make this mistake with rookie one you're
not going to be very happy when I move
my Bishop all the time you can win your
queen of course Rook D2 takes care of
everything hitting the bishop hitting
the Knight so you'll have to keep up
this bishop for Knight and F3 and not
ideal
yeah but it's really a a strange kind of
position because
something's going to happen in the next
two or three moves that's gonna make the
position different
yeah and I don't know what it is I don't
know if Magnus is going to have to
retreat and be worse or if he's gonna
go crazy with one of these lines and
needs to get his knife extricated or or
saved
yeah you don't play Rook C8 Knight C2
without calculating not just like three
moves not even just five moves you
really have to see the exact future
because that Knight will be stuck there
for quite a long time and that could
turn out to be a big mistake or it could
turn out just to be super frustrating
for what to deal with you know what
black could do if he doesn't want to you
know get bogged on in the complications
is if he plays A4 maybe even now then
after A3 you could play Knight C6 to A5
that's pretty good night on A5
it's controlling a lot of key squares
and you know the dark Square Bishop
isn't uh the best Bishop in the world
so maybe maybe black wouldn't get
smooshed if he could get Knight A5 Inc
and his Knights are a good Square take
the C file
yeah I actually like that because if you
can
get a position like this where the pawn
A3 is stuck in place you can also use it
as a hook to pry open the queen side and
then go Queen A5 Rook B8 and start
bringing all these pieces here and so
one thing that white probably wants to
avoid is a trade of Pawns on the queen
tank because if you can contain the C
file and say uh you know your night on
B4 is not really doing that much
eventually as you were pointing up and
the Queen on B1 maybe H4 H5 and you have
this sort of King's Indian attack type
of position with a queen on B1 rather uh
then you know on a different square but
I think that it holds some promise for
white
yeah potentially white can get a really
a really strong position and that's why
Magnus is trying to figure out if he can
just play Sol and he's okay or if he has
to
calculate a lot and see if he can
infiltrate White's position without
getting his pieces you know trapped
so this this is the big think of the
game that's that's one of the
differences between the strong Grand
Masters and the club player is they
recognize the critical position and this
is a critical position because if white
plays A3 either Black's going to retreat
and be passive or he's gonna have to
calculate the ramifications of whether
that Knight on C2 is okay that's why
Magnus is having a big think now and I
think part of the struggle with
recognizing this as a critical moment is
there's no real tension in the position
the pawns aren't attacking each other
there's no capture to consider so even
coming up with a plan may not be so easy
for most of our viewers but then you
start trying to come up with a plan and
realize is black going to try to
break pawns with F6 that's a typical
idea but then E6 might be weak should
black just play on The Queen side with
Rook C8 and maybe Knight C2 or even if
not Knight C2 just focused our attention
there or is white going to Parry off the
threats and then go H4 and maybe Knight
to G5 or something to that effect and
start launching a king side attack of
his own so it's a really difficult
position to assess and there you see all
the possibilities but it's not just
about seeing the variations it's about
evaluating the resulting positions and
that's very tricky when the position
isn't Dynamic it's actually a very
static position right now yeah it's
funny because we were talking earlier
about positions where we liked why but
we sort of agree that if the position
happened in our games we would have
black yeah this sort of reminds me of
that I think I'm sure black is okay here
but this seems more like a position that
Magnus would have why he would Parry
Black's threats and eventually he would
have a nice Advantage but here he's got
to figure out the counter play himself
and plan against the space Advantage so
it just seems like Magnus will be more
comfortable with white here
yeah and well he'll have to make do with
the black side of this position he is
spending quite a deal of time he's
behind in the clock so we'll leave it to
him to find out the exact plan that he
wants to employ let's go to I guess
pantelahari krishna's match against Amin
Tabitha to buy we haven't even taken a
peek at that and well it doesn't look
like the most interesting position but
then I will say these types of positions
where it looks like black is doing
totally okay sometimes black gets in
trouble and like the next four moves
like what happened it's even material my
pieces are on good squares but then it's
coming up with a plan whereas if white
eventually puts this queen on E3 and
maybe gets Bishop on B6 and a rook to D1
all of a sudden white is having all the
fun and black is struggling just to
coordinate all the rooms right and these
are the kind of positions when the
players are lower rated than these
players you know like 2200 to 2600
sometimes black just gets smooshed
because he can't figure out what to do
and somehow
the 27 and 2800 players they they defend
really well for black and it looks like
it was just completely equal Harry
Christian is the kind of guy who I would
want to have black here who I think
could figure out the in and outs and
defend properly right and I guess one
big question I have been is Queen E3
looks extremely logical to me because I
want to put my Bishop on B6 and then you
have questions like do I play B5 or will
that make my A6 Pawn weak that's a tough
question to answer on the spot uh you
know where do I put my queen because if
I play Queen z7 aren't I just walking
into a bishop B6 I still can't put a
rook to d8 I mean Knight D7 protects
everything it looks a little passive but
at least the Knight controls a lot of
squares that's true it looks risky
because you're undefending your king a
little bit but I guess it doesn't matter
here so much yeah actually like Knight
D7 uh it's non-committal you're not
creating any weaknesses in your position
and you can play Bishop F6 next if you
want and do things like that but
actually you're threatening E5 is that
just trap the piece yeah
that's unexpected
wow yeah I guess I can play Rook to D1
right so like if I work fd1 you can play
E5 then I can take it of course because
then you can sack your queen like you
like to do I do like the sack the queen
however not in this position right uh
but yeah then Queen A5 makes sense
because there's no Bishop B6 so your
knight D7 move I I think it's a pretty
decent one I was retreating before you
were born that's true no and while
you're retreating methodology I think is
paying off because 97 is
likely something that our Christian will
consider although to buy isn't even sure
he'll if he'll play Queen E3 or come up
with another move
it looks it looks pretty equal I mean I
would if I had to bet I would guess this
game is going to end and draw but
obviously there's a lot of Chess to be
played but I think Hari Krishna got a
reasonable position absolutely well
speaking of positions where
uh you know a lot to figure out but
Advantage for white I'm going over here
to Federal saves game and Ben and I were
talking during the break how feta Sam
and Harry Christian these are two
players who are super duper strong but
are often overlooked and whether it's
because their compatriots have higher
ratings or just more Fame somehow
they're not talked about enough and
ferroseo has been having a marvelous
World Cup he's winning his matches in
regulation in classical chess and now he
with all due respect to vladisov kovalev
has a pretty favorable player at this
stage of the tournament 26-37 a very
good player formerly 2700 but that's the
type of pairing you probably aren't too
unhappy about and speaking of things
that you're you're not unhappy about Ben
this is a bind if I've seen one oh yeah
this is great for white and he's one of
the guys sort of like grish shook maybe
even better than English who I think is
really good at rapid and Blitz so he has
I think some kind of advantage in this
format
yeah I mean fellow Sam's one of the few
guys who can give akaru a tough time in
these you know online Blitz tournaments
Fellowship is really good at Blitz
sometimes he plays Blitz when he's
playing slow chest
fedo save reminds me the rapidity of his
play reminds me of a young Anand Anand
used to just move instantly and he's
obviously slowed down not too much but
the effects of plays really quickly and
really confidently and luckily I didn't
look at the clock when I said that and
then I looked at it and at least I'm not
proven wrong right away he's got a lot
more time than his opponent you're not
proven wrong he has much more time and
his position is so much easier to play
because
typically in these type of structures
for black you think about B5 you think
about D5 but neither move is possible
and in these hedgehogs black has more
minor pieces and without the minor
pieces you can't explode the position in
a favorable way because white will just
grab the material and we can just see
that very clearly B5 I just can take
with either Pawn honestly but let's say
I take this way and then my knight can
just capture on B5 thank you for a free
Pawn
if you play D5 well then I have to think
a little bit more but I think I can
still just capture with the c pawn and
after e takes D5 I'm not even going to
take yeah kick this Knight the truth
hurts here yeah no good that's no good
whatsoever so no Pawn breaks for you so
if that's the case Ben what not just
what moves because I think Queen C6 or
queen C7 yeah black black looks like he
has to wait to get smushed she's waiting
but you know and white has to play
accurately to continue I mean black just
has to chill and hope that white can't
break through but that's that's no fun
yeah I guess you can wait until white
try some G4 H4 maybe even rerouting the
Knight to the king side and that is a
risky decision to start pushing Pawns in
front of your king I just don't see what
black does
no it's it's no fun for black you know
you were saying it earlier
a lot of people in this tournament who
go under the radar they live in a
country where
people are younger or more famous or
better if they lived anywhere else
they'd just be Superstars and Hari
Krishna has been the second best player
in India for quite a long time but you
know he's not 15 years old and his
rating isn't going up and you know these
you know Prague the non-ha saren and
many other the young Indian players are
just more well known to the general
public as people who are getting better
and better and nobody expects Hari
Krishna to just all of a sudden become a
top five player right and federal say of
man does he live in the wrong country I
mean I mean because
there's so many good players and
somebody said something yesterday which
was hard for me to believe although I I
guess I believe it they they claimed
DuBois was rated ninth in Russia
and I was like so yeah you got so many
good players that some of these guys who
are 2700 for a long time they're they're
not top five top 10 in the world so they
don't get the kind of admiration that we
give them because we know that Harry
Christian fetto say have comply Trust
wow that is just crazy that dubov is
number nine in Russia which means that
Federal save is like number 15 or
something yeah I don't know if he's
number nine that's what somebody said I
mean I believe it could happen I'm
thinking yeah that guy's higher that
guy's higher that guy I mean I'm like
yeah maybe there's so many good players
yes and a lot of them are left in the
tournament and they're playing each
other we actually haven't looked at this
matchup right between artemiev and
kariakin but speaking of there's two
guys who were higher rated the new buff
yeah and while they do not have the most
exciting game I'm gonna have to say that
matter exactly here because it's an end
game Rook D7 would be a nice looking
move trying to get this Pawn on B7 take
the seventh rank but after Rook to D7
amongst other things Rook C7 looks
plenty fine the Knight of E6 is doing
yeah this looks like it's going to be a
draw this is this is the one match I
would I have absolutely no idea who the
favorite is I got nothing
and you know
sorry to interrupt you Ben but is artemy
I was writing really 2704 wasn't he like
27 40. yeah he's way better than that
when when he played golf and and they
they drew the slow match the rapid match
was not was not uh competitive no yeah I
mean he's just yeah again when it comes
to Rapid and Blitz some of these guys
are just are just monsters and our time
you have is one of them
wow I'm looking at his live rating he's
under 2700 how is that possible
it's not yeah I mean you know I mean
there's just so few games played that
are feeding rated lately that again the
ratings aren't indicative of how strong
they are
that's and I think this format as you
were not implying you're just stating in
favor of someone like artemiev who is a
strong enough classical player to hang
around with all the best players in the
world and then when you get to wrap it
in Blitz oh boy you do not want to face
artemia and to be fair to this matchup
you don't really want to face karyakan
either
yeah I mean we're getting deep in the
tournament here everybody's a monster
it's uh there's no easy matchups a lot
of people are underrated so you just
obviously when somebody's winning match
after match they're not going to be a
pushover
no
and well right now artemium holding with
black he'll be very happy using his Karo
Khan defense to success here and one
match you know speaking of players he's
in no easy matchups there are a couple
matches in this round with players you
wouldn't suspect to be here one of them
is this matchup between auntie burkich
and Mike Marty rosian so hike Marty
Russian of course upset Shakira
mamajarov that was it was shocking
shocking it was indeed in a really
impressive performance after losing game
two yeah was able to turn around in the
tie breaks and win those games that
Auntie berkich maybe the unsung hero of
this event he has gone five and a half
out of six in classical chess which
means he's played zero tie breaks while
upsetting higher rated opponents and
that's right he's not a young sexually
he's attacking them he's playing
aggressive and he's not a youngster he's
not 15 years old I think he's in his 30s
and he's from Croatia he's not a
heralded player but he's in the thick of
things here and now he's the black
pieces in this game was hike Mart's
erosion and this position I think is
much more complicated than initially
meets the eye I think many people say oh
the eval Bar says what is that I can't
even see like 0.3 is about equal be very
careful in this type of position because
if white does in fact capture this
Knight on C4 puts a knight on D4 King on
C3 that is a no fun position for black
we're playing for two results with white
and let me just play a movie like H6
just to show that and I could play
Knight D4 first but just to get to this
position here putting my knight on D4
I'm putting my king on C3 this Knight
can get the C6 this work can come to A1
this is a miserable position to have as
black yeah after Knight D4 King C3
Magnus raises his hand and say can I
play White there
I would like to have white please
uh sub me and Coach yeah this is not a
position you want as black and wait was
H6 my mover did he really just played
that that was your move okay that's my
move I mean he might have played it but
it was your move yeah
he stole your move
so you're saying blacks Black's probably
about equal but he has to be really
accurate this is where I think the
engine is just not helpful because yeah
it says not okay point three point four
slightly better for white but I actually
think the advantage is bigger than the
engine would say from a practical point
of view White's position is so simple to
play and let's say you Robert keeps
talking about
planting a night on D4 let me take this
Knight on F3 and then you look at the
position I could stand out before but
yeah do you really want to take on F3
because then your D5 Pawn is a target
that's right yeah no you you sound like
somebody who works with Fabi the the
engine says one thing and then Fabi is
like no no I don't care if it's equal
I'm taking this color it's a lot easier
than the engines are on yeah yeah this
is
beautiful for white it's a dream
position uh practically speaking I
remember interviewing Fabi and it was he
beat Hikaru in some crazy Sicilian and
he's like yeah the engine and says it's
equal but I mean I'm just going to win
like this is terrible for black and and
he did it was funny yeah these things
happen and well I was now gonna hop on
over to a very impressive player a young
name that is well known pragna Nanda is
taking on Maxine vashir lagrav so mvl
outlasted David paravian in the
Armageddon tie break and now he's the
black pieces in this position against
the youngster the wonderkin from India
and if I'm counting correctly black is
actually up a pawn here but I see the
eval bar on screen better for white that
raises some questions for NBL how he's
going to play this position and he's got
some issues here yeah
he does have issues
um yeah white has pressure on the DNE
files threatening The Rook Queen G7 meat
later the Knight has E5 C4 could be
annoying there's a I mean black has to
play accurately here yeah Queen D4 hits
it looks like a grunfeld I wouldn't bet
my life on it but it looks like a
grenfeld you're correct is grunfels yeah
um and and well I honestly would bet
your life on it because Maxine vashir
legroud he plays the same openings over
and over again and right yeah he played
a grinfeld here and I I guess
I I see the advantage for white based on
the the bar in front of us I see the
attack on this Rook here big question
what if I just move my Rook to
E8 like what's so bad about that
so if I play Queen D4 are you gonna play
Knight F6 uh that was my plan
just
drop there that seems that seems like
yeah the blacks defending while there so
probably Queen D4 isn't right but but
what is right you're 95 minutes
what's that your 95 move yeah 95 is
that's good yeah I'm trying to play
something tricky like Rook A5 but I'm
too tricky
now E5 is super aggressive if you take
on C3 I have Queen F3 I assume Queen F3
is great you can also just take on D6
and uh oh and The Bishop's hanging okay
yeah but Queen F3 is probably even
better I like that let's keep the Queens
I don't know if it's better but it's
they're both good yeah they both win a
piece yeah see it's defense C3
indirectly and yeah 95 you know puts the
pressure on the bishop on D7 now maybe
C4 is actually a threat yes
um
Queen F3
yeah it's just it's just hard to play
Black it's not easy to play Black here
yeah actually you gotta play accurately
one sample line is saying Bishop E6 I
like your queen F3 move right away C4 is
coming B7 might fall this just doesn't
feel yeah D1 is annoying yeah the the
extra Pawn for black is not making its
presence very felt and you do have to be
careful if you go go into a position
like this as white and thinking oh I
have this lasting compensation all of a
sudden black just Wards off the threats
and then you're in a position where I'm
really down a pawn and I'm gonna have to
figure things out but for now probably
not using that kind of youthful
exuberance and trying to
hurt mvl's King I don't know if you
agree with this but I think when you're
somebody who's been famous and top 10
for a long time like mvl
I think it's tougher to play these kids
who who just literally don't care like
you know progdananda Cinder of you know
they're like yeah whatever and they just
play to crush you if you play somebody
who's been around the block who's been
about 26.50 to 2700 for 10 years they're
like ah mvl oh what a tough opponent
because he's better than me he's always
been better than me and you know I'm
probably gonna lose this match and the
young kids are like okay now it's time
to beat mvl I just be Geary I just beat
mom and Jara who's next the young guys
just are like give me somebody else to
beat and they're not they don't have the
years and years and years of being
afraid of a guy who's been topped for a
long time so pragodan has one of those
guys who's like yeah yeah mvl whatever
right I'm I'm gonna be world champion
soon so this is another guy I gotta beat
and somebody who's definitely never
going to be world champion who's just
hanging around to 26.75 I think they're
they're more scared of the top 10
players than these youngsters are so I
think you're a thousand percent correct
and it may seem like a joke but the
psychological component is very real
where players do get in these positions
they fear their higher rated more
esteemed colleague and they're like I
can't do this whereas somebody like
prognos like I I'm the future and I
don't think he thinks that in like any
kind of boastful way it's just that why
should he be afraid he's getting better
if he loses this match so be it but he
actually has a great chance at knocking
off Maxime and it's just because these
players do not worry about the number
next to their points ready they use this
as a way to get better his tournament is
one where they didn't expect to win
they're here they're tough for any
opponent to knock out and someone like
prognanda can indeed keep moving on but
right now we will leave you on this game
we will go to break and we'll return
more action from the fide World Cup and
feed a women's world cup brought to you
by chess.com
[Music]
foreign
Champs is back on August 29th pod Champs
4 returns with some familiar faces Mr
Beast and my guide Ludwig reappear for
their shot of Glory presented by
coinbase potchem's four promises to be
the biggest brightest and best POG yet
so don't miss out on any of the action
it is always a fun event these POG
Champs and the players and the streamers
that take part have a good deal of fun
they learn a lot and hopefully you do as
well and we are in the middle of the
fide World Cup we have Magnus carlsen's
game he's the black pieces against
Russell boytajik on screen in front of
you so we left to it during break and
Ben not too much has happened in this
game Magnus did bring that Rook to C8 he
did have to drop his Knight back to C6
and one thing I want to point out that
is probably a bit difficult to realize
initially is that when you have these
pawns next to each other for white it
makes it difficult for black to break
open that side of the board because if
you play A4 I'll push through to B4 and
if you play B5 B4 I'll push A4 so I keep
more of the queen side closed and then
you were talking about a potential
kingside attack that feels like white is
able to accomplish that if the queen
side doesn't open up
yeah I mean white wants to play assuming
black doesn't get the counter play right
away like H4 Knight G4 Bishop G5 and
pushing that H Pawn and you know if
black means counter play and as you said
earlier is is black gonna play F6 and
attack that epon and you know cause a
reckoning or is Magnus is going to chill
and be solid and hope that white over
extends and you weren't here for this
but you probably know Magnus is the only
player in the event left who's won all
of his games he's 4-0 so he doesn't want
to lose that streak either wow is that
true yeah
my he's uh really
impressive thus far I just didn't
realize he was the only one to win all
of his games but good well you're saying
Birdcage had five and a half out of six
but Magnus didn't have to play the first
round so that's true and Magnus is kind
of Magnus not he can't face anybody
higher rated than him so
not quite the same in in some ways but
here the question of F6 I mean that
remains
a good one I at first glance liked the
idea of F6 I don't want to be cramped I
want to open up the board for my pieces
and I think white probably has to take
on F6 unless I'm misreading something
here
I mean that's that's almost always the
most likely move otherwise you know like
it's a choice of what to do it might
even win the e-pawn yeah
and well how do I take back for black
bishop or Knight rather I don't want to
go to The Rook that's awkward then I
come to G4 at some points right either
the Knight or the bishop I'm not sure
probably not with the pawn either so
there's like two choices the other two I
wouldn't
I wouldn't do them if Bishop takes I do
stare at this D4 Pawn which I mean
Mission E2 becomes a threat of sorts so
I could see the merits of Bishop takes
F6 here and then white will probably
have to play Move Like Rook A2 and now
oh that's a cool move yeah you just
protect the E2 Square from Bishop to E2
which was yeah I'm getting off that
diagonal with the bishop on F6
and then I regret playing F6 and I know
you say never play F6 but these
french-like structures you sometimes
have to but now I'm regretting it
because the knight's coming to G4 yeah
now I know why I stopped playing the
French yeah as soon as white gets in
Knight G4 he's pretty happy
right the bishop can go out to F4 Rook
to E1 oh yeah this is not and again this
seems like positions Magnus wants to
have white
yes 100 you would prefer to have white
in this position and if you take with a
knight on F6 does that change anything
just this looks Bishop H3 coming
yeah that's not good
at ig5 The Brute Force attack and it
works yeah maybe black can survive and
not just be completely hopeless here
because you played Knight d8 oh but I
have Knight G4 no no no no because I'm
threatening mate on H7 yeah you're
throwing Knight F6 Knight E5 man harsh
yeah this is not what you what you
wanted to see
so yeah F6 not gonna happen probably
and if not for F6 then
yeah I'm sort of out of ideas I hate
these closed positions uh from Black's
perspective
I mean it's a really slow plan but if
black plays A4 and white plays B4 we
could play Knight A7 try a triple on the
C file try to play Knight B5 but it's
it's pretty slow right so I'm sort of
worried I'll get made it while I'm doing
that
but you know I'm getting to see you know
play like move the Rook off the queen of
theater The Rook and Knight B5 and you
know try to get in there somehow but
it's I'm scared
although it's not easy to see how white
goes for an attack and one thing I need
to question myself about is my instinct
was to play B4 to push through can I
take on A4 is that you can yeah maybe I
should
yeah then I then I probably would not
and I'm not playing 97 anymore plug it
played Knight A5 and get some squares
that way right and I'm just gonna try to
bring my Bishop out yeah B4 is a good
Square for the bishop no
yeah I don't you often don't want to
take on A4 and double your pawns and you
know maybe a lot to win them with an
initiative but here maybe you're not
winning yeah when Alex fishbein and I
were juniors
he was very opinionated about the fact
that White's a pawn up he's like well
I'm a pawn up and then I'm like yeah in
these kinds of positions he's just like
well I have an extra Pawn so he's good
accounting yeah I mean obviously the the
pawns look sort of silly but at least
you have them that's true and you're
controlling B4 and B5 yeah so oh this
does not look like an appealing position
for magnets no but this this explains
why Magnus is having a really huge thing
right because if he plays A4 or F6 you
can't take it back so
he's gonna have to make a decision at
some point to do some kind of Pawn break
and
he's hoping that it works out but yeah
definitely Magnus wants to have white
here even if even if black is okay I
think this is his kind of position with
white he he could throw in Bishop E2 and
take on F3 to make F6 more appealing
because after Bishop E2 he Rooks under
attack you probably go you have to go
rookie too because rookie one would drop
this Pawn on D4 right when I take on a
three so Rook D2 takes takes and maybe
now F6 is that
foreign
s and you you weaken the defense of them
by getting rid of the night right and
things are opening up here there's some
chances but maybe white would be smart
to actually keep the position more
closed Bishop G4 right although I can
still take on Eve I don't know what's
happening there that's when things get
explosive and that's probably why Magnus
is thinking so much because
you could take on E5 give up E6 probably
lose D5 and then D4 what is happening in
a position of this nature yet I mean
these are decisions you can't take back
no so when you when you when you trade
your Bishop for a night and do a pawn
break and you're calculating it better
be right and that's and Magnus realizes
if he just does nothing he's gonna be
worse and if he does something it could
make it even more worse so he really has
to find an accurate way to try to
equalize here and you know the engine
says it's fine because the engine has an
idea of what it thinks the most accurate
way is but you know it's hard to look 10
12 moves ahead in a position like this
but it's not difficult for the engine so
this is just this is a very difficult
practical situation for Magnus
yeah and we uh we'll leave him to figure
it out what tachek just looked you know
looked up a camera a little while ago
he's kind of hanging about trying to he
looks pretty happy yeah
and well we're talking so he's a beast
speaking of players who men always get
the respect they deserve his Peak thank
you oh wait who what his Peak rating was
something like 27.50 he was the Polish
number one for a long time that's not me
no that is not you he suffered some
setbacks but he's still nearly 2700 In
classical chess and you see his radical
Blitz ratings above 2700 so he's a
monster mm-hmm
but okay magnus's ratings look pretty
good too
they really do and
I think they just don't need to be
stated out loud they're just too strong
but then there is a game that I knew
would get interesting I'm gonna head
over to that one it's between Buckroe
and pankartov you're gonna like the look
of this game
wait what's what's happening I needed an
adult
what's the material is it even material
uh
yes wow yes and there's a Pawn on B3
yes although I mean
I I like white me too
you've controlled like every single
Square on the board yeah
um
yeah this looks good for white
every white piece is just fine yes
uh let's see we got it here from the
French and it was a knight E2 response
Knight E2 the Robert Hess variation I I
don't think that's what it's called it
says something something yeah see all of
it
he just went Queen D3 I mean this is
very hard to explain to newer players
because everything looks wrong about
this you moved your queen early your
Bishop is on F1 blocked by the Knight of
two you sacrifice a pawn that wasn't
kept but I guess Buckroe just said I'm
gonna Castle Queen side and you're gonna
have to deal with the potential attack
there was a game in the Olympiad when I
was about 11 or 12 years old and white
was I think just an I am and he played
exactly this way uh he he crushed black
play Queen D3 Castle Queen side and
black just got totally smushed
not sure who the player with white was
it might have been something like road
guard or something but it was it was a
long time ago but I I saw this and I was
like man why just went easy he just like
we need three castled and crushed his
opponent we might be getting a repeat of
that yeah I mean even Knight G4 he went
H4 I said I don't care about this bishop
F5 plane which is understandable but it
makes the E6 Pawn a clear Target yeah
and I jump to G5 H6 Knight drops back
and this is the problem when you play
music F5 is the E5 square is white
underwise control and then the E6 Pawn
becomes a future Target so he went
Bishop D7 I mean ig4 F5 H6 doesn't look
like the right plan to me no no I mean
you can't even play E5 here uh because
this queen will give a check I think and
the King has to go to the H file which
let's be honest you don't really want
and if you play Rook F7 well I think
they're I don't want that either no you
know any of this just take like take
take take
and I don't know Knight F4 I mean this
just looks so bad yeah this looks
terrible for black you've been the light
Square everything's bad and everything
it's just just tragically awful so you
couldn't play E5 and then it
it begs the question of what is the
point of this whole plan here and even
B5 because he didn't want to get smushed
right he's still getting smushed as you
can say yeah this took the words out of
my mouth
although it likes black here like the
eve of our favors Black by quite a bit
so I think it's going to change soon
but it changed that means that black
must have made a serious error it's
probably this B3 move yeah there it is
yeah it doesn't like B3 at all it goes
from -1 to plus one point what is it 1.2
in that one move
that's not good
so
yeah the engine didn't like C4 C5
although I like it but the engine's like
nah don't do that
it looked quite reasonable to me yeah
so why does it like black so much here
right yeah we both from the human eye
this looks
really dreary for black
yes E6 Pawn is
not very pleasant the G6 Square it seems
like what has great attacking options
you may be able to
I don't even know
I was gonna say Knight A5 Bishop B7
Bishop E4 things like that Warrior but
the E6 Pawn is still weak so I don't
think you have time for all this
uh maybe 985 Queen D7 and it's going for
the A4 Pawn
I don't know then yeah I assume that if
black didn't play B3 that white was
gonna play B3 and and lock it up
um at least the black plays B3 has the
B4 Square the Pawn's on B3 for a while
so that I mean that's what he was
thinking
but it looks like Buckroe is a queen C3
and then Bishop B5 and yeah Bishop
Bishop B5 is is probably what black
underestimated
the power of the bishop and pawn
protecting one another hitting this
Knight spawn is weak B3 at some point
might fall
I don't know I don't recommend this for
black
after after Queen C3 what did Black play
I missed the intermediate move Knight
back down oh Knight F6
man that Knights had an interesting
career
it's found on the yo-yo string between
G4 and F6 but D5 is a pretty nasty
looking threat in addition to Bishop C4
so yeah I think he felt obligated to
retrieve T3 is a nice Square for the
queen it unleashes the rook and the
bishop yeah
that's why B3 wasn't good
I mean this looks uh I can only repeat
myself so many times Ben this looks
really bad always repeat
exactly but the position looks terrible
I don't even know what Black's next move
is I
I really don't like if I was black here
I don't understand what to play even
because your night's trapped yeah you
you I mean what
yeah Bishop B5 is really strong
uh
I hate to say this from a queen E8 maybe
right I hate to say yeah that's why I
wasn't saying it but this looks awful
yeah I mean you're walking into a pin
which
Queenie it I can't play Knight E5
probably
I mean I don't
I have to be an engine to play Black
here because I'm a human I'm just crying
now it's as equal so something about
this
95. this is very strange the the
engine's not so bad but we are
like what is this yeah
I can't pretend to understand how black
can possibly be okay here
I mean rookies before I can't work just
take nope
this fawn's hanging this would be
defended this E6 Pawn Stills trouble I
don't believe in this
I mean maybe Knight E5 is wrong but we
like it
and that's when you see what 94 is that
right yep yeah you didn't do that he did
that no I didn't I didn't foreign
doesn't like that move
so do you take on B3 to enter a pin or
do you just move your queen somewhere
else like Queen
E1 or queen D3
I don't know I I mean Queenie one seems
really safe because then you you defend
B4 and A5 you defend F2 and you're
attacking the Knight and D5 is coming
right so that just seems safe
I like it but obviously if you play more
aggressively that could be good too but
yeah but you're right it just takes away
all the squares from the night I mean
this just seems safe but yeah either
that can't move anywhere and queen E8 D5
as you just pointed out among other
ideas this looks very powerful
takes Knight takes this is hanging this
is hanging because Bishop
this is just
I can't recommend this position for
black no no it looks really good for
buckaro no well the Frenchman would like
to keep advancing in this event but
let's actually go to some other games
for now uh once again we left a long
time ago the Abdul sitar of against
durability game that has changed
completely
we left this doesn't even look like
though so he sacrificed The Exchange
and he got you know yeah let me see what
happened here CD played night he played
91. wow okay forcing Knight takes he won
the Knights traps so it has to capture
uh-huh Rook takes and then Bishop D7 was
played uh-huh
and he just took on D5 oh and he
sacrificed The Exchange wow he did
because D6 looks to be a threat the
king's in the center Bishops the E6 is
weak then yeah okay wow he went E5
yeah turbial is a pretty uncompromising
player
that's a move that
I wasn't expecting it would be hard for
me to play that but he allowed on
passant because it frees up the Knight
to Z6
Knight C6 Knight C3 Bishop B4
Rook D1
okay he didn't take on C3 so he allowed
the Knight to go to D5 I probably would
have captured on C3
yeah he was worried about giving in the
two Bishops and all the dark squares
right the bishop that's what he was
worried about
he was worried about that more than
Knight D5 not sure I agree with him but
starting to look just difficult for
black to play here because this I mean
Knight to D5 seemed just very obvious he
castled there is a pin so you can't go
take on B4 as you would like he was
Bishop F4
rookie 8 and Bishop C7
forcing The Rook aside and
Bishop F3
is the Y position
you can't take on
um E6 because Bishop G4 says
an absolute monster time Advantage for
black
and engine approved position mm-hmm
yeah I mean both sides have to be
careful here because if blacks if if
White's initiative Fades away and he
loses his E6 Pawn he's just dead lost
right on the other hand I think black
can easily blunder and lose in one move
if he's not careful so both sides have
to play and I'm wondering if um Bishop
F3 I just assumed he wanted the G2
Square for his King but but maybe um
Bishop H5 can be annoying at some point
that's right because you can't play G6
because right and then you should have
if the bishop goes to F7 I mean you know
that's
yeah and if Rook takes E6 he's gonna
play Bishop G4 right so yeah although
Bishop F3 is a pretty good move I think
this looks like just a draw right Bishop
G4 probably yeah this looks pretty equal
yes go like this and trade and we just
make a happy draw for for Dura Bailey it
draws a good result right you typically
want yeah you draw with black and you
press with white yeah that's the
standard yeah but if you are looking at
this current position he has so much
extra time I would not I know I have
Rook takes E6 if I just want to end the
game but I'll think for maybe even 40
minutes right now because I always have
a force draw if I see that sounds like
you yeah
that's true
um but I'm just trying to figure out is
King f8 uh worthy try just to get the
King close to the center can I do
something else
maybe Knight E7 because we take B4 then
I take C7 so there are various moves
here for black to try I don't even know
if Black's really better the evil Bar
says slide slight slight Edge for black
but that means that the position most
likely with proper play should just be
right it'd be a draw yeah
but they don't know that right
durability might be looking at this
saying I'm in trouble so let me just
take on E6 he might be thinking Hmm I
had all this prep why spoil it with a
half Point hey let's try to win so we
don't know the psychology of the players
yeah and I was thinking earlier in the
broadcast I didn't say anything because
I was worried I would be rebuffed but
a lot of the top players when they're
playing a younger low-rated player like
when you know in the Geary match
they want like a safe solid position and
outplay their opponents strategically
and they don't want to get into 30 moves
of theory and complications in messy
positions
but I think that's Jerry vial is not
like that and I think I think that if
somebody's gonna beat Cinder off it's
going to be somebody like Jeremy Ali who
doesn't mind getting messy and doesn't
mind calculating and isn't just like
playing for one kind of position where
they know they have the advantage
against the youngster but he's more you
know Universal style so that's I think
that's going to be tougher for for for
Nordy as he's called
um I think only Danny calls him yeah
um it's gonna be tougher than somebody
who is sort of afraid of his
opening prep and tactical awareness
because
durabiali is like what about my opening
prep for testicle awareness I could beat
him doing that and that's what he's
trying to do
I just have to uh pause and just mention
that Nordy doesn't even make sense as a
nickname because his name is no gear
back not priority back so nor do you
just you're saying Danny doesn't make
sense uh I've never heard that until
Danny said it yesterday but he claimed
he was the only person who called him
that he probably is because it's not his
name so right so a nickname yeah yeah
and well this game still complex I'm
just going to go over to the prognananda
game real quick because it looks like
mvl has sacrificed an exchange and he
has two pawns for that sounds like mvl
yeah
Knight takes C3 was played in the
position we last looked at Queen takes
D6
forced and give me your Rook and
Ben what do you think better chances I
think it's better chance to hold for
black than for white depression
definitely White's pressing yeah
and because black spawns aren't
dangerous they're not they're not
queening they are not and this Knight's
gonna go to B5 though and I just not
sure how much progress white can really
help too I mean mvl obviously thinks
this is holdable or he wouldn't have
played Knight takes C3
no
yeah it looks looks like yeah probably
more likely a draw than white winning
but I I can't see black winning
I agree and it's not coming to B5 the
knights get traded like let's say even
if you lose a D6 Pawn so I'm gonna try
to force that action so rookie three
might be five then we're gonna be here
all night yeah I'm just gonna do
something like this
I know what you're doing yeah yeah I'm
just trying to show six Rook D6 here or
something yeah
six takes and we get here it's like is
white really even gonna be able to press
this position all the pawns on light
square is the bishop defended by a Pawn
Yeah White's gonna push his King aside
pawns and move his King up right yeah
bring the king in maybe this gives you
actually pretty good chances so mvl has
to be worried but
I'm guessing he thinks he has this hole
under control
well I like the meant before
mm-hmm
you know White's obviously preferred
here so
parking on how is going to press
yeah he will and I'm just gonna Bop
around various games Ben let's see
Jeffrey's game I haven't seen it Jeffrey
Jeffrey okay I'm not rooting for anybody
but you know I'll go Jeffrey I mean it
did it that's what I mean
did it looks perfectly okay with the
black pieces here the queen went to H5
so that's what did an H
a little off the beaten path but it's
fine over here can't get trapped and
there are some issues for white to deal
with from this diagonal potentially
it looks completely fine for black right
yeah this looks pretty equalish
I don't even know what white should do
here
I was thinking Bishop E2 am I blundering
something
I like the blunder so but that's my
specialty you got to be good at
something
and one thing though that could nice one
thing that could get white in some
trouble now that I'm
digging a little deeper here is let's
say we get to this type of position
where we trade minor pieces
careful you work on D1 no you can't play
yeah oops they get to play I think he
gets to play Bishop yeah our Trader play
this should be two yeah okay but thank
you for uh spotting yeah you're trying
to make a point and it wasn't the point
to be made but what I was trying to get
at was something like this yeah the dark
squares are under blocks control you
have this nice provision they can't
attack anything black typically is
I'm very happy to be in a position of
this nature
so this might be what did it is actually
going for and he'll try to outplay
Jeffrey from a slightly better position
right
yeah it looks like White's the one that
has to um
in the actual position who has to um
keep the equality black seems pretty
happy
I'm trying to think if there's any
that's nothing to sneeze at bless you
you know I mean Jeffrey's trying to
figure out how to trap that Queen since
it doesn't have a lot of squares but I
don't see how that's happening
the queen doesn't have a lot of places
to go to but I think it's perfectly fine
on H5
agreed yeah nvid seems pretty happy the
way he's uh hanging around there
yep he should be happy with the black
pieces no real risk at the moment I
guess one move that we have to consider
is Knight D6
just a nice tactically defended because
we take I'm too old for that move yeah
and if you take on D3 then I think
there's Rook takes D3 and yep you can
double so
the 96 can be annoying
yeah like in an equal way
like white sequoise no
that's true yeah yeah but okay if I
double Rooks on the D file my knight
stays on D6 forever why could Clayton be
better yeah but I don't think that video
really I mean Jeffrey doesn't look super
happy he shouldn't be and he's trying to
work his way through this position
but probably just fine for vivid he'll
be happy to continue this position uh
let's uh take a peek at the game between
Shanklin and Juma bye of jumabaya the
hero or the spoiler if you will from the
previous round defeating five owner
carwana and oh gosh if it seems like no
moves have been made just
they have been it just seems like it
yeah
yeah both players are looking at Federal
saves game and saying okay here's what I
should do
although this gives black a little bit
more life because of all the minor
pieces
yeah not as easy to figure out
this seems okay for black
does it
so yeah I think black is okay here is so
what move do you make that's my first
question is is it my move it's black oh
man even better yeah
um
I don't know my night's already good on
C5 so maybe now E6 D4 isn't uh
is it what he wants to do
I wonder if he's going to try to play H4
and white could probably just take it
but whereas a Grandmaster fish find when
you need it yeah but then maybe 96 would
make yeah I mean so black black has to
come up with something yeah this but
this this could be bad for black could
be bad for white
um
I like the way the Bishops are on E1 and
E8 you don't see that very often no you
do not that's unusual for either one
yeah
no it's just like a very solid position
and the question is is black in a
breakout or is White gonna break you
know with like F4 F5 or G4 or B4 or is
black gonna do something with H4 or try
to get B5 in or transfer the Knight to
D4 so it's a strategically a difficult
position do you think it's not clear
what to do do you think you asked enough
questions Ben because there were many of
them I couldn't keep track yeah now I
could ask more yeah can you do that I
mean
now the question is I think like in the
player's Minds who's who's happier right
because Sam always looks pretty happy
but
I think jumabaya if I were playing this
game I would be happier to be the white
side of this position yeah I agree I see
clearer moves we would have black but we
like white yeah exactly yeah
I just see so many more moves for white
to play whereas right now I'm not even
sure like is black and play B6 and try
to go full Hedgehog probably not doesn't
look good it's funny like after the game
if we get to this position and talked to
Shanklin I don't know if he's gonna say
like well I was perfectly fine out of
the opening I was playing for an
advantage here or yeah I didn't like
this position very much I figured I
would just make a draw with this I don't
know what he's thinking because it's he
oftentimes he says the opposite of what
I think regarding regarding the
evaluation of the position
so
I can't really tell if he's really happy
or really unhappy I just I can't looking
at him doesn't help me no he actually
just looks all alone in the world right
now yeah there's nobody around him he's
trying to figure the position out and
it's one where it says zeros and I'm
just like how there's so many different
moves right only one Pawn has been
traded just one per side so there's too
much life left in this position to just
chalk it up to zeros
that's what the engine does
oh
no 97 Knight A7 exactly what we thought
would happen that sounds like Sam wants
to play B5 right but white can also play
A5 to stop B5 because if you take on A5
well you're not going to be very happy
consequences after B4 B4 yeah I mean
Knight A7 is weird
this is a very obvious B5 idea but
I don't know it just looks very strange
right so B5 is the idea
[Music]
B5 would be good like if black had a
free move to play B5 I think yeah the
only reason to play Knight A7
um so Sam's not impressed with A5
and I wonder why not because yeah he's
like whatever
yeah I don't know because we played B4
right yeah V4 is coming yeah
um
yeah but I don't get it
no I agree I I 97 is strange he probably
couldn't find a move
um
it wasn't an easy position to find moves
in but
A5 feels very logical I mean at the risk
at the risk of uh saying something dumb
maybe he wants white to push those pawns
forward so he has a Target on C4 he
could play Knight back to A5 put the and
then if B4 play 96 95 and try to Target
the C point I guess but that seems
like you could get in trouble doing that
because white always could play Knight
A3 or Knight E3 and Bishop F1 and
eventually White's gonna play C5 or B5
and or F4 and it's if that's a dangerous
way for white to plight it
yeah for black to play to egg white
forward and hope that it collapses
because it looks like it's just good for
white
yeah it looks amazing for weapons but if
he's not doing that then what's he doing
I think 97 is just not good I agree but
I think I think I think maybe he
underestimated A5 yeah he probably
couldn't find an idea so he's like at
least if white plays A5 I will have some
ideas to undermine the position even
though I'm seating control of many
important squares but Ben we're going to
leave the players to figure it out we'll
see if we're not jumbabaya chooses to
move A5 this is quite a critical moment
for him and he is an upset specialist at
this point defeating world number two
Fabiana carwana we'll see if he's able
to take down a second American in a row
but for now we'll go to short break one
return more from the fide World Cup and
Women's World Cup this coverage brought
to you by chess.com
foreign
[Music]
tournament Arc 2 is underway it has been
since July 16th it ends July 25th you
see the amazing anime featured in front
of you I really think we should do this
with chess players Ben I mean can you
imagine what Magnus would look like if
we put them in a little anime form
yeah that would be awesome as long as
they don't do it with me I agree you
wouldn't want to be you know have a
little character of yourself no this is
good because on the bottom is the enemy
on the top of the people but Ali on the
top looks uh pretty similar
yeah in real life it's tough yeah
yeah and the chest Harmon's been fun
it's been the Redemption Arc storyline
between Sea Dog VA and gig hook and yeah
it's been cool to watch I know that
they're all having a lot of fun with it
but I just can't get over the
anime chess needs this just make one for
Magnus make one for all these players
left that would be cool but anyway back
to the chest back to the World Cup
enough with the terminar two and we just
had a peace sacrifice not a peace
offering but a sacrifice like F5 here
between voitashek and Carlson so let's
just scroll back a few moves A4 was the
response to to B4 and then Bishop E2 was
played
and the capture on F3 F6 Bishop G4 F5
and photographic said I just gotta
sacrifice a piece because if Bishop
retreated to stop F4 because that's a
big threat to go Bishop H3 to stop that
pawn push Bishop takes H4 looks very
scary because once this queen comes in
it's the bishop it's the pawn a second
time yeah the D4 Plum once that falls
it's over yeah E5 is going to fall five
is swallowing yeah this looks miserable
so Vuitton whether it was planned out or
he felt that he had to at this point he
sacks a piece on F5 and after he takes
Bishop takes F5 Ben we can see that
Magnus can more or less force a draw I
would think of a G6
takes takes Queen takes you six he made
a force but he would allow a draw by
repetition here as the King goes back so
I think Magnus is definitely going to
play for a win
um because he's Magnus
unless he thinks
he's worse if he doesn't do that I don't
know if he thinks that but he this is
what he's considering
he's like should I draw now and then
play white or should I go for it I have
one on my games this tournament I want
my reading to go up 2 900.
[Music]
um
no he's not thinking a lot of that
I would be surprised if if Magnus wants
to draw here
that's not the Magnus that I know so
what moves come to mind because G6
allows a draw maybe white won't even
take the draw you'll try to play on
somehow but you can't uh but what else
can black do here I guess Bishop takes
H4 like that was an interesting move
everybody sacks a piece
okay so do you take on H7 I
and imagine well I mean if I take on on
H4 my bishop's still on the D7 Knight
although I'm not I'm not sure I can I
can take it but because D4 is hanging I
don't know both sides are getting
checkmated
uh looks like white happens to be
checked gay check made it first yeah
because if you take on F on D4 the F2
Pawn is hanging which isn't good oof
yeah this is this is this is this is
just good for black yeah yeah there's a
Checkmate Yep this is just Checkmate
yeah so you can take on H4 and after uh
Queen takes H4 here you can't take on D7
as white but maybe there's this this
looks very suspicious for the white king
yeah
well by the way
um oh no I can't play Queen G5 check
because my the Pawn's on H4 still
otherwise we'd both be wondering yeah I
was like wait isn't the bishop hanging
yeah
well you can't really play chess like
this that it's hard to leave your Rook
right leaving all those pieces on the
first rank is uh not fun no it's not
and
you described to me maybe like Queen D3
to bring your queen to the oh did not
like that move oh because Queen G5 check
finally it works so Bishop E6 first I
guess and then try to bring the queen in
to D3 and
it still likes black but I mean material
is equal right so I like black too
The Rook on A1 Bishop on C1 are terrible
yeah if you only hit a couple more moves
to get Bishop B2 in The Rook over but we
all wish we had three moves to make
maybe Rook F4 here threading D4 and Rook
G4
I'll get a Richie for his Defender it is
okay let's play Rook F4 and double Rooks
and try to take on D4 sack all my pieces
they're not my pieces I can sacked them
hey you sound like me yeah take out E5 I
like taking on E5 now you're making
sense
now Robert's going to play one of his
patented Queen sacrifice
whether he wants to or not yeah these
are the feasts are under my control now
so I can sack the queen as I stop it but
what a wild looking position here and
Magnus did he play G6 or is that no
that's my analysis from before so he is
thinking in this moment here whether to
play G6 whether to play Bishop takes H4
and Ben I have a psychological question
for you do you think that where toxic
believes in a sacrifice
well I I think he believes he's fine
here yeah
yeah I think I mean he wouldn't sack a
piece if he thought I mean when he
played Bishop G4
um you know he probably thought if he
plays F5 I'm gonna sack a piece and he
did
otherwise Bishop G4 seems sort of silly
right
although you don't really have much of a
choice at this point because E5 is under
attack three different times and if you
take on F6 after Bishop takes F6 you
have D4
that's just lost because you can protect
it but the bishop and F3 is loose right
so I can take take and you know just
take this one here click on F3 yeah
miserable situation
so somehow I mean how does bands always
do this the position looked complicated
it looked like he might be struggling a
bit to find a concrete idea and then now
that we're looking a little more we're
like okay now white has sack recipes and
can
maybe at most making a media draw and
black can try to play for more took out
H4 yeah
everybody sacks a piece
Bishop takes H4 what a
big moment mm-hmm
and let's see if wattage's reaction here
yeah both players are upset
it was all blocked up you know and then
all of a sudden all heck broke loose
yes it's like my stream I said heck
My Stream is very G-rated yeah
why do they both look upset and who's
actually upset I don't know but neither
one looks like they're super pleased
I mean I I like black because I see a
rook on A1 a queen on B1 a bishop on C1
The Bishop's blocked by The Rook you
know and blacks Knights are ready to
take on E5 and D4 The Rook on f8 is
great whites King has almost nothing in
front of it obviously everything that I
think doesn't matter what matters is
calculation and you gotta trust magnus's
calculation because that's you know
Magnus isn't isn't going to calculate
and make a lot of errors in this kind of
position
so the one thing of note is that the h
Pawn being gone it's good for white just
in some regards because if I do take on
H7 and I can get my Rook to the H file
then the black king could just be
checkmated so I don't really see it it's
hard to get a rook to the H file yeah
well King G2 rookie I know it takes a
while yeah yeah it's a long story so you
think maybe uh White's not going to take
the bishop ever and just leave it there
because it's well then that Queen come
in is too dangerous
right but I just don't see how to do
that I can play Bishop B2 which is a
casual developing move but that looks
very casual yeah Queen G5
hitting this hitting this hitting G3
it's
this can't be good
I don't believe it anymore
Ben you don't believe in White's
position no I don't believe in White's
position right
Bishop takes H4 and
it's funny because it looked like black
was playing on the queen side and what
was playing on the king side the queen
side just got blocked up and then they
both played on the king side
and you know you Black's pieces are
coming alive on the king's side because
the f1's gone
um and the White Knight is gone on F3
then yeah I mean really really nice play
by Magnus to basically change the game
uh the flavor of the game
and yeah boytajik now in the think tank
trying to come up with a move but it's
not going to be easy and you're right
Magnus
definitely the happier of the two and uh
Bishop takes H4 was a nice shot so let's
uh leave Watashi to think we'll go over
to another game we haven't looked at the
game between yessa Panko and dubov and
that's a very elite matchup between two
of Russia's biggest talents and I see
that I thought we looked at this game in
the opening when blackhead played F
takes E6 was that this game it was this
game and it was right yeah we looked at
this position yeah but it seems like a
totally different game right and then we
were hoping that something would happen
something exciting and I think yessa
panko was also looking for something
that eventually happened and
they're just moving their kings of the H
file finally a capture but white has the
superior
Pawn Center here with the pawns more
advanced
D5
wait that's a Pawn sack so he gave up a
pawn
in the center of the board here when he
didn't have to
so it sounds like
yeah he protect his Knight by blocking
the attack and by pinning the Knight on
G3 yeah he's always fighting for the
initiative good move by yesapenko to hit
the queen
and well I just traded queens and thank
you for the pawn yeah he gave the pawn
he took it and said okay let's trade
Queens go to an end game
yeah I mean what's up a pawn and then B5
wow just
really opening things up here
takes here 97.
doesn't this just look amazing for white
yes
you had that answer lined up and this
one yeah
White's very pleased yeah
took a pawn and then yeah this is black
hoping he can draw but maybe it's uh
it's beyond hope
yeah like none of this worked out for
black
maybe he really hated his position and
he thought D5 was his best chance he
just didn't like it
I don't know there's something said
about these positions where you have the
good light Square control uh you know
black can keep the knights there and the
bishop on E5 it's a great piece because
it defends and he's defended by D4 while
putting some pressure on G7 but
maybe not the easiest position to
convert and that's yeah but plunges or
pawns he's two pawns up wow
it's very very tough for black to draw I
agree I think it's more likely white
wins right 100 agree with you looking
really nice for guest banko who defeated
famously Magnus Carlsen in the Viking
Zay tournament and the winner of this
match plays the winner of Carlson
against vortacek so that will be uh fun
to see no matter who it is so let's go
to this game I'm going to take us around
a bit because we've been away from
playing these games the idani game
against Duda where oh that eval bar is
going lower and lower I think that
Black's about to get checkmated but
according to but the engine says no
White's gonna get checked which
queen of six is the threat and Bishop
takes B3 stops the immediate threat and
probably just blasts open White's King
and
maybe doesn't look so good for dude
after all
wow Judah loses with white that's going
to be
a very unexpected result
that's for sure and it's it's
understating it
so wait a sec so Bishop takes B3 Pawn
takes B3
Knight takes Pawn takes
and
Queen
maybe just Rook takes B3 I don't know
but where things B3 then there's Rook A2
I think and just oh it doesn't like Rook
takes B3 yeah
I stopped your check man threatened one
of my own probably Bishop C4 might be
good there too threatening the maid on
d8 oh yeah and The Rook is coming A2 to
defend
so this is good for black we need to
find the right move
did a game just finish there well maybe
it is Queen maybe it is Queen A5 yeah
maybe you were right a game is Just
concluded and is that cart
the camera in the middle that looks like
it's a draw yes it's yeah reacting in
artemium and also ivich and on draken
they drew their game so the youngster
bellamere ivich still performing
extremely well and
um look at Magnus just standing Queen A5
is good here I think so
oh well it says it's not good maybe I'm
also looking at Queen A7 so I can go to
D4 yeah that's probably the movie I
don't know whenever I make a move it
says it says I'm the worst Rook A2 Queen
C3 check that was your idea oh you could
play Rook B2 and then you have King and
then you have King B1 yeah oh and
there's back rank me so you don't even
have Rook takes B3 right yeah so with
the queen on D4 ah this is a very
important
Nuance here is that F here Queen D4
check yeah now there's no back rank too
yeah we have routines B3 because the
queen stops and check yep yep that's
cool
now the thing is if black doesn't play
crazy like that I think he's in trouble
he's got he's like forced to play Crazy
I see a move has just been played and it
was not crazy it was F6 never play F6
never
ever
don't do it
so Queen takes F6 Bishop takes B3 is
probably the idea and imagine
wait how does this
and how does white save this
you can play one of Robert's Infamous
Queen sex Queen takes C6
no I don't think that's gonna hold here
but you know what Mike Queen G7 check
wow it's like my pieces under attack
your piece is on under attack this
bishop this bishop yeah I need an adult
here
at least one
Bishop takes eight yeah but the engine
doesn't like F6 because you know it
thinks it thought black could sacrifice
and get a big attack there
mm-hmm
it doesn't say Black's lost here but it
just thought it gave away Black's
Advantage yeah
and there might even be defensive moves
that white can try not just you play
Bishop takes B3 you better have it
calculated at the end
it's true
and speaking of calculation I mean we
have the cameras on Carlson and voytacek
and Watashi is trying to figure this out
I think that Magnus is the happier of
the two oh yeah no for sure yeah
and what does it really doesn't seem
thrilled
and where to go to from here so we can
leave them on camera but we can also
just pop around how's our buddy cindero
doing
we uh
haven't gone to see hit okay really
they're they're moved 22 but it looks
like you know no action has taken place
and all these other positions are crazy
yeah I think this is just better for
white though right yeah not winning but
yeah it's just better for white two
Center pawns a files open black played
F6 so and throw that in there Casper
pure Rune is a multi-time puzzle solving
Champion yeah yeah he's a brilliant
tactician and calculator so
he he's not getting into that position
that he would Thrive at this is a very
solid position for white no tactical
exploits to be had so looks great yeah
two or three days ago uh don you said
that Casper's not being friendly and I
was like well I like that pun you know
Casper the Friendly Ghost I got you but
yeah he's uh he's being friendly this
game he is indeed it looks like White's
doing pretty well and the A7 punch such
a weakness and it can't go anywhere
because the B4 pawn stops an A5 push and
the Knight is stuck on B5 which is kind
of awkward
yeah I much prefer cindero's position
here yeah
no and and you know I we don't want to
overstate how well he's doing but I
seriously thought before this match he's
the favorite
just based on the way they're playing
this tournament right I mean cindar this
is important that grishook said when he
came out for an interview he's like you
know some 25 50s or 2700 and he believes
the cindarov uh is one of those because
he's 15 years old he's playing like a
monster against Ali raise a faruga he
drew both classical games from I think a
position of strength in both and then in
the tie breaks he didn't look like the
worst player he looked at the better
player and he won the tie breaks and I'm
not saying that I'm the younger player
yeah yeah I'm not saying that he's
better likes that he's like yeah he's
like oh my opponent's younger than me
that's never happened
and well I didn't pay off for others in
this field so see I don't like that move
though
that is a uh what's the word I want to
say not bad it's a um
you know he's not slowly pressing his
Advantage it looks like he's
you know he thinks it's really good
because if he didn't think it was really
good you just wouldn't play it and uh it
doesn't look really good it just looks
like it's going to Peter out to a draw
yeah no it looks like they're going to
trade everything now
right I mean there's multiple news here
Knight D4 is possible because if you
take on A7 black can probably just take
on B3 and get into this position yeah
probably white thought this was good
because he's maybe winning a pawn or two
maybe he thought that
maybe he can't take on on D3 because uh
I mean originally maybe maybe this is
what he has to do
um if he
yeah if he takes on D3 I can take and
play Knight C1 right
at the very least yeah nice yeah
nice find
the knights under attack this was The
Rook
yeah so C4 sort of immediately gets The
Rook to A7 so he couldn't uh help
himself he had to do it I don't really
I mean let's look at State seven it's
your result game so all right that is
true they're gonna win or Draw so Knight
D6 though if you take on A7 you lose C
or E4
yeah okay but you're not attacking you
know my Depot anymore so I can move my
queen and pretend that I'm much better
pretending's fun
yeah I mean night seats a bit passive so
I don't know D4 confusing the audience
after an ICA
before in a row Connect Four yeah
weird position
I like white now yeah yeah but it's
weird strange Pawn structure
is a bit harsh but it just seems like it
creates such a clear problem in the
position that you could have sat on the
position and just shuffled around
improved your chances right down the
line and I think a more experienced
player would have waited to place yeah
C4 is a real young players move yeah
calculate C4 and old guys like me are
just like I have a better Pawn structure
black doesn't have counter play I'm
gonna slowly improve those guys just
calculated and like based on their
calculation their calculation is really
good so
certainly is
so let's uh keep on going around here it
looks like you're going to keep it on
Main developments in federal Sav against
kovalev so let's get this position up
and well that bar is very high in man
that c Pawn looks good Rick D at 97
looks good looks good
yeah what's the material it's even
material somehow yeah but I'm
threatening C6 C7 to see it in Rook d89
I mean well this doesn't look good for
black no it was completely winning for
white yeah this is terrible yeah
I mean it's just yeah white spawns are
queening and black spawns will never
Queen no
and well we were around here when we
last left off so I just want to see how
the Breakthrough happened G4 hey Robert
let me give you something look at the
clocks look at them
are you kidding me
are you are you kidding
oh Federal save too fast
crazy I mean he just played like a model
game he just yeah he plays really fast
and really well
look at his pawns yeah he's just
smooshing them yeah
and oh E5 it's a move that you never
really want to play because D6 is just
so terrible after that
so it looks like he was able to just
start I mean White's position was just
always good
and Knight D7 wins a piece and also
protects C5 and just wins the game on
the spot
and King G7 but okay Rook takes f8 just
resigns
but I assume so yeah
so this will be the first decisive game
of the round of 32 in the world cup and
federal save is looking I would say it
was a beast I hope adibun doesn't sue me
but yeah he's he said Jose of his uh he
can win a lot of games in a row against
even people who are high rated than him
he's a beast he really is and I'm just
looking at his results here in the World
Cup he beat Axel Bachmann in both games
and then he went one half out of two
against Timor Graf and now he's winning
the first game against a lot of South
kovalev so the guy will about to be four
and a half out of five in his classical
games here
not bad
yeah that was really nice how he beat
Gareth with the black pieces
yeah he
I think he got a lot of he was getting a
lot of Queens his pawns were really far
Advanced on the queen side yeah one
Queen wasn't enough he just needed
that's right I gotta get a lot of Queens
well it might not be enough here either
you might want to get two queens
[Laughter]
we'll get a resignation before that but
yeah yeah we will for sure and oh wow
just to continue bopping around a bit
and rookie Cafe was played by
you have 37
I guess kovalev can should play on but
he's completed he should all right the
game between Duda and idani had the
queen takes F6 and then after Bishop
takes B3 Queen G7 check was in fact
played so this is the live position
after all
and what a weird position it is
yeah the engine thinks it's equal
because it always thinks everything's
equal
what's the material count is white up a
pawn White's up a pawn White's
threatening Bishop takes E5 I assume
so black has to you know do something
maybe bishop takes C2
uh
[Music]
let's see do I believe that
yes
I think Bishop C2 Rook right two King
just seven yep and double up oh you
could play Knight takes D3 that's funny
yeah yeah you get to escape and uh-huh
nope
like this Black's at least fine yeah
Black's King is better than white so
it could be better for black
yeah so what a game this could be for
the young Iranian player uh not as young
as on the other participants but still I
think he's in early 20s so would be nice
for him and
um well Duda maybe not proving as much
as he would like from this first game
but still plenty of
foreign
game to be played after this whole
sequence so yeah there's no easy
opponents you don't get this far by
being easy no
we'll see but right now I think we're
going to take a break I know I need to
stretch my legs and see sitting in this
chair for so long and we'll come back as
the action heats up we get near the time
Patrol and we'll see if other players
are like ferroseia with humongous leads
in the clock and dominating positions
but for now it is break time more from
the fide World Cup and Women's World Cup
when we return
foreign
[Music]
new merch is available on the chess.com
store go to go.chess.com merch and use
the code World Cup one word to get 10
off on all chess.com products this code
remains for the remainder of the World
Cup so do not miss your chance to get
the cool merchandise you see on screen
in front of you and many more options
but there's chess being played we have
many games still remaining I just pulled
up the game between Anna music and
Elizabeth Pitts and a lot has happened
since we left off with the bishop hair
for black and down a pawn black remains
down the pawn but there's only one
Bishop remaining on the board for black
so Ben your gut instinct here what's it
telling you does white have chances here
with the extra material or is black just
doing fine
you know we we might see a repetition
here if uh if black wants it with Queen
H1 Knight G1 Queen H5 because I think
white just played Knight F3
to stop Queen takes Rook mate
right um yeah and King E2 is probably oh
you can't take on G2 yeah if you take
Rook G1 that's is that amazing is that
true it is true wow
well I guess after King E2 I could just
move my queen back to H5 and why is your
King on E2 but you are a pawn up
right so like can I play A4 you don't
have a check on E8 my queen on d7s yeah
King I E2 is solid yeah although Rook B8
Rook B2 looks it's pretty scary yeah
oh yeah I mean black just has
recompensation for a pawn so I'm not not
even sure which side I want
me neither
so yeah and it's just it's like exactly
upon's compensation
yeah black wins a pawn back somehow
which doesn't I don't see how then I'll
take black but if somehow white
consolidates and stops Black's
initiative then White's doing really
well
I don't know somehow I like black I just
I'm afraid to have white here
I just don't feel afraid of nothing but
I'm still afraid yeah I just see how
black makes progress necessarily because
the queen H1 as you pointed out you can
just make a repetition so
in in that regard I sort of want white
but I agree with you all right I guess
we'll have to play here white and I'm
black okay well agree to disagree huh
I mean rookie Eight's possible or am I
blundering a piece with Queen C6
probably
that's how I do it
the engine's not impressed it just says
that's equal yeah I guess you have Queen
A5 Maybe
aha
I'm just getting defensive oh yeah
nothing smart about it
um
so yeah maybe black is just doing fine
here
and let's uh let's keep on going in this
Women's World Cup only 16 players remain
so let's check out some of the other
matches where is goryoteka here is her
game where she's playing against
Antoinette stefanova and material count
extra Pawn for white this pawn and C5
may not be that much longer for this
game however taking immediately will
backfire because you're walking into a
pin and you've seen the eval bar
Skyrocket and Rook C1 I believe just
gets the piece yeah that's too early to
take it this is another position where
Black's down upon let me instead of
taking out C5 and has excellent
compensation
although you probably need to be
accurate to maintain that compensation
because Bishop F1 is already a threat
it's always play Bishop F1 always and
here especially so what does Black's
move actually to keep the momentum
well I could either move my queen or my
knight I guess to make bishop F1 less uh
aggressive I'm not sure if I should play
Knight E5 or queen before
um got to do something otherwise as you
said Bishop F1 is too strong
right and then I can then go to E5
hitting this Pawn the bishop comes to E2
then D2 as an option right yeah black
has plenty of compensation here and
probably is doing just fine
yeah these positions are so difficult
there's
I I keep saying it but this is such a
refreshing uh tournament compared to you
know some things that we've seen in the
past where it was
it wasn't fighting like this wait she
took on C5
that's not my analysis
no way
no way she took a C5
nothing better than that oh because she
probably thinks after B3 right you're
trying to exploit the pin but Queen D4
yeah Queen D4 Queen E5 yeah it says
black is completely winning oh my
goodness Rook D2
oh oh that is just nasty wow and if
Queen C4 rookie won wow oh my God that's
awesome yeah
that's just meat yeah that's awesome
yeah
so she's hoping for that but the problem
is after Brooks Rook C1 was played oh my
gosh you don't have Rook D2 because
Queen takes D2 and there's a pin down
the C file now you just lose all your
material did she see Rook C1 or she only
saw B3 and was really happy about it now
there's no way she saw Rook C1 yeah
because Rook C1 if you see it you're
like I guess I shouldn't take that
because B3 is a little more obvious than
Rook C1 than she sees Rook D2 wins
and that's very risky to play Queen C5
it's a risky move because you're pinning
your diet
complete oversight by I mean an amazing
player great has been on a crazy role at
least she finished I think in third
place in the
um Russian Champion higher League
Championship I forget the exact name
where she beat many strong players like
Alexis Serana and drev and then she's
been great in the World Cup Women's
World Cup this far but then she just had
an oversight here above an outright
blunder from a player who's been on an
absolute Terror
yeah it's just a blunder I mean I she
moved quickly so I don't know what's
going on what did she do
um I saw her move
what does she play Rook ed3
yeah and she did it pretty quickly
okay well
oh that's Queen C4 this Rook D1 check
okay so this position so she didn't just
blunder in one move that was yeah she
saw this and there's a winning move here
for white we're not seeing
what is that move Bishop F1 I play Rook
D2 yeah you don't want to see Rook D2
happen no
I think I got it Ben
I think we'll give it to me I think it's
good for it I'm over all my sicknesses
yeah
because you're trying to distract the
queen away from this pin
um one of the important things to note
is that if a queen takes C4 there's Rook
D1 check and
after Rook takes D1 Rook takes D1 check
again and your queen is lost because
there's nothing you do guys like Queen
F1 and who's your queen there so
B4 distracts the queen so after Queen
takes before Queen takes D4 Rook D1
check yeah yeah Bishop F1 or Rook F1 and
you just skipped today yep wow B4 is
that's what she missed she she saw Rook
C1 Rook D3 right but she didn't see B4
which
I'm not sure if I would see that I'm not
sure White's gonna see it that's such a
strange wolf I I didn't even see it
until I see the eval bar still really
high for white and then like okay
there's something here so I need to
distract this queen away from
C5
is B4 the only good move I think it is
let's see
I mean
the blacks I mean Rook D2 is a serious
threat
and maybe before is the only move
wow
honestly I could see white losing this
game in two moves
yeah if she doesn't play B4 I think
she's in trouble
she plays B4 then she's gonna win yeah
Jesus wow this is this is an important
moment
and how much time it she has under eight
minutes remaining if the clocks are
correct here so
not much time before is easy when
somebody shows it to you right and after
you that but if you don't then it's not
easy and you have the when you have the
eval bar you just see oh there's a win
for white somewhere you find it in in
her mind she's like oh shoot Rook ed3
there's rookie two is the threat Rook D1
check or my take on C4 I need to work
that out and
well what to do here but I uh B4 is just
such a nice shot that I admittedly did
not see at first either so
a surprise
and that's really hard to see yeah and
the idea is that Rick D1 loses its
strength when the Queen's done on C5
attacking The Rook on C1 V and x-ray man
that's
hard to understand but true
do you think that so find B4
yeah
I think it's uh very close to 50 50. but
the move is so crazy I'm going to say
it's less than 50 50.
so I think it's like
I think it's a two to one shot I don't
think she's gonna find it she looks a
bit nervous I mean that move is so hard
to find yeah it's really just out of
nowhere obviously when the bar tells you
and you know okay but if you're playing
the game
wow before such a crazy winner
it's just six minutes and yeah and the
idea for those of you at home is if I
take on C4 and you play Rook D1 check
Bishop F1 the the queen is defending on
C1 so you play Rook takes C1
foreign
is on B4 then that that doesn't work
that's why B4 is so strong but that's
man that's a tough move to see
and now I'll be really impressed if she
plays B4 and you know I'm thinking that
black Seas before now
um that's what I think and that she's
just like okay don't play B4 and people
ask what about B for Queen B6 and it's a
great question Queen takes C4 you have
this check but after
um Bishop to F1 which was Ben's point
that this queen on C5 is no longer there
hitting the Rook on C1 so if you take on
C1 the queen just takes right back if
I'm black I'm getting up and leaving
because I don't want to give away B4 I
don't want my if I see it if I see B4
I'm leaving I'm walking around looking
confident
although
based on the time consumption right now
I wonder if Stefan was just trying to
find a move and because her position
looks really tough if she does not play
B4 then she might stumble into it based
on that yeah she'll be she'll be a
heroin or she put oh King H1 King H1
that was like the safe move that that
um is not that's not good yeah she
didn't find B4 it's just really hard a
cage one actually might still be a good
move because black is tangled up here
King H1 is the move I was thinking of
when I didn't see B4
because I was trying to get out of this
pen and the evil bar has stayed at plus
three oh that's also good I thought that
I mean White's not even threatening
Queen takes C4 anymore no oh actually
yes no are you because if Queen takes
out oh Queen takes D3 yeah wow
I just thought White's threatening B3
which is good enough
that is the threat here
black should see I understand black not
seeing B4
I saw King H1 but I thought black would
have a lot of moves here but I guess
black doesn't have a lot of moves here
no and maybe in her mind when she was
busy I didn't see Queen takes D3 yeah
she probably thought oh I'll play Queen
D4 get out of the pin the road is uh
under attack on F2 but after Queen C4
right yeah if Queen takes D3 doesn't
exist black has a lot of moves yes but
but now black doesn't have any of those
moves because Queen takes D3 wins yeah
and it looks like just getting left is
too slow
then probably be three wins right so you
put H5 versus H6 then yeah then yeah
then
yeah we stopped Queen D3 but we're still
pinned and the Annoying Thing for black
because you never have Rook D2 because
you take and then take a second time
right you don't even take the Knight on
C4 which you can but Queen takes D4
inches ends the discussion
wow
yeah I thought after King H1 black could
just get out of this pin but she can't
no yeah Queen takes D3 is a cool tactic
yeah
so I think stefanova is about to score a
huge object of course she is a brilliant
player or former women's world champion
yeah she's won this world cup event
before until she became the world
champion and you know a really really
tough opponent but this is surprising I
must admit I thought that gory oxygen
was kind of Unstoppable these days in
these women's events but right now
Stefano was giving her all she can
handle
yeah I thought black just had a lot of
things to do here because I didn't see
Queen takes D3 now there's very little
to do
yeah there's there's tricks but they
don't work
no tricks
the king h1's like is I didn't like it
as much as before because my Rook on F2
is not defended but it's indirectly
defended because the queen takes D3
tactical difference always the best way
yeah
well let's um leave this game for now it
looks like it's going to be a big upset
and we're actually going to lose her
first game of the event uh let's go to
just one of you quickly here Zach meezi
and shuvalova are playing and I saw this
Knight on F6 and this Pawn structure for
white at the corner I assumed why I was
doing well and then I just have noticed
it's Black's turn and you can take this
Pawn in H3
foreign
also
I guess in some positions we can take on
E5 maybe Knight D5 is a good response
but yeah obviously the king side counter
play is is great
oh this King on E7 could be checkmated
at like any moment
these things happen sometimes you get
checkmated
um you play F4 here for white for kids
two try to grab this Pawn
actually how does black move here
seems like a bind I'm forced to make a
move yeah terrible
not easy
no
like The Rook camera would be so seven
because there's Rook D7 check the Rook
on h8 can't go anywhere of note oh who's
playing I'm thinking about uh Knight B8
to D7 because I like retreating
always retreat
so like if I broke D2 even in stock your
knights from yeah but I I could play H2
and 97 if I want to but
I can't very fair point white should
still be better in these lines but
yeah so
I mean it's tough for black you gotta
you gotta risk it gotta restate the
business let's go to the game that we
see on screen here between
and durability whoa
what what has happened so White's done
in exchange still for a pawn still
but yeah I mean the king 97 looks good
it doesn't need
I mean Black's just better right much
better the pawn is stuck what's the time
situation also good for black
but they only have four moves to make
till time
so okay enough for white yeah it looks
good for black yeah yeah Dura Bailey
trying to
land a very important win because
great opening prep so let's uh let's go
back to Magnus because
um his game looks kind of crazy as these
two players still are making moves
well we went on break like like uh
voltage still hadn't moved
so finally he made a lot of moves
so this is the live position and Magnus
just made a move did he play Knight F3
uh yes there's a knight on F3 yeah okay
so Queen takes F3 is the only move
because you get checkmated if you don't
take it they're getting checkered it's
bad yeah Queen be queenie one's made
yeah right so here yeah okay
yeah and King G2 is the same just Queen
H2 and queen G1
yeah very easy Checkmate so
the queen sacrificed on F3 yeah they
already did you already did it yep I see
eight this has been played
what do you make of this fence so we're
looking two Bishops for a queen but
White's King is very suspicious and The
Rook on a1's no good Bishop's unsee it's
not defended Magnus doesn't have lift
yet she has to watch out
so that's very scary for both sides it
looks like I without analyzing I would
take black because I don't like White's
King
okay Rook Cafe attacking the bishop and
stopping the back rank mate
oh and
okay Rook of Fate so the problem for
white right now is where to put this
bishop actually
I mean I want to play safe and play like
Bishop B7 to G2 although take taking my
B Pawn is annoying but maybe that's just
the way it goes
I think you have to do something like
that because if you go Bishop to D7 or
something like this then Rook d8 is very
annoying just trying to take and give
you a check and if you play Bishop E6
you're walking into no yeah yeah that's
right
ooh coffee delivery thank you
go Karen man that's hot be careful I'll
have to assume I have to sue my own
chest center it's too hot
wait what happened here I wish you can
corabaugh have finished their game base
they drew I see the Kings on e4 and E5
yeah it wasn't the most exciting game no
I was predicting a long time ago that
would be a draw yeah
so it looks like they were both happy
with the draw I think Federal say I'm
still the only person who has uh won a
game in this round thus far
and I mean voltage isn't necessarily
lost even though you know his King is
suspicious and is hasn't moved his Queen
side pieces this game
what's funny is
if the engine says it's about equal
um it's the kind of position where
if black doesn't play well
or misses anything eventually
White's going to be winning eventually
if I can just cheat and play Bishop G2
Bishop D2 double Rooks on the D file
sorry attacking G7 I mean
White's gonna have a an initiative
against the black king with the bishop
on B2 and the Rooks coming in so if
Magnus goes too far trying to win he
could get in trouble it's not something
usually does so but it does happen and I
I'm with you there Ben yeah I mean he
likes to win so and you have to make
sure that white doesn't get untangled
and then start attacking with you know
his Rooks and Bishops all right this
bishop gets the B2 and G7 is a problem
yeah white yeah I mean black has to be
careful at some point just not right now
we did see
um both siddler and vitugo on screen
briefly I'm gonna flash their board they
drew a game that didn't look the most
exciting although in this entire
position
white appears to be slightly better
based on the pawn structure yeah and
they just agreed on a draw
unless oh maybe King E5 wasn't the move
and that's just right they always put
the kings in the middle like King E5
doesn't make a lot of Team E5 makes no
sense to me because you just give the
Rook right yeah yeah direct line over to
B5 but either way game was a draw so
let's uh oh
right here hike Marty Rosa with a past B
Pawn Auntie berkitch trying to survive
this one here with the black pieces
will he be able to succeed
wow this is an interesting this is again
one of those positions where like I
could see either side winning if the B
Pawn doesn't Queen and black takes
White's King side that's not good for
white but that B Pawn looks awfully
strong
that's true awfully strong
and we have Duda on camera just walking
around dude is looking confident over
there I'm not sure if he should but it's
walking around like a boss
yeah this game is easy let's look at
other games yeah that's what he's
thinking
d8 plane so is that how's it stopping
the bee Pawn
um I guess B6 Bishop C8
and then I mean you asked me to stop the
V Pawn but yeah I was just gonna Rook C7
and mm-hmm
um no comment you can come after the bee
Pawn but then you drop F7 oh yeah that's
right you can't play B7 right now no
yeah but let's say I go Rook F6 Knight
takes D5 is
uh-huh yep
I mean this is no this is this can I can
I I can't do that I was gonna take on B6
and resign after Rook C8 it's important
to resign yeah
um
uh yeah this looks really good for white
not I mean not blundering the piece
this looks really good for white
and height March your ocean that would
be another excellent game from him as he
did knock out Shakira Mama jar of a top
10 player and would like to see his
World Cup Adventure continued as he's
the last Armenian player remaining
so let's uh oh by the way prognanda and
mvl did draw their game so many draws
this round
yeah that's going to happen more and
more draws because the players are
getting to be about the same strength so
let's see is that by Crow I was gonna
say how is that buck Row game going so
let's well yeah that is bakra right then
how is this King on A3
yeah
what's happening here why why is the I'm
so confused
okay let's go back wow Bishop G5
yeah what happened here 94 Queen takes
B3 so you didn't play Queenie one Knight
A5 Queen A2
so why is just giving everything away
white is up two pawns yeah and Bishop D7
wow that's an interesting move and not
approved up by the yeah that's a strange
move Rook F6 and then Knight E5 giving
up the queen because Knight F7 check
mm-hmm
Rook takes B2 because of course wow this
game is the remove is amazing
uh King takes B2 oh
yeah the idea is I guess Queen BH check
you don't have Knight F7 check
but the Eva bar starts swinging right
but that's the idea yeah so King A3 yeah
the engine likes it
Bishop takes Queen B6 because wow I
thought it was I thought it was a typo
but yeah
the pawn has been Bishop F7 Queen F6
because of course the queen wanted to go
from B8 to F6
Bishop G5 and now wow and the engine
doesn't like Bishop G5 no
and then Knight takes G5 H takes G5
Queen takes five but now it loves it
wait so go back why Why didn't it like
does it change its mind or did it is
Bishop G5 a mistake I think there's
Bishop takes C5 check and then take this
Knight on E5
looks so scary oh if I I'm looking at
King A2 but I'm too old for that
King A2 Knight C right but even I'm
still confused like King eight
I always play King A1 no but King A1
there's Knight B3 check what was the
main ship defending B3 oh
wait
[Laughter]
uh yeah I got nothing for you can you
one
yeah the engine says Black's winning now
what but how I don't know I completely
missed that the bishop can take oh can
you play Queen D6 oh wait it likes
Knight B3 I blundered but it loves it
what the
it likes my blunder because probably
Queen B6 now hitting there for it
hitting yeah yeah wow
oh my God I can see why black didn't
play Bishop C5 because nobody can see
any of this no this is just absurd right
okay so instead of blunder I mean
probably bakaro didn't see that either
he's like I Bishop C5 I don't care about
that right
right
yeah the black King's looking bad
yeah
looking bad
oh this is an easy one right I can just
take everything it looks like it should
be an easy win yeah this is why can't I
just take everything I check here and
then and then rip track and Rick takes
G6 check
can you play Bishop d8 there after
instead of moving the king no
well I'm trying
no I mean yeah this looks absolutely
absurd yeah
it's funny King D4 looks good but Queen
D2 check it's funny
I'm making H7 oh this is the actual game
yeah so wait Bishop G6 check
who hates that move look at that yeah I
hated that move it's a free Pawn with
check
doesn't like it because Queen D2 is
happening and things like that chess is
a ridiculous game
so let's see
so I played Rook B8 King
I'm not yet hasn't played yet
how do you win this game
I have a crazy idea but give me a second
okay it's crazy though
yeah my crazy idea doesn't work
oh my crazy idea really doesn't work
okay now I can never tell anybody
because it's embarrassing
um
yeah what do I do here I have I don't
want them to play Queen D2
so then play Rook D1
I'm not good enough to play Rook V1
I was really saying it just uh yeah I
can't I can't find a move like that
but maybe maybe it's just a calm move
that's required maybe yeah humans are so
bad at just making moves like this and
I'm just saying it should stop your
planet wasn't actually just half ingest
but now
maybe it's the move
I want to do something with white I want
to sack everything and made them but I
don't see
anything like that
there's a just an absolutely ridiculous
game
I wonder if there's something better
than Rook b a check although that looks
really strong
wow
these two have been playing
fascinating battle
so I was trying to look at
my attention was caught by other games
Ben and I need you to explain something
to me so we're going to go look before
you say anything go ahead okay no no
don't laugh at me yes F4
so you're giving up the G3 yes yes King
King B4 what yeah
yeah if you move your knight I have Rook
H6 Rook G6
oh
yeah so what if oh King no you're I'm
gonna take your knight
you are you're not gonna play King I'll
keep walking up yeah
take that night
that was my idea
approved by the way if I don't take the
night
probably Rick hg1 wins yeah only this
doesn't this looks not very maybe yeah I
don't know but I I like my crazy idea
yeah it's cool yeah when I'll use the
engine I have crazy ideas otherwise this
play the best engine move
um maybe I should stop using the engine
forever so I can play really badly I
agree
not with the badly part but with the
yeah but F4 is a really interesting move
I don't know if it's good but it's
interesting well he played for a PhD he
checked yeah
um but I had a question on the Magnus
game so okay I'm gonna hop there real
quick because yeah time trouble is
coming so the games are going to get all
crazy now
like what is this Rook on eight these
Rooks solid it's almost as if you want
to pass Pawn but you don't have one
mm-hmm so how did this happen it's a
knight of three check
here Queen F6 oh you have to play that
move why do you have to play it what am
I missing everything well you can't go
Rook B1 because Queen G6 checked I agree
you can't play Bishop B2 because Queen
G5 check I agree what if I play the
other Rook to A2 now what is Queen E7
and queen E1 wow
everything
wow so we have to play that yeah I
wonder if Magnus saw all this in his
head and then stopped here like this
looks ridiculous for white uh-huh
I mean I would be scared to have black I
would think that if white consolidates
I'm losing like Bishop E3 double on the
D file I'm scared of that I don't I
don't like two Rooks and two Bishops
when I'm black no I don't like it I'm
not saying that White's doing well I
just I'd be afraid with black
but maybe voitashek has no fear
yeah no I mean if I was Magnus I'd be
afraid here
uh no I'm completely with you I think
that Magnus is
in real danger right now because these
Bishops the engine says it's okay but I
think it's hard to play Black
I mean white just activates his pieces
you probably have to play perfectly for
black just to be okay yeah because I can
see white like getting a big attack here
isn't I wasn't watching too closely
because it was a nerve-wracking moment
but in the Juma bye of carwana game
didn't the engine say like it was equal
and then one move later it was just yeah
that's happening in a lot of games this
tournament yeah these are tricky
positions everything's fine I resigned
no
so
I guess it draws the most likely result
but I if I was playing somebody My Level
I would say quiet
I just wouldn't want to have black here
because I'd be afraid
I'm in complete agreement I think that
White's position is to be preferred and
not only
okay so Rook d8 played I guess there's
some kind of Rook D1 check that you did
think about yeah black and trade Rooks
it's less likely he'll get attacked and
that his b-pawn is probably stronger and
rookie two here what if I just start
centralizing my pieces
because Rook D1 does look pretty
annoying
so like if I've ever E2 and you play
Rook D1 check I can just
I was gonna play rookie one but I'm not
so sure about this
and the engine hates it clearly
yeah this just looks like a position
where
[Music]
I thought that'd be good for white but
maybe you're defending here too
clutch
well the bishop D4 still looks good I
don't like it facing the Bishops in The
Rook well I agree I'm I'm really scared
if I'm black here but the engine's not
scared
no emotions yeah
so
how many more moves until time until
they're just played 35th move Rook to d8
so Magnus with just over two minutes boy
tajik with five and counting down
wow this is
a nerve-wracking moment before but these
games all remind me of something funny
when when I'm at a tournament especially
like in my chess Center often
you know especially in swisses in rounds
one and two I'm severely outrating my
opponent and
when the game is over people are like
was that easy and I'm like it's never
easy like I could be playing a 1200
player and it's not easy just nothing's
easy and so even if Magnus wins this
game it's not like oh Magnus is higher
rated and he won it's such a battle it
is every game is possible and that's the
thing about Chess right any individual
game the yeah it's all your energy in
every game yeah and the lower rate
player can win but of course if they
played a 10 game match then that's where
you would see one size yeah yeah I could
be the 1210 game match yeah yeah
but each individual game
you know a lot of Club players are just
like well that higher rated player won
that higher rated player one what an
easy first round but man some of those
games aren't easy
speaking of not easy we're just being
informed in the chat that Auntie berkish
made a bad blunder on the 40th move man
the truth hurts I'm gonna quickly pull
up that game right back here but the
40th move Bishop to E6 apparently is a
blunder
and I mean the evil or Skyrocket it
means that something like Knight B5 B7
is just oh because there's no Rook B2
you can't even attack my knight so
Knight B5 I should just do the trick
yeah that seems to win right away Knight
B5
yeah
but what if he didn't play Bishop E6 was
he okay
let's see it says uh what
it's like well we were looking at Rook
B6 but you thought Knight D5 was great
that's probably why he played Bishop E6
he was afraid at 85. true but black is
of course worse no matter what but it
seems like Bishop B6 is just
that tragic 40th move blunder yeah
and well what hike has the time to
figure it out he doesn't have just 10
minutes he gained 30 minutes of the
clock so he might be a good timing yeah
work through this and there could be
other moves that are winning but Knight
B5 just to play B7 looks good enough
right
all right so let's um
check out let's go around the horn a bit
just check out some of these games did
it and Jeffrey Jean woo
somehow Jeffrey is like the best
position ever
yeah I I I refuse to ever play Jeffrey
again
but I don't like it what just happened
what game just ended magnus's game ended
what how could it have ended
what happened
did they agree to a draw nobody can
resign here no Magnus must have offer to
draw
yeah I guess they agreed to withdraw
because uh that's the only result that
makes any sense well and even that
doesn't make too much sense and it makes
a little sense but yeah not too much
this is one of those reasons where you
know I don't blame either player it's
within the rules of Chess but ban the
draw for
right yeah the The Spectators and the
commentators want to see what's going to
happen yeah ban the draw for mm-hmm
and it's just some really smart
psychological play by Carlson because if
boy tajik plays on he needs to prove
something right you're probably offering
you a draw you feel like well Magnus
either must see something or just iffy
spot but Magnus just wants the white
pieces in game two and to use that to
his advantage
but surprising and now they're just
chatting about the game that was yeah
that game was too interesting there's a
lot to chat about yeah maybe can uh do
does anyone have the Arbiter on speed
dial can you yeah thanks Arbiter make
sure we can't yeah
they're just analyzing the game going
over stuff the arbor is like hey that's
interesting analysis let me hear
oh gosh well I think for Magnus it's a
good result you had a topsy-turvy game
with the black pieces you make a draw
now with the white piece of tomorrow you
can play for win but didn't seem like
Magnus had a big advantage of something
I like magnus's position yeah but then I
I mean like here both sides are risking
a lot
I mean you got to be careful with both
sides here and the engine says it's
equal right that's a pretty cool thing
they put voltage Rook never moved
let's move 35 in the rookies yeah yeah
stayed on A1 the whole game
although yeah what I I told sponsky that
and he said uh in his match with Ian
Fisher they'll hold my beer I think
Fisher didn't move one of his Rooks and
it was like a seven Evil game well if we
had ended the game just a move ago
before Bishop E3 you could have said
both these pieces hadn't moved that's
right the bishop on C1 had removed until
the very end yeah so finally the bishop
develops and of course the game must
come Magnus is like all right if you're
gonna move your Bishop okay fine yeah
uh well they are I guess Zoidberg went
up to the players and said stop the game
it's too exciting and they went all
right yeah they're agreeable folks so
let's uh see what's happening in some of
these other games that are go back to
Jeffrey because Jeffrey was looking good
okay I have Jeff you were both surprised
because it looked like Vivid had no
problem
it did seem that way and now it seems
yeah six is good the back rank Checkmate
is good this is tough to play Black
has 20 seconds left what move number is
it it's a 37.
so a black letter not blunder here okay
G6 engine doesn't like it too much what
what other move was there besides G6
what's the threat
Rook B checkmate there's a rook on B4 oh
not Ricky
oh boy oh boy
never mind I'm gonna pretend like that
moment didn't happen don't know what the
threat is
yeah one of the reasons white has a big
Advantage here isn't necessarily the
Checkmate which is good but the A6 Pawn
is a lot better than the A7 Point that's
right
that's right because that's on my queen
so take on B7 ever precisely because of
that yeah so this is this is tough for
black it's not easy to play Black here
I guess he couldn't play Queen E5
because his rook's hanging
um
yeah it's hard for black to ever play
Queen E5 right can can white play Queen
D2 now hitting the rook and hitting the
H6 Pawn hitting the rook in the H6 Pawn
um
uh uh
I'm trying to find a move for black
I don't have one but the engine doesn't
say plus eight
but no I don't I don't see a move for
black there
that looks tough
I don't know and I'm not sure if it
knows either I'm not sure I don't see
any move but wouldn't the engine thing
go all the way to the Top If that just
went instantly
so there's
I don't see any move
I have no idea but we are Buffy plays
Queen D2 we'll find out oh he did he did
okay good now we'll find out
now we'll find the great move for black
that none of us see yeah the engine says
Black's fine
yeah and the players are really I don't
I don't I don't see
I don't know
Rook somewhere you have to move the Rook
off the B file I assume
yeah 15 seconds left for visit if this
is right I don't know what to do I guess
he's gonna show us
or he'll just lose on time I don't know
I wouldn't want to have black here and
have to move in seconds so Rook C4
played and if Queen takes H6 there might
be Rook C1 check for like Queen takes D5
check something like that uh-huh
that defends B8 too so that's good
yeah if you play Rook be a check now
King G7
yeah
so Queen takes H6 you know I can't play
Queen F4 because Knight E2 check
actually Queen A6 mine even run to 92 as
well there are some checkmates that
block is trying to yeah
to make work
all right both players could lose this
and before the time control it's moved
39 about to be one million years less
than a minute yeah yeah
okay so what to do here Rook C4 might
have been the only move
and it looks scary
no I agree because E5 is hanging
you can't even defend E5
Jeffrey must have moved because he's
writing something down
okay let's
Bishop takes G6 I saw that move but I
didn't like it I didn't think that
worked so
Pawn G6 Queen I thought you could just
check and take on E5 with check or maybe
he plays F4 and I'm wrong yeah that
might leave The Rook yeah I think I'm
just wrong F4 and wins yeah
[Music]
Bishop G6 oh what
oh
nope he took on G6 I don't know what's
happened there but the evil bar went all
the way down in Black's favorite Rook C1
check
King H2
no it's it just saw a ghost yeah it's
too hard for the engine yeah
I was like what do you miss
okay so and so both players have made 40
or no
no that was move 39 this is the last
move the final move of time Patrol I
think Jeffrey has to be relying on Queen
H6
but then Rook C1 chat wait this looks
bad for white
I would throw on Rook b a check just to
make my last move but
Ben this is not what you wanted if you
were no no
what happens on Queen H6
um
Rook C1 well maybe not Rook C1 maybe
Knight E2 but okay Rook C1 King H2 I
also got 9 F3 check but I don't know
right then I have to play King G3
he played Queen H6 oh this morning I
don't know if he played it I think he
did he did and I think those move order
is even better what if I just take on E5
I was gonna play F4 midnight F3 check
then I play King G3 or I can't in a
queen E1 and wow
yeah your king is not very happy
well if it's going to win then wow both
sides getting checkmated
it looks like vids can take this one
black
so if I play oh look at that fate oh
that is if I play King G4
there's Knight H2 and Rook
C5 I don't know those are 95. I can just
find mate you this way
.
[Music]
King G5
uh I'm good friends with Nigel yeah
wait
oh my gosh if I go you just
yeah me and Nigel were like that yeah
but can I just can I just check you here
and just
I wanted to move my king up
like I wanted King takes G6 and I made
you but obviously every move wins for
black yeah
and if you take here I don't think you
have a Perpetual the king will just run
away
[Music]
probably
presumably now there's no Perpetual here
oh my gosh well this was or is still a
while Dr King H2
uh uh Vida just walked away because I
guess it's bathroom time
it's bathroom time well the players are
gonna take a break we also will do the
same as the players that approach time
control when returned just more action
from the fide World Cup and the feed a
women's world cup these games are really
something we'll be right back everybody
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign
[Music]
Invitational starts October 27th and
will feature 16 Elite American players
under the age of 25. everybody's
favorite commentator streamer player
Grandmaster Daniel nariditski is taking
part the prize you guessed it it is one
Bitcoin so don't miss out on seeing
Donya and others battle it out for the
blitzcoin Invitational sponsored by the
Charlotte chess Center and we do have
games coming to their conclusion near
their conclusion and we have renat Juma
bayev on screen so while Jeffrey Zhang
it looks like he's in a lost situation
you see how jumbabaya is doing over
there against Sam Shanklin and well
looks very good for human bias up a pawn
yeah it's an extra Pawn
[Music]
um
shanklin's blockading the pawn but
you know eventually if white plays
Knight C4 to D6 then I give up
[Laughter]
uh yeah giving up is maybe premature
from a resignation standpoint but it
looks terrible yeah I mean why why it's
close to winning here and uh it's gonna
take some time I guess
I'm trying to think what counter play
Black can possibly drum up here because
you may have a timely for B3 and there's
all these pieces for white are on weird
squares the knights and Bishops next to
each other like this they're having a
conversation they're talking to each
other yeah what are they saying they're
saying yay we have that c Pawn
[Laughter]
I agree that guy looks good very deep
combo and well this was White's 41st
move was Bishop F2 so will gain 30
minutes on the clock and he'll need that
time because right now his position
looks doesn't look good no no it doesn't
and one thing to note though don't play
Knight C4 too quickly let's say yeah
yeah here Knight C4 there's Rook to B3
right winning the bishop yeah you don't
want to blunder that yeah
I have to prepare
this would be a huge win for Juma bayev
who knocked off yeah he's supposed to
beat all the Americans I didn't hear
about that yeah and well if Jeffrey
loses and you know Vernon can win then
there's just no more Americans left in
the field here so that's good
not be ideal for fans of the United
States players but still you Mumbai
playing such excellent chess and
speaking of excellent chess Ben you were
very impressed with Dura Bailey who
defeated Abdul satara with The Blacklist
yeah
yeah he just he after the exchange
sacrifice he he defended really well and
you know when you're down the exchange
when there's very few pieces on the
board then you you know there's nothing
left
yeah so here white doesn't have any
anything else to do
for abusatara if he'll get the black
pieces tomorrow he'll need to win and is
dura Bailey his preparation clearly is
quite good so maybe durability will prep
something in particular to minimize the
risk but I've always thought that vasif
was quite an adventurous player which is
the type of player you want to play in a
must-win scenario mm-hmm yeah he's not
going to play for a draw no he he likes
to he likes to play the way he likes to
play which is that's the right thing to
do is to play your game
so far his game looks good yeah
excellent and he's trying to make his
way to the round of 16.
so let's uh pull up in some of the other
games we have Duda on screen let's just
show his game because you and I were
talking about this during the break Ben
it looks like a position that should
just result in a pretty easy draw for
yeah the engine says white has no
winning chin says obviously I'll take
white I like being a pawn ahead but yeah
I mean the white king doesn't really
have anywhere to hide and Black's King
is pretty good
so
yeah it's it's just a draw yeah and
they've been actually sort of
doing yeah just checking them and yeah
nowhere to hide
yeah and if you go up the board then
rookie five would just scoop up before
and now white has to make the draw yeah
now Black's better right yeah still a
draw but you'd rather have black
so this game is about to conclude and
yeah Jeffrey Jeffrey's gonna lose yes
I mean he's going to that that line we
were looking at that's that Line's
winning for blood yeah finally Vida came
back probably from the bathroom play
Queen takes E5 track and now he's
very happy
um
I don't think he's played F oh he did
play F4 right and I think Knight F3
check as you pointed out just wins only
move I think because there's all these
checkmates right I mean otherwise you
can get checkmated yourself yeah
so yeah he's forced to win he has to
play Knight F3 instead of uh lose so
Knight F3 if you take Queen to E2 King
G3 Rook G1 King is four and that's just
mate so you're running out of options
for Jeffers and Knight F3 I like your
line that you were coming up with here
so King Chief yeah this is this is
actually the engine variation
and then 95 as you pointed out
tonight shoot does that also work are
I don't know
I have one legal move so I'll play it
yeah
well Queen G3 might get you in trouble
because King F6 and
if Queen C3 checks King G5 back I think
it's
or I guess I could
it's a very confusing position
so Rook C5 check is also possible to
bring the brook in
who's better
feels like it's uh leading towards a
mate but I can't quite if I play King F6
and you play Rook F5 and I take on oh if
I take on G6 you have you you have Queen
G3 oh
but it says that white is just winning
and I guess is King E7 winning yeah I
think he's seven wins yeah there's no
Queen before and if Rook F7 check King
touched his down yeah the Knight on H2
isn't very helpful there Robert
oh my gosh this is just so funny with
the kids I mean black blackhead messed
this up but he probably won't no but it
is a great calculator and
Knight F3
check King g495 he came here
well you have to be certain that after
Knight F7 Rook takes F7 that you're
winning yeah
because
like this could seem like the king is in
some pretty big I mean if black does
this he's either going to win or Draw
he's probably going to win so it's not
there's no risk right so
I I think a funny draw
um which makes no sense is if black
plays Rick H1 check in the original
position and then Queen E1 check Knight
F3 check
I just said and then Queen F2 Queen F1
yeah yep that's a draw
yeah it's ridiculous because Black's
winning but still
I mean you know if it doesn't see that
he's winning it looks like Duda and
idani uh shook hands getting it on the
board made a draw and yeah video will
just calculate this the rest of the way
he is 18 minutes so he has time let us
where else can we go it looks like
Martin rosian against burkish he didn't
play Knight B5 but he did play the move
Rook A7 which which was awesome yeah
just winning for him anyway because he's
starting to oh yeah rookie check and B7
that's annoying
we checked the king up the board played
Bishop C8 and B7
white is now up a piece for a pawn yeah
this is just easy because the black king
is so bad the NS Pawn E3 survives
because Rook G2 uh Rook F7 Rook G3 is
getting pretty close to taking all of
White's pawns but after Knight takes not
close enough
you're not even getting this Pawn here
foreign
we might get all this in fact so it
looks like
for hike marketing is going to win yeah
yeah he's just been awesome this
tournament for berkich well his winning
ways have been halted at least for now
and what about
Harry Christians game we mentioned him
as someone who is yeah I was looking bad
for him and it's still looking bad
oh
yeah it is looking very bad so Knight E1
Knight C6 check is probably the idea
and take with a night here I would
assume that's winning or is he gonna put
h4h5 and just get away with it I assume
that's winning
I mean if I take the pawn on E5 and just
ignore the H Pawn just clean my F Pawn
keep pushing my F Pawn every move yeah
that's pretty good I don't I don't like
that for for black yeah
this has to be winning yeah it must be
it must be winning
so what happened in this game because
earlier on we thought that Hare Krishna
was a couple moves away from stabilizing
yeah yeah
we were we left it a long while ago
we're on these
Queen B8 was Harvard University's choice
he lost this position
yeah the engine just thinks it's equal
and I agree he just got outplayed the
end game wow
doesn't sound like Hari Krishna
I mean this is just
I wonder if he relaxed like he thought
it was too easy to draw I don't know I
mean White's better but it should just
be a draw
yeah I'm just surprised the player I
mean he lost a queen Side Pawn it's one
to zero so I'm
okay well this is now starting to get a
bit scary so yeah now he's yeah
probably taking on C5 was wrong
why are you letting that Knight get to
B4 not ideal oh and then he here comes
C6 and just Knight takes E5
that's probably what he missed because
if Knight takes A6 Knight D6 I'm
threatening the fork yeah Knight D7 yeah
right yeah he did the ce5 yeah E5 so
nice definitely didn't see E5 yeah
beautiful move taking away the square
and if you play Knight A3 then it's King
D14 right yep yeah he didn't see E5
beautiful move
and then
in came White's King upon and
so looks like it should be easily
winning but I guess yeah
so
now we're around here no I think it is
easily winning yeah he didn't see E5
but he was still you know he was still
on the worst side of the draw there much
worse so he was getting close to losing
anyway
what E5 is just one of those beautiful
moves to flick in and
for tablet to buy you he's having a
great event I think oh yeah on under the
radar because he's not right
2700 plus caliber but he's having a
really fantastic event where he's
knocked out some great players
trying to continue his tournament he's
not ready to go home he beat Yu Yang Yi
he beat the Hungarian Grandmaster
berkish and
it's kind of crazy because in the
opening round I remember Dubai lost a
game against uh with white pieces
against the Im so he went from that
start to this point here
really
showing his might
yeah if it had played Knight F3 and
queen E1 check and Jeffrey played King
G4 as we expected
this is this is what's happening oh
that's not what happened
I could see on the live Ward and after
after King G4 uh vivid's thinking again
I think I play 95 check
um
is that the only move that wins
Knight H2 might not win yes it's just an
awkward move because if you realize the
Knight can't be captured on E5 it just
seems to make
a ton of sense
but he'll continue thinking
this position is a lot easier to play
when you have engines helping you
yeah it is when you're playing in the
World Cup and you got to figure it out
and there's no bar telling you anything
you know you hope your calculation's
super accurate
that's right and you know look at the
Players composure here yeah but it's
you know he knows he's better obviously
this is much more exciting if you don't
have an engine if you're just watching
at home and you're like oh my God what's
happening I agreed and I tend to watch
my chest without engines and I'm just
like oh I would take white chances here
the King on Jay looks made and then the
engine laughs at me and says nope it's
actually just minus a million right yeah
I would look at the video though he does
look a little nervous
I'd be nervous too because if I don't
win I might lose that's true I mean if
you don't play the winning line and you
don't have a check you got You're Gonna
Lose White's checkmating black also yeah
he's been taking some glances at the
club the people who have the engines who
are watching us they're just like what's
the problem the problem is they don't
have engines so they don't know that
it's winning and they might think
they're losing you got to calculate
everything accurately
and he thought this was winning because
he obviously saw Rook H1 was a draw so
he thought this was winning
right he would have played Rick H1 and
Drew
and
he was looking for the people at home if
he if he played King takes tonight he
gets made it immediately Rick to uh C3
and then Queen G3 May
yeah so he couldn't take the Knight so
he had to play King G4
and Nigel is watching with baited breath
will that king walk up the board and he
can't have beta breath he's commentating
that's right
and oh did it here comes here comes
Knight E5 it looks like he's in that
that pose where you're dragging the
Knight back
he hasn't made his decision yet
he's really concentrated
it's a huge moment for him
so vidit still thinking and he's got a
triple check there it is a check
King G5 yep
the king went up to G5 and
let's see how it continues here even
though we know black is winning it's
still exciting
well one of the questions I have because
we only have the number we don't have
the moves right is Knight F7 check the
only move here oh he's crap it's like
he's playing it
oh
okay 907
nope
Rook takes
and the fact that he's thinking here Ben
he might have an in-between move that's
not King yeah you could play Rook C5
track or
Queen G3 Chuck looks weird that doesn't
make any sense
yeah he's just gonna take
all right
yeah he must have calculated saying
there's no uh I can't believe those are
Perpetual I don't believe it nah
the chain can just run via E8 and start
running to the clean side
yeah found the right way to play and
he's going to win
huge huge game and for video actually
something of note for him is that he's
actually lost some rating points in this
tournament just because he drew his
first match against Alexander fear the
very strong British grandma oh excuse me
Brazilian Master not British and then he
tied 1-1 With His companion Audi Bond
but audubon's lower rated so he's been
losing some rating points here right and
and Jeffrey's gonna have to when he
loses this game has to get some advice
from adibon about how to win on Demand
with black yeah
how to channel the Beast how did you win
with black on demand I need to know
it's just one of these moments Ben where
you know it's more than just determined
for vidit who has been around 27 20 27
25 for a couple years now like if he can
first regain the points he's lost and
then win the second game with the white
pieces against somebody who's playing
you know I have to win chess which is
yeah not always objective he can just
launch himself into an even higher
rating and that could be Monumental for
his career
even more monumentals if he wins the
World Cup
yeah that would be something for sure
and I'm actually going to look at the
tournament tree to see where he is and
you don't want to look ahead to the next
matchup but you got to play the match
you're playing but we can look ahead
yeah we are looking I'm looking ahead
video yeah right yeah we're definitely
the winner of this match plays the
winner of dura Bailey against abusotaro
so you know it's chances that it could
win that match too yeah he would be the
favorite against I think either one of
these guys is the favorite yes so yeah
wow nothing the favorites ever win but
you know no there's a reason Magnus has
never won this event and you know
Fabiano was bounced early and
Geary and on the jar of man the truth
hurts yeah test is tough
it certainly is so we'll uh go away from
this team let's go to the Women's World
Cup games because we haven't checked in
on them for a while uh fewer left looks
like Maria muzichuk with the black
pieces here against Alexander castenia
the former well both of them are former
women's world champions of fun so blacks
up a pawn but everything's on the same
side what is this Rook on age for well
the truth hurts yeah sometimes your Rook
is on H4 yeah
not something you see now whose turn is
it here it's White's turn it's White's
turn
yeah White's fighting for a draw
can she can she achieve it
what move do you even have for what your
pieces
yeah the engine doesn't have the bar all
the way down so there's some way for
you know white to not just lose right
away
if you're a rook H5 which actually just
gets you pinned some more is one of your
black F5
probably not like F5 if you take on
Busan obviously your Rook is no your
Rook saying yeah you can't do that
if that's cool move
but that's Rook H5 is an impossibly said
yeah I don't want to have white here
because I don't know what to do
yeah and you can't even pass I don't
think
can I um let's see
I wanted to do something like check and
then take on H6 and take on G7 but I
don't know
yeah Bishop to take on G7 yeah
very suspicious yeah
King is that Queen F5 check probably
wins too
yeah okay that's I'm trying no but this
you know this definitely would give yeah
why some chances to hold this position
right yeah but
I'm trying to get a position where I'm
not you know so unhappy but I think I
can't have one
I think I'm just gonna be unhappy I'm
sorry that you're in happy Ben yeah and
I mean if I'm white I'm not white so I'm
not that unhappy now okay just but yeah
this looks this just looks terrible for
white
it does
and
King H7 can you just
play Queen back to G4 and try to claim
you can't make progress
uh so if you take on G5 you're gonna
lose your e-pawn nice that'll be a draw
yeah probably oh although probably maybe
not no there might be Rook H5 here wow
wait a minute how do these things work
wow
like pin there and this if you trade
Queens you're also trading Brooks you
probably lose the king pawning game yeah
well I mean why why can uh move the
queen I guess
and try to draw this ending but yeah
that's
yeah it's not fun I don't know where but
yeah
yeah maybe they're actually a good
chance to hold that yeah there's chances
to draw here yeah
just yeah Ridiculousness but yeah I mean
this is uh no fun for white
white has to play Super precisely and
then she has a tough time drawing after
that
she did just she did exactly what you
said she brought the queen back to G4
and
the good news is these end games are
broken three against rook and two will
be a theoretical draw so certain trades
will favor kristenyak's strong chances
most trades actually
so let's uh
by the way gravity hasn't lost yet what
I've never been so mad
uh but she's completely losing
yeah it looks like she lost yeah we're
just still playing
yeah this is no fun
yeah a zillion threats yeah the game
just ended I think the Arbiters there
yeah
and the tricky thing about this Ben is
in the Women's World Cup three Candice
spots three women's Candace spots are on
the line koryachina is already qualified
for the women's candidates because she
lost the world championship match
against June June so what all the
players who won't play her potentially
until the semi-final one is for gray
ashtron just beat everybody because then
if you make the final four you've
already qualified for the women's
Candles now here's my question
if if Magnus let's say makes it to the
final I don't even care if he wins or
loses then the person who plays Magnus
gets in
I mean typically the other two wouldn't
even play anymore but I guess they have
to
to see who gets to the to the candidates
right
he right they have to play because the
prize money is different but
oh third and fourth is different yes
oh so they're playing anyway
yes
oh okay that that makes it easy if
they're all yeah okay yeah not exactly
you know the biggest incentive sometimes
for these people though but now there's
an incentive yeah right
and wait I have a different
position here
I think then
the game Rooks
C5 takes
check can be three check and whites have
a piece but isn't it that's what I was
thinking yeah
being up a piece is good
I can concur with that yeah
that's a minor upset oh I guess when
you're white it's not really enough
Paulina she's 20 years old she also did
really well in the Russian higher League
whereas gray action went six and a half
and a nine and right for a third
um I think got six out of nine her
rating has crossed 2500 feet a uh she's
really been playing excellent chess as
of late and with the white pieces a 2500
player no Underdog yeah
um there's no underdogs anywhere who are
these players
and I've been wearing masks it's is that
dubov and yes Panka I think
what those two
that Steve bought me asapanko is it okay
yeah yeah I guess you're right I just
with their with their hands like this
and the side view I'm like who are these
guys usually with the mess I don't know
but
but yeah you're right
two Russian stars and well we they both
look unhappy that's how you know they're
good chess players oh yeah they look
unhappy we're gonna leave them in
because
we're gonna take another quick break
it's about move 48 in this game and
other games also at a similar point in
time the players have enough time so
we're gonna take a break and win return
we'll be here for the end of the round
it would seems so stay tuned everybody
we'll be right back for more coverage of
the feed a World Cup and the fide
Women's World Cup
foreign
[Music]
and just another reminder that coming
your way this November the 2021 World
Chess Championship between John the palm
tree Magnus Carlson chess.com is your
exclusive twitch home for the video
feeds for this year's World Championship
you will not want to miss that action
though with great commentary and
exciting play for the world title
exclusive coverage with camera feeds can
be found on this channel right here but
for now we are very much excited for
this game here it's about to conclude
video's rothi taking down American
Superstar Jeffrey Zhang and well Ben
this is uh maybe the end of Jeffrey's
tournament I want to count them out
early he's an amazing player but losing
with the white pieces did it with white
in game two I know adibon did it but
something
doesn't seem like Lightning's gonna
strike twice yeah he just resigned yep
um
yeah I mean obviously that it is a huge
huge favorite to win the match
yeah
you gotta gotta feel free very very nice
uh
um
you know it of all the players in the
tournament I think um the the best loser
is is Jeffrey Jean when he loses he's
not um doesn't he seem to seem angry
yeah he's a really nice person he's just
like yeah that's what happened yeah I've
known him and his father for a while
just yeah loves chess plays really hard
yeah you know is someone who is striving
to reach even higher Heights but 2700
plus player he's great but unfortunate
for him Vita Gujarati just had the
complications I better handle them in
the time trouble he did better yeah
and there's a the fan favorite video
Gujarati any yeah fans and not just
people from India but all around the
world are big supporters of his and
they're gonna be thrilled and he's yeah
they're not going to be happy with Hari
krishna's results today but they're
going to be happy with that
well let's go over to the hard Krishna
games to see if that one's near its
conclusion it's going to end soon yeah
progdananda Drew against mvl so that's
good result
yeah
this game here
is black have any chance to survive this
probably not much
no two two pawns there's two pawns and
the white king is better than the black
king
yeah I was gonna start like King D4 but
I understand you want to play King of
six or something it's up by King E3 I
was just gonna play Knight G4 so your
king can't come in
oh you're that kind of guy but you have
that H4 check yeah I missed that yeah
all right so you're right when you're
right you're right
for making a I don't know Kings King of
five looks pretty good too you just kind
of push the pawn and
yeah this is winning for sure maybe you
can throw a check King goes over Knight
has to go back you cannot afford to get
in the pawn ending so here now your
knight G4 moving now Knight G4 I finally
you know stopped lighting before you did
although 91 still a little bit tricky
if F4 thank you for this I guess this
isn't
win the pawn the Knight protects it
yeah
the king comes here some chances yeah
right it's not it's not easy easy yeah
but it should be winning yeah
so just something looks like he's
winning the end game yeah and uh tabat
survey looks like he's winning
yeah the the engine just says whites I
mean you just have to pass d-pawn
um I assume Rick F5 check I didn't think
I need the engines look at duboff's face
yeah yeah he looks very unhappy yeah
wow man I I saw Essa panko like a long
time ago and and each people get older
yeah
I mean a lot of people that I knew three
four five years ago and I haven't seen
them because the pandemic or whatnot I'm
like who are these people it's the same
person but
you know when teenagers get older then
you're just don't look the same
yeah I mean yes panko the game seems
much taller every time yeah that's yeah
I was thinking that and much stronger as
a player Crossing 2700 being a
magnificent like and say and here
looking like he's taking down dubov in
the first game of their match
so probably Rook at five check is
you mentioned
yeah and by the way on the break it
looked like Sam shanklin's position was
improving because he was probably losing
um to jumabaya but maybe maybe he can
hold now he's got chances anyway so
let's go over I don't think um
shanklin's lost any slow games yet
he has not but he just played the move
Bishop C6
um
and and yeah that's a I mean this isn't
I mean he's got a really good blockade
on that pawn as Rick is active so it's
not easy to win for white
yeah the pawn can't push to C6 it's the
one thing it wants to do here
what can you even do as white so yeah
Sam has Sam has chances
and if the times are accurate he could
even seem to have win this game because
jimabaya really doesn't have that much
time but with the position being the way
it is I think that of course white is to
be referred especially if you take on e4
and this Knight comes into F6 did she
foreign
well yeah
yeah White's doing really well but uh
probably not as well as he was about
five moves ago
it seems like uh the Shanklin got his
pieces to good squares but what do you
think
the players are thinking about in this
position because yes shingles pieces are
in better squares he's blocking the C
Pawn Maybe by trading some minor pieces
there's some loose squares some holes in
the position that black can jump into
but it's so complicated so many pieces
remain that do you think Sam is
confident he's fully equalized here or
what would you say the mindset of these
poses I never know what Sam's thinking
but I don't I think Sam is probably
happier than he was a few moves ago yeah
and uh
I think I think white is still pleased
that he's he's the one pressing
so I think I think both players are are
pretty happy now compared to you know
especially Sam from a position that
didn't look very good now it looks like
as you said he's you know he even could
win because of the time situation if if
white goes crazy
um
but yeah I I thought white was going to
win this game a few moves ago and I
think the most likely result is a draw
yeah that's uh
probably the result we will see although
Anything Can Happen time scrambles and
positions of this nature where Black's
King at first glance looks a bit safer
than White's team even though Blackstone
pieces attacking just yet there's some
potential there although the neck came
to C3
very likely to replace the Knight on the
bishop on e4 rather and jukebox looks so
sad
I want to give him a hug except I can't
because of you know covered stuff but uh
that's the only reason yeah yeah he
looks that's the only reason he looks so
sad yeah
and well he's like I'm barely in the top
10 in Russia come on
I just I just did the whole flying from
the US to Sochi thing not that easy
did not miss travel how long have you
been back in New York
uh let's see a day and a half uh-huh
yeah my back I can't believe you're
you're awake because you know the time
change is crazy
it's true but
how many flights from Sochi to New York
just two just two Sochi to Moscow Moscow
New York
yeah Moscow New York is not a short
flight no actually I have no idea how
far the flight is from Sochi to Moscow
it could be long too I don't know it was
like two and a half hours okay that's
not too bad yeah and well we just saw
trades on B5 the queen jumps out here
puts more pressure on the C5 Pawn yep
and how to continue this
turn for white to win when the bishop on
F2 just has no
you know it's nothing just sitting there
The Bishop's not doing anything to help
white win and Black's pieces are all
great the bishop on f8 puts pressure
Bishops I mean all blacks pieces are
like on good squares it's very hard for
white to go forward and
if white goes too far forward his King
on G1 could get exposed because he
pushed all the Pawns in front of it so
you gotta be a little bit careful and
you you obviously don't want to
acquiesce to a draw because your
position is so good but you can't think
two three minutes a move to improve your
position so it's it's not easy to
improve even when you are winning in
these positions when you just don't have
time to do it
and there's some issues in White's
position a timely H4 could make the F4
Pawn right a Target and the light
squares as you were pointing out seem to
be very weak and I think that this
position is becoming increasingly easy
for black to play and difficult for
white to do so no I agree Black's pieces
are all just great I mean they're just
on the right squares and White's pieces
are basically just defending C5 The Rook
C1 the queen D4 the bishop on F2
and um you know white
White's just not as active as black so
that's why I think the game is going to
be a draw because I don't think white
can get through there
right
having twice as much time is also good
for black there's no extra time to move
60. you can't go get an orange juice
terrible
no extra time you're in the final time
Patrol and you have to that's why Magnus
sends his games quickly
doesn't want to make the orange juice
blunder no he does not Bishop takes C6
okay I would take with a knight I think
who hit this queen
and I guess Queen C4 is possible
definitely do not want to trade on C4 if
you're black you would like to avoid
that
but
that's Queen B7 just always Retreat
right yeah that's a nice diagonal
so the bishop out of two is just
terrible
yeah it is really bad it's really really
bad I want I want active pieces what's
Black's plan though I don't know what
White's plan is I'm just trying to
figure out let's say you've got 57
what's you know black gonna do here
well what if I play Rook B5 the next
move because I'm a I just want to take
on C5 no I'll have to move where's that
going
I haven't figured it out yet
somewhere bad
probably Queen B7 just played by the way
yeah yeah after Rook B5 if it's black
smoke I don't I I don't know what white
does
moves the Knight somewhere terrible
where does my knight need to go it's
like maybe C2 so I can go to uh I don't
know can I go Knight F1 or do H4 I'm
worried about H4 yeah yeah
starting to get scary for white
H4 is a very legitimate threat and if
you play H4 for white I mean then you've
kind of locked up this position which is
make the bishop worse yeah yeah the show
is worse and then oh my gosh we have
Rook B4 Knight D4 and yikes uh oh
right that's why we think you know if
white if white goes too far you can lose
we shouldn't lose but you know sometimes
you go too far
so maybe Queen E4 just to
stop his Knight D4 threads very
reasonable because Knight C4 to D6 looks
okay yeah I wouldn't complain my night
we're able to get there we got a cheat
to do it but we'll do it
you know when if you can lose if you
must but always cheat yeah you know good
well if I play Rook B5 now that stops
Knight C4 I guess
right I think it does
so 96 I guess you just take an F2 yeah
check and all that stuff yeah because
Queen B6 check or Rook B2 check yeah
so Queen E4 plane
yeah if I'm dreaming about it I'd
probably just let the game
Peter out to a draw if I
can force it it doesn't sound like what
he does no
you can see Queen B5 Queen C4 and if
Rook B5
oh
maybe Night Moves somewhere Knight F1 or
1991 something
should not be a problem for black
all right well
he's trying to figure this out Shanklin
confidently holding should we head on
back to dubov and Jessica some moves
have been played here he went Rook E6
check rather than Rook F5 yeah he wants
the knights to go to E5 he wants Knight
true yeah the truth hurts yeah
so maybe it was King F7 a wrong move
well I'm thinking
he wants to play Knight C3 and Knight
takes D5 so The Rook is attacked ah
okay so yeah and then what happens on
Knight takes
each oh we just no no we just attacked
the Knight rookie five or Rook D6
I don't think there's anything
particularly wrong with this one either
yeah that's also yeah your moves better
yeah you're right yeah I forgot the Rook
was trap this is totally yeah this is
completely lost yeah okay so he took on
he took on H3
um after King F2 you think
uh I'm just looking at the live board
but now 95 and DC yeah he wanted to play
95 yeah
boy
so what black really needs to do is
trade off this H pump for this G4 Pawn I
have a question
no my move doesn't win
wait he played my move I thought he
couldn't do that oh no he didn't okay
good I I thought King G2 but then Knight
D5 is fine
yeah
so in 85
yeah this is uh not fun for black
not even a little bit yeah
can he can he try to sack his Knight for
the pawn and try to get H5 in I was like
King G I don't know where seven yeah D6
Chevy two oh man that makes it hard to
sack my knight for the yeah and The Rook
is hanging darn
yeah I guess that's why the things going
all the way up
the Deep Pawn's too good
can I throw in like a check here
yeah but when I play D7 I have rookie
eight check and queen yeah
I mean even even Kings even just King G1
right and then Rook D2 D7
looks pretty good
am I pretty I mean everything looks good
yeah yeah
yeah dubov looks like he he's resigned
to his fate
he went to G7 just so there's no rookie
check and clean but D6 looks
yeah now he he looks really unhappy yeah
he knows the end is near
although dubov is such a creative player
that if anybody can win a game On Demand
with white he's high amount yeah this
match is not over yeah not at all no and
we're getting word that Casper piorun
against cindarov that piorron is taking
control of this game
yeah that went from White having a big
advantage to White being slightly better
to equal and now Black's better
Queen E4 so he gave him the H3 Pawn
after King G2 oh he missed Rook H4
he just
oh yeah I I can see missing Rook H4 and
then some
man would I miss that move oh gosh yeah
I wouldn't see Rook H4 either
he just threw away the game yeah no I
understand missing that but that's cute
that the knights pinned and but but then
let's look at this position right okay
blocks up a pawn in the driver's seat
and let's go back to this position Ryan
yeah you know where I'm going right
things turned around I mean white had
the dreamiest yeah I mean black can't do
anything yeah nothing I couldn't move so
yeah white was doing great then equal
then then losing Maybe
I think C4 is one of those moves you
just regret immensely after the game
because it made the position very sharp
rather than just a solid Edge and now
we're in a spot where that didn't cause
him to lose the game of course but now
he's in big trouble mm-hmm
then D6 was played by estepenko
okay I can uh switch back over
to that one Jessica panko pushes the
pawn up wow Rook H4
to control
D6 then I came to check the king scooted
over
into Rook H4
no oh in the other game Sorry I was
looking at this
dubov position and Rook H4 yeah
you can't stop Rook H2 check is what he
played
with the Knight on C3
uh
or wait a minute what's going on no no
go go back yeah I don't think you played
Knight E4 check did he and I'm looking
at the live board
yeah I think you played Rook H2 check
here got it mm-hmm
that makes more sense 94 Kings you choos
just resigns yes
Rook H2 check
yeah I was saying King G1 but that was
with the King on f8 so I could get that
rookie check in all right but can't you
and you were so they maybe King E3 is
better I don't know
okay here looks
this isn't this would give black some
chances but yeah
overall doesn't seem like black should
get any chances
so Rook H I think he I think he played I
can't really see the board as well as I
thought so
no no move yet as far as go back to the
other game because all heck broke loose
in the cinder game yes okay okay let me
go
that's funny what happened we left and
it just got crazy yeah whereas the
Peoria you can do it what
on 95. oh man yeah go back and show how
that happened
okay so we saw Rook H fly wow yeah he
played Rook C6 Rook G4 King F3 and then
Queen takes for Wow
Wow and that's a way to win the game
yeah because if rookie for Rook G6 King
G6 otherwise g7's hanging you get right
this position
where why is some chances because this B
Pawn is the decoy and yeah trying to
secure yeah after Queen say C6 he does
not yeah
Queen takes c66 forces resignation huh
yeah wow
that's a nice finishing move man
well he is the puzzle solving world
champion for a reason I don't know if
he's the current champion but he has one
yeah Queen C6 is really nice
damn
ouch
yeah if Queen C6 95 check the King has
to move away from The Ruck that's funny
unless you have white then it's not
funny
amazing nights can be such great Pieces
Just defending the hanging Rook check
and hitting the queen all at once
beautiful stuff so I win for piorun who
I mean he's speaking of people going
under the radar this guy I don't even
know he's talked about in the entire
event and here he is just powering
through the competition
let me see who
that was a really nice finish and esta
panko played King F3
after Rook H2 check
okay
by the way Ben I just looked at piorun's
history in this tournament he won his
first match one half he then beat Marcus
ragger the Austrian nearly 2700 one out
of that he beats Jordan van Forrest one
and a half and now he's up one nothing
on cindero so he's winning all his
matches he has no tie breaks wow none
wow
he's just that is flying under the radar
because you know
nobody's picking him to go far but he's
going far he really is and when there
are three polish players remaining and
two of them are Duda and voitacek you
don't really think that maybe one of the
other players will go further but piora
he's in the lead and he can keep winning
yeah both Drew
so what township is up here
mildly tough opponent he has a tough
opponent yeah
so let's see King F3 Rook D2
D7
how do you not win this position for
what
that is a funny question yeah
all right so remove the answer to it
Rook D2 D7 oh this is almost completely
lame well the engine doesn't like Rigby
too but I mean that's I mean what
what else do you want to do how many
likes anything just lost yeah I mean
it's just winning a very simple plan
what games just ended there
uh did we already see the end of that I
can't tell which game that is let's say
Knights and pawn so it's probably that's
the that's the Hari Krishna game yeah I
mean time to buy wins with the white
pieces over pental Hari Krishna yeah
and
um
Hari Krishna lost and did it won is that
the three Indian players who are left or
am I missing somebody those are the
three yep
and Zhang lost and uh shankland is
fighting back
you know quickly pull up the Shanklin
game and
oh the Knight went back to F1 and the
eval is slipping in Black's favor
so it's H4 the move
it's tempting to me
the engine actually prefers to have
black here yes maybe yeah maybe yeah
maybe
wow that's crazy oh but Shanklin just
like rooked B2
so he didn't go H4 which
difficult to meet Ben because white has
three minutes and right I was gonna say
yeah maybe shanklin's waiting for even a
bigger type advantage of them play
something crazy
I I think if I'm human body I'm just
trying to play Queen C4 I need to change
I did it already
yeah he played Queen C4 as you said it
he heard you I hope not you know the
famous story
kaspara was playing a non at the World
Trade Center their world championship
match
I guess it was 95 and
they were in like an enclosed glass that
technically was sound proof
and Yasser was doing commentary with
somebody nearby
and when the game ended Kasparov said
davichi Yasser suggested this
the players could hear the com
ments that's not a good thing although
thankfully back in that day there were
no engines that could really outclass
the players so Yasser was just you know
doing his own thinking of course the
Oscar is amazing player and yeah had
beaten Gary um so yeah that's
impossibility you buy 86 yeah it's a lot
different when you compensate nowadays
like well the engine says that and then
you put it out here yeah
that's funny yeah Sam looks pretty happy
and probably Sam's not even thinking of
winning he's just like yeah I didn't
lose that position right so he might it
might be hard to change gears and try to
win with his opponent's time trouble
it's one of the most difficult things to
do right yeah he's just on the other
hand maybe white still wants to win
because he's a pawn up
so he's still there I'm not sure who
wants to win more if they're going to
repeat or one of them wants to win think
of Rook C2 I kind of he did Play Rick C2
yeah I saw his hand move but I didn't
see it yeah yeah he did yeah
like what if black was before and pawn
H4 mm-hmm
the one really bad thing about black
doing that is you give up like the G4
Square for that white knight to jump
into and then F6 and things like that
but yeah I don't know Rook B4 and H4
seems very tempting
I don't know when you have a time
Advantage like that and things are
turning around it might be time to try
to put your foot on the throat instead
of just draw
I'm sure if he asked him 10 moves ago
he'd be like yeah I drew but maybe now
he's like well I'm not losing and I have
a big time advantage
so I don't know
you don't get any more time either so
that if you get 30 seconds but there's
no extra time in any move nope
I was just looking in the corner of my
eye looks like Paulina shuvalova in the
Women's World Cup she is completely
winning in her game with the white
pieces so a great start for her in her
match against very strong Georgian
Grandmaster
foreign no it was a much needed rest day
yesterday so the players can rejuvenate
and play some good chess if we make him
play five hours a day without a rest
they're gonna then we might see some 30
move draws yes but yeah we did see some
of those today but that's just because
the players are pretty evenly matched
and yeah positions were level but look
at Juma Vibe here
he's calculating the position
it's not his turn oh
look like Rook before playing hey maybe
H4 is gonna happen
he moved with some oomph right with yeah
yeah he it was like I'm the man before
he had that Hans demon energy yeah
so Rook before played and where did the
queen even go because H4 is my pre-move
for black put it in H
h
Queenie too I mean I know it gives up
the G4 square but I still like H4 I
really like H4 yeah
and like H4 the engine says White's
winning what a blunder
you see Shanklin here the cameras are
all on him
and
Sam trying to calculate through you can
see is the eyes starting from side to
side here
and Ben you played Sam a bunch of times
right I have he he looks at you he's the
type player who like will stand a lot of
guys do that of course of course but
he's definitely has like a memorable
like glance at you yeah how you're
feeling that's right yeah
yeah for reasons that don't make any
sense I have a good score against sand I
think it's because I played him before
you with Sam
you know I played him when he was like
an I am yeah but I played him in the U.S
Championship
twice and I won once and Drew once then
there was this big tournament in
Michigan with like eight nine GMS and I
drew him there too
and I that might be it
and then he beat me in like the U.S
chess League or something but yeah as
long as we don't count that everything's
fine
I won't count it if you don't but you
know H4 has been played so Sam Shanklin
he's been playing for the win yeah just
a good move you're undermining the
defense of the F4 Pawn if F4 collapses
so does E5 yeah and Sam just ran away
right I mean see I mean but now his
opponent's like man the guy's trying to
beat me the guy's not moving back and
forth he's actually trying to do
something
and June 5 is an exceptional speed chess
player but I wouldn't want to be down
six plus minutes and be facing an attack
in the near future and also just the
trajectory of the game June bye was
confident he was playing really well he
had a bind at the start where Shanklin
couldn't really do anything and now all
of a sudden he's looking at his Pawn
structure falling apart where did he
just go this is like reversed roles too
I would expect Shanklin outplays Juma
bayev and then jubab gets some tricky
attack but it's the other way around
and Queen by Queen F3 okay Queen F3 yeah
and he just ran away that seems
reasonable
well
so Sam is still well Sam Sam definitely
had to go to the bathroom the way he got
up
he wasn't getting up he wasn't getting
up to take a stroll
yeah he got up with purpose
so what's he gonna do here though
because Black's position maybe according
to the eval bar black is actually
seizing the initiative and has an edge
here but you have to be precise because
just H6 G3 oh you hurt White's pawn shop
then the Knight takes on G3 and then I
guess the E4 and well White's very happy
to
stick a knight on FR D6
so Sam all three results are possible
still
just three just three yeah
there's a fourth result we probably
shouldn't talk about it
the Arbiter says I'm sorry we have to
stop the game and you go
um well on that note I'm gonna stop
talking we're gonna take a last short
break when in return we'll come back
with the conclusion of this game it will
be an exciting finish between Shanklin
and jumboven there are some other games
going on so our last Quick break we will
be back shortly
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and we are back with this coverage of
the fide World Cup it looks like Sam
Shanklin and Vernon General have traded
queens in a tactical fashion after the
moves Bishop H6 Bishop E3 was played and
then finally the Palm was chopped and
Knight takes E5 a nice shot by Shanklin
exposing the Queens to one another and
after the swap of Queens you can't
really take on E5 because your Bishop on
E3 is hanging with check so Ben at this
point in time Juma bayev using his
remaining minute series a minute and a
half left on the clock you thought that
this was turning in Sam's favor do you
still think that he's in charge here or
should jumabaya be able to hold
probably white can hold past pawn and
even material but
I think I'd rather have black here
because of the three isolated pawns I'm
not thinking that c Pawn is going to
Queen and obviously white has a Time
disadvantage as well
so
yeah I'm not I'm not happy with what's
happened for white the last you know 10
15 moves but I don't think he's losing
but uh I don't think he's pressing
either it's just not very appealing to
play this position as white in the Blitz
game as you just point out the healthy
Pawn structure for black and the Knight
just Blockhead the pawn C6 and these
pawns are terrible for white all over
the place
it's hard to dislodge the Knight on C6
and defend the seed pawn and defend the
F Pawn
um so yeah I mean the engine might say
equal but I think uh we're gonna take
black here rather have black
and it looked like June bye you're a
knight E2 or something you kind of
he did play 92 mm-hmm
yeah he's trying to get rid of that
Knight on C6 right next to D4
pretty good strong although yeah I guess
Knight Knight T4 is upon sacrifice so
yeah not an easy move to play then yeah
and Shanklin is so we got like six and a
half minutes for Shanklin and one and a
half minutes for joomobayev that's right
and I'm again all three results are
possible but it's looking like it's you
know shanklin's out of trouble
oh well speaking of results oh my
goodness I just called the corner look
at the dubov game with yessa panko
because we thought that that was just
going to be an easy win for yessa panko
but not so fast uh refresh to get to the
current position
uh what's going on I gotta really
refresh because
doesn't want to go to the live boards
doesn't like the live position this is
the live position where this is the best
that black could possibly hope for
that let's see D7
took H6 checked an H7 he got the Knight
on E5
um
so
you get a queen because you
probably have to and how easy is this or
is it even winning for white this would
be in the table base
it's funny because I would think this is
an easy win but that's what I think
I would think that he checked first that
way you can't play Knight D4 check or
Knight D6
we checked on E at first so now he has
to get there yeah that was annoyed I I
mean this should just be a win
which is that simple I think so I think
it's simple
and then if the game is a draw that
shows you how wrong I am
[Laughter]
so we trade here
yeah you're probably right I don't see
how black can hold this yeah it's great
yeah this is not going to do it
the king and
so I was gonna be checking the sixth
rank the king will be forced back
you're right no I like the rookie age
check that was nice
yeah making sure the Knight can't go to
D6 or D4
so what do you play King E5 now
so I can bring my knight to those yeah I
wanted to play Rook f8 to F5 but all
your night moves stopped me
yeah it's not nice
never claimed to be a nice guy I guess
I'd play King E3 and then if your knight
comes in I'll play Rick GA and then my
King's gonna walk in
you know then Rook uh G8 yeah
yeah I guess your king gets to King D4
Maybe
yeah
yeah not yet but not Knight H6 is a
threat
you're so mean
uh but even this rookie eight Knight age
six rookie four or this
if you can hold this as black just yeah
it just seems like you should eventually
lose
King is walking in
but yeah it might go for a while
yeah it seemed like it was really over
and now it just seems like oh White's
probably winning right the proof is
required I I would be shocked if he
draws and people are saying it's a table
based draw table base draw this position
this is a table-based straw wow
it's hard to believe
do I believe these people is the chat
ever right well I'm trying to look also
the player's Expressions because dubov
doesn't look distraught like he did
earlier but I wouldn't say he's looking
like he knows for a fact this is a draw
easy table based draw why are they even
thinking that's right
so I'm just looking at a table based
draw or I I think White's gonna win
well in the candidates right didn't
Maxime have a draw for a bit against
Fabiano but it was such a difficult
position yeah
and yes Banker was thinking but he only
has a minute and 25 seconds and counting
down
so how to win this I like King E3
I mean if it's a table based draw you
can't win it yeah play it wow I'm
surprised this is a draw
very surprised
there probably are many ways to go wrong
for black though yeah I would I would
expect Victory here and I would be
shocked if it was a draw like if I was
playing but now I wouldn't because the
table base said so the table based knows
all which is actually true
and I mean what a disappointing finishes
would be for jessupenco if he can't
convert
um
dubov
is hovering
looked like he was gonna play Knight
D4
he did I think I think the knights on D4
and I'm guessing 94 somehow loses you
know that's how table base works you
have one way to draw you make a normal
looking move and everyone's like oh you
lost
um
now he'll play Knight E6 I guess and I'm
looking at the chat everyone's saying
King F6 only move to draw so this is now
losing oh Knight D4 lost and King F6
Drew yeah so actually 96 there's just
Rook 8 probably and then rookie five
check I think once you
get your Rook actually 96 does Rook G6
win
I guess you can play King D5 yeah Knight
C2
what what let's see too
what is the Alaska over there trying to
draw King and Knight against Rick and
Pawn Yeah
surprise me
uh what if I ask of King
King D3 let's see two wow
yeah where's that night going I don't
know
yeah you can't play Knight D4 I guess
you can because you have 96. oh the Jeep
ones yeah so yeah maybe after King D3
plays Knight D4 and after it takes King
F4 and he's trying to do a last or
Laster
all right so give me the exact move over
here yeah King D3 Knight D4 Knight D4 a
d yeah so rookette
uh yeah if you take then King F4 is my
idea
and then input with the Knights
somewhere yeah yeah
it's Lasker Alaska all over again yeah
that that's a draw
that's a known draw but I'm not gonna
take on G5 then but I assume that was
his idea I'll play Rook f8 and then
you're so mean
never claimed to be nice yeah
so let's go back to the live position I
like Rick f8 I like that
money
weird situation this game has seen
yeah maybe he's just trying to check the
king away from the king's side give up
his Jeep one and try to get the king and
Knights of block cave while the king's
far away
you you know what's going to be
interesting about this is if Jessica
does win this game it seems like he
should be winning now I don't think
dubov's gonna be upset about not drawing
because he's probably going to be like
oh yeah I was so lost that you know I
shouldn't have had a chance even if it
was a table based draw nobody can do it
yeah it's harder to draw than win
you got to play accurately forever
so what's the move here King D3 looks
right King D3 has to be played I mean it
just looks so obvious
how do you not play King D3 he's gonna
play King D3
well let's go back to Shanklin
is that shanklin's game it is shanklin's
game wow Shanklin got his King over to
C7 okay so I mean that to me that should
be winning
should be winning it should be to me it
is because the the Pawn's not dangerous
the engine says it's equal but the
Pawn's not dangerous and white just has
bad Pawns right but let's say I trade
Knights and even if I lose my C Pawn are
you really going to win that position
why not I like winning by the way uh 25
seconds for white oh well that's making
shanklin's life you gotta defend all
three pawns and no but with the King on
C7 white White's got nothing
before I was like slightly worried the
seed Pawn would get dangerous now I'm
not worried about that
so what movie you just play
this is very hard to hold for white even
if it is holdable because yeah a little
time on his clock and three isolated
pawns the Black Knight has F5 the sedan
C3 moves Knight has D5 okay but Bishop
on E3 stuck defending all these Pawns
Knight F5 Bishop F2
yeah no I'm just saying this is this is
just unpleasant for for white as my turn
to sneeze in the truth
your turn to what sneezing the truth oh
yeah that's right
bless you thank you
he played Knight F5 don't play my move
Sam no no
play Robert's moves 905 looks very good
yeah
Sam seems super duper confident
this is a great uh comment Shanklin
looks like he knows he wins but doesn't
know how just yet yeah it's amazing
between was 40 and 45 if you told
Shanklin he could have this position
with his opponent having less than a
minute
he would be very pleased
absolutely
and
where's what supervised gonna do here
is Knight takes E3 really a threat
probably
Bishop D2 yeah I thought he played
Bishop D2 that surprised me
you just want to keep F4 defended yeah
a rook B3 like pinning everything
oh my gosh I blundered I didn't see 95
check but then I realized that's the
queen blunder yeah
no 95 is bad because he takes defense
because you have 194 check your blunders
are always good
your blunder is always win I did not
intend to make it I'm just trying to pin
the Knight but oh
this is mine
oh
I'm gonna refreshed
you did play Rook B3 I can see it
yeah Sam's gonna win you know it and I
know it
just human Vibe doesn't know it he might
know it too he might know too he's like
man I got no time this game is not going
my way my opponent looks too confident
what happened in my beautiful position
yeah it's psychologically it's crushing
because he knows he was in the driver's
seat
now he knows he's in trouble and has no
time right he probably thought when he
played Bishop D2 that he couldn't play
Rook B3 he probably didn't see the
Knight D4 when he played it wait a quick
question is he still taking notation
because he has to you have to 30 second
income he is yeah okay no I saw him like
you know whatever he was doing yeah you
see oh he's a lefty he's a lefty right
yeah
also I think I think granddelius is a
lefty when he was playing Jeffrey
well I saw this it looks like a piece of
paper there right on the right side over
the oh I don't know what that stuff is
there's a lot of stuff there yeah
I don't know why we have a close of his
hair I mean he's looking like he's been
here today gone tomorrow he's been
through a very pulling out his hair it's
tough game what happened in the other
game the esta panko is that still table
based winner table based draw
um I demand the answers only the chat
knows it's true they know very quickly
the chat's like oh table base I got that
they just know how to look it up they're
good at that
so I'll pull that one what are the table
bases saying guys all right we have that
game on the smaller board there uh
looks like a win to me
with no analysis that's the best I can
do
yeah it looks really good
somebody said 97 draws
um somebody else said it it's a dragon
this is a draw it's what was played
um
then all the people on the internet if
you can call them people they're gonna
say why they play so bad in the ending
draw Win draw Win draw Win that's
because you have table bases and they
don't
in fact probably like you know 50 years
ago they probably would have thought
everybody played great
that's true and Taylor races are like
nope you all play terrible
and
I mean the engine says that white can
draw this position the Shanklin game but
less than a minute all the pawns are
weak I don't believe it do you think
that Shanklin will trade Rooks here no
so what Rook B2 Rook B2 yeah yeah
in King F3 Maybe
how do you win I see that you're better
I'm not going to deny that how does
black actually play for a win
yeah I want to play bishop f8 and take
that pawn even if it loses I still want
to do it
I mean I can gang up on it you know Rook
C2 Bishop f8 right you might win my f
Paul you might play Knight G5 yeah
that's what I would aim for
okay so we have a dubov and yessa panko
here it looks like let's go to that game
real quick
and King D6
Knight E5 probably only move and after
Rook f8 check there's Knight F7 block
and check and then nice and go to H6 and
the G4 Pawn is gonna be in trouble
that's right we are slacking not knowing
the table base terrible
we're just the worst unequivocally yeah
you know I I talked to uh Ken Thompson
at Google about
nine years ago
um I was visiting a friend at Google and
it wasn't even tall chocolate although I
did see him there and he said he thinks
the eight piece table bases will be done
in 20 years and that was about nine ten
years ago
so maybe he's right
still got half a decade left then yeah
we got we got time yeah
so I mean this looks like black playing
King G7 Knight H6 and now I can see
exactly why Black's holding
oh yes panko
it's probably very very frustrated
that's why you never resign
you always fight to the very end because
everybody is a good idea King D5
so yeah King G7 9h6 The Rook has to
defend the pawn
and the King can't cross back on the
fourth rank that's the big problem as
well
so black is just like Knight H6 King F6
King G7 just hang out
mm-hmm
for the people in the chat all the king
upon things are draws so this you could
almost never win the king upon ending
you gotta get Black's King the E7 D7 C7
when it's on G7 you're not winning those
King upon endings nope
because if you take the Jeep one it's
still a draw
and here in 986 takes care of everything
because 96 Rook A4 to defend the pawn
and King F6 and you just can't make
progress your king can't come back to
defend the pawn and otherwise Black's
King can just sort of stay in this box
here
wow what a turn of events
[Music]
so by the way Shanklin did trade Rooks
wow
and Jessica actually looks
like he knows for a fact this is a draw
he is not
oh he's oh yeah he's choking on his own
rage yeah he's really sad
this is quite the opposite of how he
looked when he beat Magnus where he was
like a kid in the candy store so happy
he looks like you know he he recognizes
what's happened here he's he's yeah one
of the things that separates the super
GM's from barely a GM like me is the the
fighting when you're losing and and we
saw that when Jeffrey lost to grandelius
at 100 moves
Jeffrey was like always playing the best
move in this really tough position and
he really forced Neils to play perfectly
and actually there was a position when
it was Queen two versus queen that it
was a draw
um with Queen e4check instead of Queen
H5 check but that was at the beginning
of the end game
but yeah if you keep fighting and
fighting and fighting your opponent can
make a mistake
hard to play Perfect chess every single
move and we've seen that here and looks
like jumab and Shanklin let's go yeah
let's have a look at that okay Queens
are off the board I see Queens Brooks
pardon me are off the board and that's a
nice kick on D5 what what is 98 when he
played 98 it looked like the way he
played it it looked like he had no time
left also it says 15 seconds which so he
had five seconds left when he played it
looked like he played it in a rush it's
30 second increments so 30 second
increment yeah 15. man yeah there's a
wonder he played it so fast relay issue
yeah
so
Knight E8 that's this looks really bad
Knight G2 and the C pawn and the F Pawn
right
but why 98 I'm just confused about that
couldn't the knife on F7 just attack a
bishop
that was way more natural to me than
putting my name
on E8
[Music]
okay well yeah he's suffering
yeah Sam looks too confident
man the guy's hair is going crazy he's
pulling his hair out
yes it's a bad hair day
all right so King takes C5 has he moved
why did it move I saw him physically
move I just don't know where he moved
Knight C7
um
oh that can't be good
I mean probably Sam's winning with
perfect play now he's E5 comes to mind
that pawn on oh wait if I remember
Bishop A3
check
so now it's thinking C6 yeah King C6
wins doesn't it
yes well
oh this could be one of those positions
where eventually you're able to
sacrifice a piece for some stuff so you
have to
I'm guessing Sam can meet with bishop
and I a played E5
definitely
a good choice can make a bishop a night
yeah pretty positive piece
more than capable of doing that mm-hmm
yeah he's just playing on the increment
now and his position's bad from a buy of
you got no time and his position is
falling apart yeah
man I've been there it's the most fun
you can have except for one thing
um I'm not gonna ask I'm not gonna ask
yeah I always feel bad for the players
when
something bad happens and the whole game
is destroyed I just
I don't like that like when granddelius
allowed Bishop E5 and against Jeffrey
and he was I mean
he's so upset I think the problem in a
way in our you know GM brains is that we
then say Oh that person didn't really
deserve to win which isn't entirely fair
to the player who wins but I get that
same sort of bias where if someone is
just worse like much much worse and then
somehow wins weight later in the game
I'm like there's no way they should have
won their position was terrible but
credit to Sam for this is obviously
winning because Knight G2 is going to be
really annoying
yes it's gonna be really annoying Knight
G2 looks like yeah it's it's there's
good and there's not good that's not
good and then probably like E4 check and
Knight G2 wins too
do you think we're gonna fist pump from
Shanklin
no
you mean like shaking hands or being
like yeah yeah like an enthusiastic like
yeah I just won this game with black
yeah he's probably ashamed
foreign
I uh
yeah Knight G2 though is just yeah but I
mean if you defend well you get rewarded
yeah as we're seeing in all the games I
mean Sam was worse and he blockaded he
didn't give up he tried hard and now
he's gonna win and who else did we see
piorron had a tough position early on
but yeah and Esther panko's probably not
going to win I mean
it's hard it's hard to win
everybody's tough
and wow these two yeah Sam's too
confident he said he looked at him he
looked at Juma bio yeah
they both know what's up
the kingdom Pond ending is an easy win
if it happens Two Against One
right if they trade everything on F4
it's just an easy win
unless white gets in King G5 now even if
he gets in King G5 he's losing oh it
depends
he plays King G5 and H4 and the blood
yeah then
yeah so some of them were some of them
are drawn but not the ones they're gonna
get
it yeah just take on that four right
Bishop takes F4
um
King D6 is a funny blunder because they
take a check
and black might still win but it's still
funny yeah probably are still winning
yeah this is this is like the game that
uh Mama jarov lost
to um macharosian
very similar
and you know Sam has the time so he
might as well be accurate he did make a
move he took anything took the bishop
yeah
King D6 resigns yeah
yeah you won this game no that's the
that's the that's the best Knight E3
that's the simplest
yep I'm waiting for the handshake and
then the head shake of disbelief from
Shanklin of like how in the world did I
win that not the head shake from his
opponent how did I lose this yeah but I
I expected more from the side that
that one
man I'd be really dejected if I was
white losing that position after I knew
40. right wow
and
and dream about just sort of playing
some moves trying to
probably shake off the upset just you
know he's going to be devastated and he
hits the black pieces against Shanklin I
mean beating Shanklin with any color is
hard but good luck
yeah Shanklin hasn't lost any games in
the slow chest
I thought he was going to lose today
until he until he won
it's always a good time to resign
[Laughter]
saying it's not too early
somewhere yeah not too early now
and
what's the Thought right here
what was the last move played by Sam
Bishop G5 just you know and it's not
resigning
oh and there's he got his King back to
F3 so his Rook was free okay yes the
panko game
pull that up real quick that's the panko
looks very unhappy yes it's just a draw
the you know the king is stuck and you
need two pieces to run in this game yeah
sacrificing his Pawn
I like it he's gonna win King and Rook
versus King and Knight except for one
thing he won't win right
Knight takes G4 King F5 just Knight back
to H6 check
and
easy draw for two ball
it's funny when I was in Ann Arbor I was
at the chess club and I was probably
like 12 or 13. it's one of the Masters
there was telling us how like even in
the worst positions King and Knight can
often draw against Iraq he like set up
the worst position you could imagine
he's like this is a draw
like the king in the night in the back
Rank and you know some of those are
winning but a lot of them are drawn yeah
and well this uh yeah it's hard to lose
it's like the easiest you have like Rook
at night against Rook rook and Bishop
against Rook Rook against Bishop Rook
against Knight like this is like the
easiest Rook against Knight right this
is you just can't win yeah no rook and
Bishop against Rook is really difficult
oh yeah and you might win yeah yeah
working night against her because they
draw but sometimes they win it sometimes
people wonder
even at the top level but yeah working
against tonight nobody's ever won unless
it was already winning
if it was yeah and they just yeah
yeah he didn't yeah he just took the
night
it fed up oh gosh you see that
oh man look at him oh wow that's pretty
upset yeah that's more upset than I
think he should be
oh well I mean he just you know his head
just fell to the board wow yeah that's
not good
I hope he's able to recover for
tomorrow's game because you know he's
got the black piece of short against
duboff was great but yeah the match is
still very much anyone's for the taking
but the agony of the egg the agony of
drawing yeah new mantra there saying
yeah I've had two Grandmasters basically
cry at the board against me and it
wasn't because I beat them or I played
better than them they both made really
bad one-move wonders
I mean really bad and then when I
responded that I mean they were they
couldn't vote I mean
like really bad bloggers yeah that
wasn't a really bad blunder that was
just you know he didn't win
yeah he should have won for sure and
yeah there wasn't like one move and it
was the worst move ever but
and it looks like I think Ferdinand
hellers quit chess because I beat him
he he blundered a piece to some trick I
moved like 14 with white he was white
yeah he put his head down and shook his
head for a minute
and then he we played on and eventually
I won and he didn't he quit chess
eventually became an attorney
so yeah he was really unhappy
you know who's really happy Sam Shanklin
oh yeah
this is the most fun you can have that's
why you resign because it's too much fun
for your opponent
oh gosh look at you yeah he's like I
can't believe I'm losing this is
ridiculous yeah yeah he's like how did I
lose that position
yeah
exactly how he feels he looks Frozen and
then some yeah
yeah poor guy
one day you're beating Fabiano caruana
the next day you're better at winning
and you'll lose
foreign
[Music]
not complete 180 but against Bobby I
don't have the opening his position did
not look very good but he was able to uh
do on the tax and there's a result all
right there's the handshake
let's see who's more upset
I I guess it's uh Jewel five yeah
yeah he's getting out of here
the Arbiters like can't you do this
paperwork and Drew by was like leave me
alone
nobody ever wants to do yeah let me get
out of here and of course in the shot of
the camera as well
and wow what a turnaround that game was
because Juma Baya was
really in charge for
the majority of the game and then
something sort of Switched and he
couldn't quite keep up the
hole to the position so a win for Sam
Shanklin a huge victory for the American
player and you know you look at the
final position of course he won but Ben
I mean if we go to move what was it even
I think anytime between 40 and 45 yeah
just like this position is clearly good
for white
um just
one upon an A6 to lose this position
I could do it but
I didn't I didn't think uh Drew mobile
could do it but I could do it I got no
problem losing this position wow yeah
and just good fight by Shanklin uh
making it so that Juma bias pieces
couldn't coordinate the way he wanted to
and I guess from here it was all
Shanklin just every move sort of
improved his position to the point where
it was right here and he played your H4
idea yeah right there that worked out
well for him
I wonder Ben if he also didn't make the
switch in his mind that maybe I
shouldn't be playing for a win anymore
because
H4 seems so natural for black and just
ruins White's Pawn structure and he was
shuffling around and just allowed it to
happen
I I I just feel bad for him I feel bad
for all these guys when something really
bad happens because you it's really hard
to recover there's it's a two game match
right and this is happening in a lot of
matches where looks like you're winning
looks like you're drawing and then you
make a move when you're out of the
tournament
that's it's very frustrating because
it's rare and I pointed this out
yesterday I think it was yesterday
in you know if you play tennis you
always get knocked out if you lose
that's the way tennis is in chess you
lose then you get paired with me and you
win I mean it's not you know it's not
like you know Robert Hess is like man
I'm having a bad Church oh I'm playing
Ben next round great and this tournament
not good and you actually think it's
very awkward from a social standpoint
because you're used to playing in Swiss
tournaments as you're saying you have
the same people with you for all nine or
11 rounds or however many it is but in
this knockout format you just your
friends maybe going home the next day
and then you're kind of on your own and
it's also weird not knowing when you're
leaving right because it's probably not
weird in the sports where that happens
like in golf after the second day either
you're done or you're not they know that
and in tennis they know that they could
get knocked out any round but in chess
it's weird you're like I'm done I have
to go home I mean half the players go
home after round one because
it's crazy it is crazy this event has
been crazy but Ben you and I are going
to take a break from Return we may be
joined by a guest for an interview that
would be awesome but if not we'll just
wrap up the show but we're not going to
be around that once yeah I mean who
wants to join us right but stay tuned
everybody for the finish of this
broadcast by chess.com of the few day
World Cup and the feed Day Women's World
Cup
[Music]
foreign
thank you
we have special guest Grandmaster Sam
Shanklin from the US joining us Sam
congrats on what was a really
hard-fought game
oh yeah thank you first of all Robert
it's great to see you I didn't get to
say hi while you were here but yeah
thanks I um I was uh very fortunate to
win I'm not supposed to win it of course
but a big part of playing good chess is
defending resourcefully when he
overpressed I I took my chance
yeah what was your mindset like during
the game because at one point you were
down upon uh you were trying to blockade
and at what moment Did you sort of think
I can actually try to win this game
rather than just hold
yeah so when he took A6 my suspicion is
I'm lost uh but I think in the few moves
Before Time control who screwed it up uh
once Queen A3 Queen B it was on the
board already here I think I have enough
counter play it's a at least make a game
out of it during the game I didn't even
know if I was worse anymore but uh
basically at some point he started
repeating with Queen A4 Queen C4 and I
thought we were just making a draw there
and when he declined the draw not only
did he decline the drop he played Knight
F1 instead of Knight D1 I was already
starting to wonder and then once I
played H4 at this point I mean when I if
I don't play H4 I think I'm fine but
once I played H4 I thought it's a three
result game and then very quickly I
managed to get a nice ending with um him
having the three isolated pawns I still
believe that should be a draw but it's a
difficult defense for why he didn't have
much time and I managed to scoop him up
everything you said is like stuff we
were saying during the game I think
you're spot on with with what you
thought and what the engines thought and
you know it's funny we were looking at
two games at once your game in esta
panko's game and we went with no idea
look at your game we went to ask the
Panko and we came back and your king was
on C7 from like G8 and I was like well
Sam's gonna win now I mean yeah the
white then white just has bad pawns the
engine didn't say you were winning I
said no no he's gonna win because why
can't defend this with no time on his
clock yeah that was good running your
king over and it was really good that
you we knew I knew when you played H4
you'd probably win because we were
worried you would just play for a draw
because you know you were losing earlier
but you had the right mindset to play
for the win when with H4 that was great
yeah it reminds me a bit of this uh
playoff match with other shenko where I
was
just totally outplayed in the second
game but when I just when I saw my
chance I had to draw my hand and I just
didn't take it I thought I should keep
fighting
uh it's very easy to just have a
miserable position to defend it while
all of a sudden you see you can save it
and just take your point your half point
that you know you didn't deserve in the
first place and you weren't expecting to
get but you should still be objective
and look if I have chances to push here
I should push I'm glad I did that today
well Sam obviously you're a very strong
player but did that recent match against
arashenko do you think that helped you
in a situation today whereas you're
saying your back was kind of against the
wall but you could then be objective
because you just had this really
hard-fought match that you know what
it's like to be in these stressful
positions it definitely gave me some
confidence that just because my position
was bad I'm not necessarily going to
lose it I mean the rapid game sort of
anything can happen when there's no time
on the clock but the second classical
game with arashenko I was really in bad
shape and it I was sort of expecting to
go home uh that time and uh saving that
position gave me the confidence that it
helped me feel like I'm in good form
again I mean I played a very bad game up
to that point but I thought it was
saying a lot that when I'm playing badly
against so hang on against really strong
guys and so I was very happy that that
happened and I think today it shows as
well I don't think I played it brilliant
game I think I played pretty badly he
outplayed me for for much of the middle
game
I kept fighting I guess
yeah a lot of the players in this
tournament especially the the really
young ones seem pretty underrated and
the way he played against Fabi and the
way he played against you to build up to
the winning position
it doesn't seem like his rating is
correct although the final result but it
just seems like everybody here is tough
and when we had on I guess it was
grishrock he said well cinderov is 25.50
but it actually should be 2700. so a lot
of these people just seem underrated
because you couldn't play feed it rated
chess for so long did you feel that
during the game that man this guy's
pretty good oh yeah I mean I had pledge
remember before and I I knew that he's
there's some things he does extremely
well I mean there's parts of the game
and things that are where I don't
believe I'm a better player despite
being much higher rated and uh but the
things I noticed with him is he can get
into severe time pressure this is the
second time I've played him second time
with black second time I beat him from a
position I was supposed to lose because
he got way low on time and lost some
level of objectivity
um he just strikes me as a guy who does
some things very well but also has some
notable weaknesses the things he does
well he's absolutely amazing and when
he's showing that it really looks like
he's you know just right up there with
any other 2700 guy as for cinderov I
don't know another thing is uh while I
would never question the abilities of
all these young kids who are just
playing absurdly well and whatnot I do
think a big part of it isn't even so
much that they're necessarily playing
better I just think everyone else is
playing worse I think they've been
maintaining their normal their normal
training regimen and even if they're
just maintaining their strengths if you
know the 30 year old guys are all 2700
plus they're all just being lazy and
sitting at home and because they don't
have tournaments to play they don't have
the motivation they don't have the
coaches to force them to work the
parents to force them to work they can
just get really they can really drop a
lot and uh so I think there's multiple
uh facets to it but yeah some of these
guys I mean nihal I know he's gone but
geez he's up like 60 points or something
at Regis like that and he's really
gotten strong well Sam last question
because I know it's getting late in the
preparation to do for tomorrow's match
but you know how about yourself you just
had a great showing before the World Cup
even started so uh you're one of those
30 year olds who are you know above 2700
So how did you keep in shape and what
were you up to because you had the first
place finish in Prague and now you're
performing well here well I think part
of it was just like real funnily enough
2019 was just the worst Year of My Life
by by far so many bad things happened
both my parents got sick my hand got
slashed open my heart got broken I I
didn't get to put the feed at Grand Prix
I played 40 consecutive games against
lower players and watched my rating
played away it was just a really
horrible year and after that like being
stuck at home just felt like a breeze it
was really nothing I I kept up my normal
training I got back into Peak physical
condition the way that you really can't
if you're traveling like crazy I was
really exercising rigorously every day
got to the same kind of fit that I was
when I was like 20 years old
and I think I just started playing the
same as I sort of did in 2018 I think
the big reason I dropped was that my
wife fell apart and then I sort of put
it back together and now I'm just
playing well again and that's uh so I'm
just hopeful that I can keep it up I
think here I have more points than I
deserve but at the same time you know
you never know yeah well congratulations
again on a nice hard-fought Victory and
we're gonna of course cover your games
tomorrow and forward so have a good rest
and we'll see you back at it tomorrow
Sam thanks so much thanks Sam
and you heard it from Sam you know he is
just ready to play he's taking this very
seriously and he's uh just in shape and
both on the board and just making sure
that he's physically in shape and he has
another game tomorrow July 23rd you've
seen the schedule in front of you it's
the fourth round of action and well he
doesn't want to go to tie break he's up
one nothing he has to wipe pieces I have
a hard time envisioning jummabi of
winning with black tomorrow but crazier
things have happened in this very World
Cup yeah you remember Robert
um many World Cups ago when uh Sam beat
uh Peter laco in the first game and
Peter Heather win with black in the
second game and you just got nothing Sam
shut him down right so
he's a tough opponent to play on under
any circumstances but when you're no
longer just focusing on the board but
also the result that's becoming
increasing that was a very objective
analysis of his game I I usually don't
agree with Sam when he talks about his
game I agree with everything yeah that
sounded right yeah yeah I would say that
you know I don't think he was ever
completely lost but he clearly
understood he was in a bad spot I didn't
like his position he fought out of it
and I yeah I actually really like how
yeah kind of very objective yeah and
he's just very blunt about how he saw
his chances he's like you know I think
that's probably why Sam got better I
think when Sam was a you know teenager
in early 20s he wasn't that objective
but now I think he's super objective and
that's you got to be that way if you
want to be 2700 well and he was 27
30-ish at his Peak he dropped a bunch of
ready points 2019 he expressed why that
happened heartbreak just all these games
and slow rated players that he wasn't
able to convert on uh some family
situation but Sam Shanklin is back in
Tip-Top shape he leads heading into the
second game of his fourth round Mansion
Ben what a day it was though not just
Sam I mean just so many interesting
games Catherine bouncing back and
winning so
I I just think that yeah the people who
defended in these bad and or lost
positions a lot of them were rewarded
today
yeah I mean even even uh Jeffrey had a
really good position in Lost and and
Essa panko couldn't win this one
position and this game and as you said
the Casper there was a lot of games that
that changed around move 40. yeah and
also that tab it to buy E5 move where he
sacrificed the pawn and then just didn't
capture upon them that was great that
was a fantastic game by him so he upset
pintala Hari Krishna so so many uh
interesting games we will have more in
store for you tomorrow but for now Ben I
don't know any final thoughts before we
head on out I hope tomorrow is as
exciting as today and it probably will
be because people are going to be in the
must win situation so that's going to be
that's good for chess when you're in a
must win and Magnus is going to have
white tomorrow so he's probably pretty
happy and uh grishek's gonna have white
tomorrow so he's going to press against
corabov so it's it's looking good for
some people and some people better win
tomorrow so and the Russian Derby
between three sets of 2700 plus Russians
kayak and artemia artemio get the white
pieces all the games were draws yeah
they're all draws similar and did you go
we didn't even look at that game but it
was drawn and then of course Essa panko
spoiling a chance against duboff many
great matches but for now we are going
to sign off I want to thank everybody
who's been tuning in and supporting the
channel just loving chess and watching
these matches it really makes it much
more fun to do our jobs our producer
behind the scene make it magic happen
making sure the show goes smoothly of
course the graphics team and all
everyone at chess.com who's been so
helpful and Ben thanks to you buddy I
mean we haven't commentated together for
a long time but it was really a joy yeah
it was great I commented with you before
in St Louis and I want to most of all
thank Danny for taking the day off
thanks Danny I got to work with a real
professional thank you ah well on that
note we will say goodbye so enjoy
yourselves until tomorrow for more from
the feed a World Cup and the fide
Women's World Cup
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]